WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE HEARING
ON CRITICAL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ISSUES RELATED TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS THIS IS
THE ASSEMBLY IS FOR HEARING IN
THE ERA OF PHYSICAL DISTANCING
USING TECHNOLOGY TO TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM PANELIST
REMOTELY AND PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE. WE ARE ALSO
OFFICIALLY RESTARTING ASSEMBLY
SESSION TODAY AND I AM PROUD
THAT THIS IS OUR FIRST HEARING
COMING BACK FROM THE EMERGENCY
LEGISLATIVE RECESS I WANT TO
THANK THE SPEAKER STAFF
ASSEMBLY RULES AND THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER FOR
THEIR HARD WORK FOR CARING AND
FOR CONFIGURING NEW TECHNOLOGY
AND PROCESS AS TO MAKE THIS
HEARING POSSIBLE. I'VE BEEN
ASKED TO READ SOME DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING ANTS TO HELP
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE HERE TODAY WHILE
ALLOWING THE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION. FOR THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE IN THE ROOM TODAY IN
CAPITAL ROOM. FORTY TWO OH TWO.
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING. EVEN
THOUGH THIS ROOM IS THE LARGEST
HEARING ROOM IN THE CAPITOL WE
CAN ONLY A COP ACCOMMODATE
ELEVEN MEMBERS A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE UBLIC
AND MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
SIX FEET APART. THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND EXIT THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE WHO ARE HERE TODAY TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS BUT IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WHICH IS TO SPEAK THEY
WILL PLEASE RAISE THEIR HANDS.
AND I WILL ASK THEM TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. I ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE PUBLIC
COMMENT IS COMPLETE OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON%
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR THE
PANELISTS WHO ARE SPEAKING
TODAY ALL OF YOU ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY TODAVíA WROTE-
TELEPHONIC CONFERENCE CALL.
WITH STAFF ASSISTING SO THAT
THE PANEL CAN CONVERSE WITH THE
MEMBERS HERE IN THE ROOM.
SHOULD WE EXPERIENCE ANY
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WE ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE BE PATIENT
WE'RE ASKING ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS TO TURN OFF THE SOUND
AT THEIR LOCATION AND TO USE
YOUR PHONES IF POSSIBLE TO
REDUCE FEEDBACK. TODAY'S
HEARING AS THOSE THAT HAVE
PRECEDED TODAY'S WILL HELP US
TO MAKE PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
GOAL OF MAKING OUR HEARINGS
EASIER FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE. NOW FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WILL BE DOING REMOTE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BE USING
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION.
THIS NUMBER WAS MADE AVAILABLE
WHEN THE AGENDA WAS POSTED ON
OUR WEBSITE LAST FRIDAY AND
SHOULD ALSO APPEAR ON THE LIVE
STREAM SCREEN DURING PUBLIC
COMMENT. OUR CALL IN NUMBER
TODAY IS. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. PLEASE NOTE THAT YOU
ONLY NEED TO TYPE IN ONE ZERO
ONCE. RE ENTERING THOSE TWO
DIGITS WILL TAKE YOU OUT OF THE
QUEUE SO PLEASE AVOID DOING
THAT. ONCE WERE IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SEGMENT OF TODAY'S
HEARING AN OPERATOR WILL COME
ON TO THE LINE AND YOU WILL
PRIVATELY. BE ASKED YOUR NAME.
SO PLEASE BE PREPARED TO SPEAK
WITH THE OPERATOR AS THIS WILL
FACILITATE WHEN YOU'RE TAPED TO
SPEAK TO THE SUB COMMITTEE.
THOSE WATCHING THIS HEARING
REMOTELY SHOULD KNOW THAT THE
LIVE STREAM HAS A SLIGHT DELAY
FROM THE ACTUAL EVENTS GOING ON
IN THE ROOM BY ABOUT TWENTY
SECONDS. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE INCLUDING YOUR BROADCAST
LIVE STREAM TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. YOU CAN ALSO CALL
THE COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2890
NINE IF YOU ARE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS AND SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF
WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP.
WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS FOR
PANEL TO. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT. FOR WHICH THE
ADDRESSES BUDGET SUB ONE AT ASM
DOT CA DOT GOV. ANY EMAILS WE
RECEIVED BY THE CLOSE OF
BUSINESS TOMORROW MAY FIFTH
WILL BE COMPILED AND SENT TO
ALL MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE AGENDA TODAY
AFTER MY OPENING REMARKS I WILL
WELCOME ALL MEMBERS TO MAKE
OPENING REMARKS. AND THEN WE'LL
TURN TO PANEL ONE. AGAIN
PANELISTS WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
VIA CONFERENCE CALL INTO THIS
HEARING ROOM WHILE WATCHING
THIS LIVE STREAM. PANELISTS
WILL ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE AN
AGENDA ORDER. ONCE PANEL ONE
HAS CONCLUDED WE WILL MAKE
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND DIALOGUE
WITH ALL OF THE PANELISTS.
AFTER THE CONCLUSION OF
QUESTIONS FOR PANEL ONE WE WILL
GO TO PANEL TWO ONE GO THROUGH
THE SAME FORMAT. ANALYSTS WILL
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE AN AGENDA
ORDER AND THEN WE WILL GO ON TO
MEMBERS QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS.
FINALLY ONCE THE MEMBER
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN CONCLUDED
FOR PANEL TO. I WILL OPEN THE
HEARING UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT. I
WILL FIRST TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM THOSE IN THE ROOM AGAIN BY
ASKING YOU TO RAISE YOUR HANDS
AND DIRECTING YOU TO THE MIKE
INDIVIDUALLY. I WILL THEN OPEN
IT UP TO THE PUBLIC ON THE
PHONE. NOW I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
OUR COMMITTEE CONSULTANT PLEASE
TO CALL THE ROLL. RIGHT
ARAMBULA PRESENT. FRAZIER
RATHER. MATHIS PATTERSON RAMOS
YOUR RUBIO HERE WOULD HERE.
WITHOUT A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. I'D LIKE TO START
BY SAYING THAT OUR STATE IS
FACING UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES
AND AS WE COPE WITH THE COPAY
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND ALL OF
THE SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND FISCAL
EFFECTS OF THE AND EMPLOYMENT
CRISIS THAT IT HAS CREATED. AS
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
THE PAST FOUR YEARS IT HAS BEEN
AN HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE TO
SERVE THIS STATE AND BE A PART
IN THE EFFORTS WE'VE TAKEN
SINCE THE GREAT RECESSION TO
RESTORE AND IMPROVE OUR SAFETY
NET. TO EXTEND HEALTH CARE AND
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND SERVICES
TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES IN OUR GREAT
STATE. NOW WE ABRUPTLY FIND
OURSELVES IN THIS NEW MOMENT OF
TREMENDOUS NEEDS FOR OUR NEWLY
DISPLACED WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WE SEE SHARP
INCREASES IN APPLICATIONS FOR
OUR PUBLIC INCOME SUPPORT AND
BENEFITS PROGRAMS. LINES OF
HUNGRY FAMILIES ARE WAITING
OUTSIDE OF FOOD BANKS. EVEN
WITH THE FEDERAL STIMULUS
CHECKS AND EXPANDED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE WHICH
AREN'T UNIVERSAL BENEFITS. FULL
AREN'T ABLE TO PAY THEIR RENT
AND THERE IS SERIOUS CONCERN
ABOUT AN ADDICTION CRISIS THAT
COULD COME UPON US ONCE THE
<c.blue>VICTION PREVENTION ORDERS LEFT.</c>
SO WHAT IS OUR ROLE HERE IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ARENA.
I THINK IT IS TO DEFINE AND TO
FRAME HOW THE SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS FIT INTO THIS COBIT
PICTURE AND THE BUDGET
GRAPPLING WITH ECONOMIC
RECESSION. IT IS MY MOTTO TODAY
AND WILL BE FOR AS LONG AS WE
ARE IN THIS FIGHT THAT HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES ARE INTEGRAL
TO THE COUNTER RECESSION
EFFORT. AND TO UNDERMINE THEM
DURING THIS TIME THREATENS TO
ELONGATE AND DEEPEN OUR
ECONOMIC TROUBLES. TODAY WE
WILL HEAR FROM STATE LEADERS
ACROSS CRITICAL PROGRAMS
STAKEHOLDERS WHO REPRESENT
SIGNIFICANT PARTS OF OUR SAFETY
NET FABRIC ANDYOU THE PUBLIC
WHOM WE ALL SERVE. FOR THE
HEALTH PANEL WERE FOCUSING ON
THE DIRE NEED TO REBUILD OUR
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
RECOGNIZING THAT HEALTHCARE IS
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT OF
OUR ECONOMY. AND THAT OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY DEPENDS ON.
FOR THE HUMAN SERVICES PANEL
WERE ASKING HOW ARE PUBLIC
PROGRAMS ARE RESPONDING. HOW
THEY ARE WORKING AND WHAT
TROUBLE AREAS AND CHALLENGES WE
NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF AS TIME
GOES ON. MY GOAL IS TO PARTNER
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WITH AVID ADVOCATES TO BUILD
THE FLEXIBILITY AND PROGRAM
CHANGES THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
AUTHORIZED INTO OUR BUDGET
PLAN. EXTENDING THOSE POLICIES
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE TO DO SO
STRENGTHENING OUR ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO FAMILIES IN NEED.
ALLEVIATE SUFFERING AND TO
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS. I ALSO
WANT TO HEAR ABOUT LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION APPROACHES THAT WE
REGRET AND NEED TO AVOID. THE
CHANGES MADE AND THAT TIME OR
DRAMATIC AND WE STILL HEAR
ABOUT THE REMAINING DAMAGE THAT
IS STILL ON ADDRESSED. I WANT
TO ALSO BRIEFLY ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE ISSUES WE HAVE
SELECTED TO DISCUSS TODAY ARE
JUST TWO OF MANY URGENT
CRITICAL HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT OF THIS
CRISIS. SADLY WE DO NOT HAVE
THE HEARING TIME AND SPACE TO
ADDRESS ALL OR EVEN A FEW OF
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING OUR
STATE. NEVER THE LESS THE LAB
LEGISLATURE IS EVERY BIT AS
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE OTHER
ISSUES INCLUDING THE NURSING
HOME CRISIS THE URGENT NEED TO
BUILD OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE.
AND MANY OTHER HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ISSUES. AND IS WORKING
ON THESE CHALLENGES OUTSIDE OF
OUR VERY LIMITED HEARING
PROCESS. FINALLY I WANT TO
EMBRACE ALL OF THE IMPORTANT
LESSONS THAT WE'VE LEARNED IN
THE LAST DECADE. ABOUT THE
DAMAGING EFFECTS OF POVERTY ON
CHILDREN AND THEIR BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT. ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND HOW THEY SHAPE
A LIFE TRAJECTORY INCOME
INEQUALITY AND THE INABILITY
FOR FAMILIES TO WORK FULL TIME
AND STILL PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES. GIVEN OUR COST OF
LIVING. ABOUT OUR HEALTH
DISPARITIES WHICH ALONG RACIAL
AND ETHNIC LINES AND ABOUT THE
RAVAGES OF HOMELESSNESS AND HOW
THAT INCREASING ACROSS OUR
STATE. ABOUT HOW ALL OF US ARE
LINKED TOGETHER AND NEED TO
ASSURE THAT WE TAKE CARE OF ONE
ANOTHER DURING THIS CURRENT
STORM. NO MATTER WHAT. NOW I'D
LIKE TO OPEN THIS UP FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO MAKE OPENING REMARKS
BEFORE WE START OUR FIRST PANEL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WILL BE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM I THINK-
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY COME BACK AND START
WORKING ON SOME OF THE CRITICAL
ISSUES I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IN THIS COURSE THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE FOR MAKING THIS POSSIBLE
I KNOW IT'S NOT GOING TO BE A
VERY DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING
BUSINESS BUT I THINK IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE HERE TO
START THINKING ABOUT WHAT ABOUT
A GREAT CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
AHEAD SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE-
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO. SOME WORK I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE TOUGH BUT I
THINK THAT IF WE ARE TRULY
TOGETHER WE CAN ACCOMPLISH MANY
THINGS AND HOPEFULLY GET
OURSELVES AND THE STATE AND
AGAIN THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION I DON'T WANT TO I
KNOW IS TO COME SO THANK YOU
AND AM HAPPY TO SEE YOU MY
COLLEAGUES AND HAPPY TO SEETHE
STAFF AT BUT I KNOW THAT- THESE
ARE TRYING TIMES AND I THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND- ECHO
YOUR- REMARKS FOR THE SPEAKER
LEGISLATURE AND EVERYONE THAT'S
CONTINUING TO MOVE FORWARD HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
AS WE DISCUSS THE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO- LOOK AT AND GET
RESOURCES FOR THOSE THAT ARE
OUT THERE SUFFERING- WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WITH
SUICIDE PREVENTION- WE SEEN UP
TO- DURING THIS TIME IN COVERT
NINETEEN OF THOSE SEEKING THOSE
SERVICES ON THROUGH THE
COUNTIES AND THROUGH THE STATE
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT IS PART OF THE DIALOGUE
AND ALSO AS WE TALK ABOUT- THE
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ADDING A VOICE TO
THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN-
POPULATION HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT SUFFERS- HIGH
RATES OF DIFFERENT ILLNESSES-
THAT ARE UNDERLYING ISSUES- FOR
THE MAJOR POPULATIONS AND
WORKING TO ENSURE IN HEARING
IDEAS OF HOW- COUNTIES THE
STATE ARE REACHING OUT TO
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND VICE
VERSA MAKING SURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE. WE KNOW
THAT. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES-
EDUCATION ALL THOSE AREAS THAT
HERE IN AND HEALTH AND SUB ONE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. AS
THE PRESENTERS COME FORWARD
THAT THAT STAYS IN THEIR MIND
AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS- CERTAINLY THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND WITH THAT I WILL BEGIN OUR
FIRST PANEL. THERE ARE A
CLUSTER OF QUESTIONS ON THE
AGENDA THAT DESCRIBE THE FOCUS
OF EACH PANEL. PRIOR TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN CRISIS
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE STRATEGIES WERE
SEVERE AND WIDELY RECOGNIZED.
YET NOW WE FACE THE IRONY THAT
THE PANDEMIC HAS BROUGHT OUR
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE TO ITS
KNEES. WE ALL COLLECTIVELY HAVE
DONE SUCH AN EFFECTIVE JOB OF
SHELTERING IN PLACE. AVOIDING
ANY AND ALL NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL CARE AND OF EMPTYING
OUR HOSPITALS SO THAT WE COULD
RESPOND TO A SURGE IN COVERT
NINETEEN CASES SIMILAR TO NEW
YORK CITY. THAT WE HAVE
EFFECTIVELY DISMANTLED OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. WE MUST
FIND WAYS TO BRING IT BACK TO
PROTECT OUR HEALTH OF COURSE.
BUT ALSO TO RESTORE OUR ECONOMY.
I NOW WANT TO ASK AN OPERATOR
TO OPEN THE LINE SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR FROM PANEL ONE WITH BEN
JOHNSON OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE ASKED THE
LA- TO SUMMARIZE THE REPORTS
WE'VE RECEIVED FROM THE MAJOR
HEALTH CARE SECTORS. LEAVING
OUR HOSPITALS AND DOCTORS SINCE
THOSE SECTORS ARE RIPPED
REPRESENTED ON OUR PANEL. ON
THE IMPACTS OF THE KOBE CRISIS
ON THEIR RESPECTIVE WORKFORCES.
THEN. HI BEN JOHNSON FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
PLEASE LET ME KNOW IT BY COME
THROUGH ON CLEAR AT AT ANY TIME
DURING THIS CALL- GOOD MORNING
TO THE CHAIR AND TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US TO TESTIFY HERE- AS
DR CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA NOTED
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO- PRESENT ON
HOW THE CODE NINETY CRISIS IS
AFFECTING THE STATE'S HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS AND ITS WORK
FORCE- THE LEGISLATURE HAS
RECEIVED THESE RECORDS AND
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO SUMMARIZE
PERSPECTIVES BEFORE DIVING INTO
THE SUBSTANCE OF OUR MARCH
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
IS AN EVER EVOLVING SITUATION-
WHERE THE IMPACT ON PROVIDERS
COULD CHANGE SIGNIFICANTLY
WITHIN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
MOREOVER WE FOUND HARD DATA ON
THE FISCAL AND PROGRAMMATIC
IMPACT OF CODE NINETEEN HARD TO
COME BY AND SO IN THE TIME THAT
WE HAD TO PREPARE FOR THAT
HEARING OUR OFFICE WITH NOT
ABLE TO INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY
THE REPORTING OF PROVIDERS AND
AS SUCH WE GET THE EMPHASIZE
THAT WE ARE NOT MAKING LA-
FINDINGS BUT RATHER REPORTING
THE PERSPECTIVES OF THE.
VARIOUS PROVIDER GROUPS. NOW
TURN. SUMMARIZE IT ALLOW HIGH
LEVEL THE XP OF PROVIDERS UNDER
COBRA NINETEEN HOW THE
EMERGENCY IS AFFECTING THEIR
FINANCIAL BOTTOM LINE. AND HOW
SUCH FINANCIAL IMPACT
ULTIMATELY AFFECTING THE WORK
FORCE. FIRST WE OBSERVE WE'RE
HEARING THAT PROVIDERS ARE
HAVING INCREASED COSTS AS A
RESULT OF IN NINETEEN- BOTHAS
A RESULT OF HIGHER COSTS FOR
PERSONAL. PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT-
FROM PRICE INCREASES AND THE
NEED FOR GREATER SUPPLIES AND
THEY'RE ALSO REPORTING HIGHER
STAFFING COSTS YOU DO NEED TO
PAY OVERTIME HIRING OUTSIDE
CONTRACTORS STAFF AND IN SOME
CASES IN HIGH RISK AREAS.
PAYING HAZARD PAY NURSING HOMES
ARE A PRIME EXAMPLE OF-
PROVIDED TIGHT THAT IS FACING
SUCH HIGHER COSTS. AND THEN
FINALLY PROVIDERS ARE MAKING
NEW INVESTMENTS TO HELP THEM
ADAPT TO THE CHANGING SERVICES
ENVIRONMENT SUCH OF MODIFYING
FACILITIES TO ALLOW FOR GREATER
ISOLATION OF POTENTIALLY
INFECTIOUS PATIENTS. AND
EXPANDING THEIR TELEHEALTH AND
VIRTUAL HEALTH CAPABILITIES. ON
THE PATIENT VOLUME AND REVENUE
SIDE PROVIDERS ARE REPORTING A
FAIRLY DIRE SITUATION YOU'LL
HEAR FROM PHYSICIANS AND
HOSPITALS LATER ON THIS PANEL
WHO CAN SHARE THEIR EXPERIENCE.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM HEALTH
CENTERS WHO ARE REPORTING- THAT
THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT LAUGHLIN REVENUE AS
A RESULT OF PATIENT VISITS
BEING DOWN BY 4250% COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
DEDICATED THAT EVEN NURSING
FACILITIES AS WELL HEY THERE
THE REDUCED VOLUME OF SERVICES.
AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE
IN THE CASE OF DENTISTRY SURVEY
DATA COLLECTED BY DENTISTS
GROUP CHAU DENTAL SERVICES
VOLUMES BEING DOWN BY UPWARDS
OF NINETY PERCENT. WITH THE
ONLY EMERGENCY DENTAL SERVICES
CONTINUING RALLY TO OCCUR. IN
SOME STATE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
MAY BE LOOKING AT REVENUE
LOSSES IN THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- AND GROWING AS THE
EMERGENCY CONTINUES. HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS HAVE TAKEN A AND
TAKING A NUMBER OF MEASURES TO
RESPOND TO THIS SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN UTILIZATION AND
REVENUE SUCH AS BY TEMPORARY
CLOSING OR LIMITING THEIR HOURS
OF OPERATION. AND THAT WHILE
SUCH THAT CAN AT LEAST ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS. BRING PROVIDER
COSTS AND REVENUES AND THE
CLOSER ALIGNMENT THE FACT THAT
MANY PROVIDERS HAVE FIXED COSTS
IN THE FORM OF LOANS AND LEASES
FOR THE OFFICE SPACE AND
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT MEANS THAT
SUCH MEASURES MAY ARE ONLY
TEMPORARILY HE IS THE THAT
REALLY CHIEF FINANCIAL STRAIN.
OF THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
SPECIFICALLY WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY ARE EXPERIENCING FURLOUGHS
AND LAYOFFS BOTH ON THE
CLINICAL AND THE NON CLINICAL
SIDE OF THE WORK FORCE. AND BUT
FOR THOSE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
CONTINUING TO OPERATE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT- THAT WORK
WORKERS ARE SOMETIMES RECEIVING
THOSE OVERTIME PAYMENTS THE
HOUSE ARE PAY AND WE'VE ALSO
<c.red>EARD OF PROVIDERS MAKING</c>
ARRANGEMENTS FOR CHILD CARE SO
THAT WORKERS CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK- DESPITE THE. SCHOOLS
BEING CLOSE. MEASURES HAVE BEEN.
BY PUBLIC IN PRIVATE AND TO
BEGIN TO ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. FOR EXAMPLE
THERE BEEN NEW FEDERAL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES- CONGRESS HAS
PASSED A SERIES OF LEGISLATION
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN- AMERICAN CITY AND
THESE PIECES OF FEDERAL
LEGISLATION AND INCLUDED
APPROPRIATIONS SPECIFICALLY
AIMED AT HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
THE LARGEST SOURCE OF DIRECT
FEDERAL FUNDING HERE FOR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS GIVES A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
APPROPRIATED THROUGH THE CARE
EXACT AN INITIAL ROUND OF THIS
FUNDING HAVE GONE OUT WITH HELD
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS RECEIVING NEARLY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS. IN
RELIEF. THIS FUNDING WE BELIEVE
WILL HELP PROVIDED CASH FLOWS
AS WELL AS THEIR BOTTOM LINE-
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE LARGE
MEDICARE FEE FOR SERVICE
PATIENT POPULATIONS. FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER IN THE
STATE OF RECEIVED A ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FROM A SEPARATE
POT OF FUNDING- DOES THAT IT'S
DESIGNED TO MITIGATE THEIR
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES. AND BOTH
OF THESE PARTS OF FUNDING THE
FUNDING FOR THAT BEING
ALLOCATED THROUGH MEDICARE FOR
A VARIETY OF PROVIDED TYPES IN
THE FUNDING FOR HEALTH CENTERS
REALLY SHOULD HELP PREVENT
PERMANENT CLOSURES AND THE
LAYING OFF OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS. FINALLY WE NOTE THAT
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
WORKERS ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
SOME OFTHE MORE GENERAL FORMS
OF FEDERAL ASSISTANCE THAT HAVE
BEEN RECENTLY APPROVED BY
CONGRESS CONGRESS. SUCH AS THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
LOANS TO HELP THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER IN OPERATION AND OTHER
PLAYERS AND THE WORKERS
EMPLOYED AS WELL AS THE ENHANCE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR
WORKERS WHO ARE WHO HAVE BEEN
LAID OFF OR FOR A LOVED. IN
ADDITION THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS PROVIDED SOMETIMES AT THE
REQUEST OF THE STATE'S MEDI CAL
PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE NEW PAYMENT
AND SERVICE DELIVERY
FLEXIBILITY SUCH AS PAYMENT
PARTY. FOR CERTAIN SERVICES
BETTER BUILT DELIVERED
VIRTUALLY OR TOUGH
TELEPHONICALLY. AND THIS ALLOWS
PROVIDED CONTINUE TO DELIVER
SERVICES THAT OTHERWISE- WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE BEEN FOR GONE
ENSURING SUMMARY REVENUE
CONTINUES TO COME IN. AND
LIKELY PROTECT THE EARNINGS OF
THOSE PARTS OF THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE TO SERVICES ARE MORE
AMENABLE TO VIRTUAL AND
TELEPHONIC DELIVERY. FOR
EXAMPLE WE'VE HEARD THAT SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH WORKERS
HAVE BEEN ADAPTING TO INSTEAD
PROVIDING THEIR SERVICES
VIRTUALLY WITHIN THE HOME
ENVIRONMENT WHILE THE SCHOOLS
ARE CLOSED. WE HAVE HEARD A
NUMBER OF MEASURES THAT HEALTH
PLANS AS WELL ARE TAKING TO
ENSURE THE STABILITY OF THEIR
PROVIDER NETWORKS FOR EXAMPLE
WE'VE HEARD HAVE HEALTH PLANS
MAKING LOANS TO HELP PROVIDERS
WOULD HAVE WITH CASH FLOW. ONE
PUBLIC PLAN- CONVERTED IT
PAYMENT TO SOME OF ITS
PROVIDERS FROM BEING ON A FEE
FOR SERVICE BASIS TO- MONTHLY
CAPITATED BASIS SO THAT THE
PAYMENT CONTINUE TO FLOW
REGARDLESS OF THE CURRENT-
SERVICE UTILIZATION MEMBERS.
AND THEN OTHER PLANS ARE MAKING
XCELERATED ARE ADVANCE PAYMENTS
TO THE PROVIDER AND PROVIDERS.
WE WOULD EXPECT LEAD TO
PURCHASE TO BEAR SOME FRUIT IN
TERMS OF PROTECTING THAT
PROVIDERS FROM BY THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES AND HELP TO PREVENT
BREAKDOWN BEEN HEALTH PLAN
PROVIDER NETWORKS AND ALSO
STABILIZE THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. DON'T INCLUDE
PROVIDERS REPORTING SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL STRAIN CALLED BIKE OF
IN NINETEEN BOTH IN TERMS OF
HIGHER COSTS AND HIGHER
REVENUES AND THESE ARE
IMPACTING HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN
SO FAR AS THEY ARE- BEING
AFFECTED BY CARLOS AND LAYOFFS.
THERE HAVE BEEN MEASURES THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN BY BOTH. PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE ENTITIES SUBJECT
CONGRESS AND SUCH AS BY HEALTH
PLANS TO HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF
THE FINANCIAL STRAIN. AND WE
JUST KNOW THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES CHOOSE TO
PROVIDE ANY LET'S LIMITED
RESOURCES TO HELP HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE UNDER THIS CRISIS. IN
MAY WISH TO CAREFULLY CONSIDER
THE THESE EXISTING SOURCES OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SUPPORT.
WITH THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS BUT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BàN AND NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
SHELLEY. ONE DOCTOR RANDY RUN
NUMBERS- AND SHELLY REQUIRED
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND I'M HERE TO TALK
TO YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT-
NETWORK ADEQUATELY AND THE
MEDICAL WATCHED RATIO- WOULD
YOU PROCESS. SO YOU WOULD
PRESENTED ME SEVERAL QUESTIONS
THAT I'M GOING TO ANSWER AND-
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS FROM
THE TIME THAT YOU ASKED FOR A
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE MOST
RECENT DATA ON NETWORK ADEQUACY
ENORMOUS CARE PLAN. SO OUR MOST
RECENT REVIEW OF HEALTH PLAN
NETWORK DATA WHICH FOR
MEASUREMENT YOUR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND WE HAD NO
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THE
PLAN. COMPLIANCE WITH THE KNOX
KEEN ACT. THE DEPARTMENT WE THE
THAT WERE DATA MEASURE MY YOUR
TO NINETEEN ON MY ARE A LAST
FRIDAY. AND OUR EVIEW WILL
OCCUR OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS.
YOUR SECOND QUESTION WAS ABOUT
WHAT IMPACT DO WE EXPECT THE
KOBE QUAKE TO HAVE A NETWORK
ADEQUATELY AND WHETHER MANAGED
CARE AND WILL BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN NETWORK ADEQUACY. IT'S
REALLY TOO EARLY TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE SHORT OR LONG TERM
IMPACT BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
CRISIS WILL HAVE ON HEALTH PLAN
THAT WORKS- AND THE LA- POINTED
OUT WE HAVE HEARD TO FROM
PROVIDERS PARTICULARLY HOSPITAL
PHYSICIAN COMMUNITY. HEALTH
CENTERS IN PARTICULAR.
REGARDING THEIR CONCERNS WITH
REDUCED INCOME STAFF LAYOFFS
AND REDUCTION IN WORK HOURS.
MANY OF THESE PROVIDERS TO
TRANSITION TO PROVIDING
SERVICES VIA TELEHEALTH WHILE
OTHERS ARE JUST BEGINNING AT
TRANSITION. IN ADDITION TO OUR
ANNUAL MONITORING OF HEALTH
PLAN NETWORK WE WILL KEEP AN
EYE ON THE ACTIVITIES AROUND
PROVIDER NETWORKS INCLUDING THE
NUMBER OF NEW FILINGS THAT WE
RECEIVE. THE EXTENT TO WHICH
HEALTH PLANS REPORT A 10%
CHANGE IN PROVIDER NAME.
TERMINATION OF HEALTH PLAN
CONTRACTED HOSPITAL TO PROVIDE
ORGANIZATION. AS WELL AS CALL
THE COMPLAINT SUBMITTED TO THE
HELP THAT ARE. IT REMAINS TO BE
SEEN WHETHER THERE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
OVERALL PROVIDER WORKFORCE THE
STATE AS A RESULT OF THE
SITUATION. YOUR NEXT QUESTION
WAS AROUND- MEDICAL LOCKED RATE
RATIO STATUTE AND WHAT REQUIRED
THAT TIME LINE AND HOW IT'S
OPERATIONALIZED. SO FEDERAL LAW
AND AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE
YOU ARE- BILL- IF YOU CHAIR
LAID OUT THE RULES FOR
DETERMINING A HEALTH PLAN AND A
LARGELY CALLING THE MLR DIFFERS
FOR INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
MARKETS CLICK HERE TO THE LARGE
GROUP MARKET. OTHER REMINDER
THE ON A LARK FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
MARKET IS 80% AND FOR A LARGE
GROUP THAT 85% BUT WHEN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET MARKET FOR
EXAMPLE A PLAN MUST SPEND 80%
OF ITS COLLECTED PREMIUMS ON
MEDICAL CAUGHT THAT HOSPITAL
DOCTORS. PRESCRIPTION DRUG
QUALITY INITIATIVES AND OTHER
SERVICES FOR ITS MEMBERS. ON
THOSE MEDICAL COSTS INCLUDE
CLEAN CAPITATION PAYMENT AND
ENCOURAGED BUT NOT REPORTED
CAUGHT. BUT ON THE MARKET
SEGMENT A CLINICAL LAB TO SPEND
15220% OF PREMIUM ON
ADMINISTRATIVE AND OTHER COSTS
THAT YOU CAN PLAY TOLERATE THE
BENEFIT. OFFICE IN MARKETING
AND BEEN ACTIVE OTHER FEES AND
POP BUT- I HEALTH PLAN AND A
LARGE CALCULATED USING DATA
OVER A THREE YEAR CLEAR YET
WHICH INCLUDES THE CURRENT YEAR
ON THE TWO PRIOR YEARS. THE FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN THE DATA WOULD
INCLUDE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
GOING. CALCULATING MLR
DISPLAYED MOVES OUT THE OUT
WIRES FROM YOUR YOUR HIRE SOME
THERE'S A LOWER IN A VERY BY
PLAN. AND ALLOW REPORT FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN IN DUE TO THE
DEPARTMENT ON JULY THIRTY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY
THE REPORT IN THE JULY THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ANY
PLANET FAILED TO MEET THE
EIGHTY OR 85% THRESHOLD MCLEAN
REBATES AND FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL
IF YOU PURCHASED COVERAGE.
REBATE YOU'RE PAID EACH YEAR IN
SEPTEMBER. IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO
CALCULATE A HEALTH PLANS MLR IN
REAL TIME DUE TO THE LACK IT
CLAIMS THE MISSION ALSO BECAUSE
THE LEVEL AND TYPE OF SERVICES
PROVIDED- CAN VARY WIDELY FROM
MONTH TO MONTH. THE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVES AND THOROUGHLY REVIEWS
THE MLR REPORT. WE ALSO CONDUCT
MLR EXAMS AND OUR AUDITS TO
ENSURE THE PLANT PROPERLY
CATEGORIZED REPORTED THERE. THE
IMPACT OF THE NINETEEN WILL
SHOW UP IN THE ANNUAL FEDERAL
FEDERAL MLR REPORT REPORTING
HERE THAT AND THIS YEAR
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. AND THAT REPORT
WILL BE PUBLISHED AT THE END OF
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. YOU
ASKED IF MANAGED CARE PLANS OF
EVER BEEN OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE MLR AND THE ANSWER TO
THAT IS YES. EACH YEAR THERE
ARE SOME PLANS THAT MUST BE
BATES INDIVIDUALS AND
EMPLOYERS. BUT THE MOST RECENT
YEAR FOR WHICH WE HAVE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. TWENTY HEALTH PLAN AT
NOT INCOMPLETE CROSS BLUE
SHIELD A TOTAL OF SEVENTY ONE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS MON
PLAYERS. ONE CLAN COMMUNITY
CARE PLAN PAID NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO MY GYM
PLAYERS AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THAT CREATED VERY BOB HAS
ONLY NINE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS. NO PLAN IN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET PLAYED REBATE
TWENTY FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALL%
MET. THE 80% AND A LARGE
FRACTIONAL. I'LL JUST NOTE THAT
TAKES TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN
THEY'RE PROGRAM TO WHEN IT'S
WITH THAT HELP PLANS THAT. OVER
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO DOLLARS MAKE
THE DATE. YOU ALSO ASKED IF
IT'S REASONABLE THAT WE WON'T
HAVE AN ALARM REVIEW
INFORMATION A COMPLEX YEAR. AND
I WOULD SAY THAT IT'S
REASONABLE IN THE SENSE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT WILL RECEIVE AN
ALL OUR RECORDS FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN IN JULY. THAT THE TIME
PRINT THAT OUT AND FEDERAL LAW.
KEEP IN MIND THAT THERE CAN BE
SIGNIFICANT LIKE TINY CLAIMS
SUBMITTED BY PROVIDERS. AND
EVEN THEN SOMETIMES HEALTH PLAN
ASK FOR ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW THEM.
HOWEVER RATE FILINGS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WILL BE OUR FIRST
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A CLOSE
LOOK AT WHAT ASSUMPTIONS AND
UTILIZATION DATA PLANS ARE
CONSIDERING LATE EIGHTY PUBLIC
NINETEEN. AS WELL AS THE
ASSUMPTION AND UTILIZATION DATA
FOR THAT. THE MAN BUT MAY
EMERGE FOR SERVICE THAT HAVE
BEEN PROVIDED DURING. YOU ALSO
ACT THERE SOME WAY TO EXPEDITE
THIS REVIEW GIVEN THE EMERGENCY
WORK YEAH. IN ADDITION TO THE
RIGHT KILEY THAT I JUST
MENTIONED HEALTH PLANS FILE
QUARTERLY FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
BUT THE DEPARTMENT. THESE
FILING BASICALLY DETAIL
INFORMATION ON EACH HEALTH PLAN
ASSETS LIABILITIES RESERVES
REVENUES MEDICAL EXPENSE THE
MINISTRY TO CLASS. PUBLIC
LOSSESAND. AND OTHER DETAILED
FINANCIAL INFORMATION. THE
FIRST QUARTER FINANCIAL FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN A GIVEN THE
DEPARTMENT ON MAKE THE- TWENTY
TWENTY IT'S UNLIKELY WILL BE
MUCH IMPACT FROM THE NINETEEN
IN BOTH STATEMENT. QUARTER
FILING COULD DO AUGUST
FIFTEENTH WILL SHOW MORE OF AN
IMPACT ON THE HEALTH PLANS
FINANCIAL TURN THE CLOCK IT
WITH NINETEEN. A WELL AS THE
IMPACT OF NOT PROVIDING MANY
OTHER TEXAS. HELLO THERE MY
COMPARATOR I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
YOUR QUESTIONS WHEN THE TIME
COMES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR REALLY
AREN'T NEXT WE HAVE DIRECTOR
GILBERT. GOOD MORNING- DR BELOW
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SO I WILL ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE PROVIDED AND THEN OF
COURSE BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS AFTERWARDS SO THE
FIRST ONE WAS TO PROVIDE A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE MOST
RECENT DATA NETWORK ADEQUACY IN
MANAGED CARE PLANS SIMILAR TO-
WHAT DIRECTOR REAL. WORLD WAS
TALKING ABOUT. WE DO NOT WORK
CERTIFICATION EVERY YEAR TO ON
JULY FIRST TO SEE A MATH UNTIL
THE PROCESS GOES THROUGH. THE
PERIOD BEFORE THAT WAS THE
MISSION BY THE PLAN. LAST YEAR
TWENTY OF THE MANAGED CARE
PLANS WERE PUT ON CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS THOSE OF ALL BEEN
CLOSED BECAUSE THERE'S A SIX
MONTH PERIOD FOR THOSE CAPS.
THEY CAN HAVE A TIME AND
DISTANCE DEFICIENCY DUE TO
EITHER NOT SUBMITTING PROPER
ANALYSIS. NOT SUBMITTING AN
ALTERNATIVE ACCESS SUBMISSION.
FOR YOU KNOW THE DHS ACTUALLY
DENIES THEIR ALTERNATIVE
ACCESS. THAT DURING THE SIX
MONTHS AS I MENTIONED AND
DURING THAT TIME THE DEPARTMENT
MONITORS ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
AND REQUIRES A MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO PROVIDE- TIMELY ACCESS
TO OUT OF NETWORK PROVIDERS-
WHEN THAT IS NECESSARY TO MEET
THE TIME AND DISTANCE
STANDARDS. WE ALSO REQUIRE THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS TO TRAIN
THEIR MEMBER SERVICES STAFF
AROUND THOSE DETAILS. AND WE
DO- ACTUAL SECRET SHOPPER CALL
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PLANS ARE
PROVIDING THE CORRECT
INFORMATION. TO THEIR MEMBERS
AROUND THOSE RIGHT. DURING THAT
CORRECTIVE ACTION PERIOD. IN
ADDITION TO THE NETWORK
CERTIFICATION- WE DO A TIMELY
ACCESS STUDY THAT IS DONE BY
OUR- CROW OR EXTERNAL QUALITY
REVIEW ORGANIZATION. WHICH IS
HEALTH SERVICES ADVISORY GROUP
AND THEY DO PHONE CALLS TO
DETERMINE- WHEN PEOPLE ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS CARE. THE LATEST
RESULTS- FOR TWENTY NINETEEN ON
THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE WERE
ADULTS- FOR NON URGENT NINETY
PERCENT. FOR CHILDREN 94% FOR
URGENT FOR PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS 81% FOR ADULTS 84%
FOR CHILDREN. FOR SPECIALIST
THE RESULTS WERE ADULTS 76%
CHILD SEVENTY EIGHT FOR NON
URGENT AND FOR URGENT ADULTS
7069% AND CHILDREN- SEVENTY
FOUR POINT 4% WE ALSO DO
QUARTERLY MONITORING AND WE
FOLLOW UP WITH- THE QUARTERLY
MONITORING AROUND PROVIDED A
MEMBER RATIOS- NETWORK REPORTS-
GRIEVANCES AN APPEALS STATE
FAIR HEARING SIX CETERA. AND
EVERY QUARTER WE GIVE THE PLANT
A QUARTERLY MONITORING
RESPONDED TEMPLATE WHICH LOOKED
AT OUR GOALS ARE EMPTY PIECE
SPECIFIC FINDINGS AND ANY
QUESTIONS WE HAVE FOR THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS. SO THAT'S A
OVERVIEW OF OUR NETWORK-
ADEQUACY RESULTS AND PROCESS
FOR BY LAST YEAR. SECOND
QUESTION WAS- SIMILAR THE TO
THE ONE PROJECT REGARD WHAT
IMPACT EXPECT OF A NETWORK
ADEQUACY IN WATER. WHAT YOU
KNOW WILL MEANT THAT ACCOUNT
MANAGED CARE PLAN TO BE ABLE TO
HELP. WHAT WE HAVE SEEN FOR
DURING THIS PERIOD IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
TYPE AND VOLUME OF SERVICES
PROVIDED BY TELEHEALTH. NOT HAS
BEEN MENTIONED. YOU KNOW THAT
IT'S BEEN REALLY- SOMETHING THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT CMS HAS
PROVIDED AS IT HAS HELPED QUITE
A BIT IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS CARE AND BE PAID AT THE
SAME RATE AS AN IN PERSON
VISIT. HOWEVER AS OF THOSE
MENTIONED- WE CERTAINLY HAVE
SEEN SIGNIFICANT DECREASES IN
UTILIZATION IN THE CLINIC WAS
SPECIAL FROM ONE HOSPITAL. AND
THERE HAS BEEN SOME TEMPORARY
CLOSURE AND CONSOLIDATION OF
CLINIC AND PROVIDER OFFICES-
THAT WE HAVE BEEN NOTIFIED
ABOUT. WE GET WE WERE- ACTUALLY
DO THAT MONITORING- IN TERMS OF
THE PLANS REPORTING ON A DAILY
AND WEEKLY BASIS WE THEN MAKE
SURE THAT THE PLANS HAVE
PROPERTIES IN PLACE- WHEN THOSE
WE GET THOSE REPORTS OF THE
FACILITY KIND CLOSING. THAT THE
MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
CARE- EITHER ALTERNATIVE
LOCATIONS NURSE ADVICE LINE AND
IN PERSON URGENT CARE LOCATIONS.
THAN IN ANY PLAN THAT
ADDITIONAL REQUIRED TO MAKE
SURE BUT- INDIVIDUALS OF THE
TRANSPORTATIONTHEY NEED. SO WE
DO THAT MONITORING- WE LOOK AT
IT VERY CLOSELY- WE ARE YOU
KNOW THINKING ABOUT AND
WONDERING ABOUT THE INCREASE IN
ACTIVITY THAT WILL OCCUR. AFTER
YOU KNOW THINGS START TO OEN
UP IN TERMS OF PROVIDERS BEING
ABLE TO CARE FOR. DEFERRED AND
PREVENTIVE CARE SO THAT'S ONE
THING WE'D BE LOOKING OUT TO
MAKE SURE ADDS THAT ADDITIONAL
CARE START BEING PROVIDED THAT.
THE NETWORK IS ADEQUATE TO
HANDLE THAT CONTINUE TO RIP A
NETWORK AVAIL AND WORKING. CAN
THAT MY- I DO WANT TO ASK TO
WHAT- BEEN MENTIONED ABOUT
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS
THEY HAVE PROVIDED. QUITE A BIT
OF SUPPORT WE HAVE BEEN
ENCOURAGING AND SURVEYING THEIR
ACTIVITIES. THERE'S ADVANCE
PAYMENT CLERK CELERY IN THEIR
PAY FOR PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS. THERE CAPITA
ATTAINING PROVIDERS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY READ- PEEPER
SERVICES THAT MENTION. THEIR
ADVANCING OUR EXPEDITING
PAYMENTS. UNDER INCREASING
CAPITATION FOR NETWORK
HOSPITAL- THEY'RE DOING QUITE A
BIT OF ACTIVITIES AND OF COURSE
PAYING FOR TELEHEALTH AS IT'S
ON THE SAME BASIS- BALLOT IN
PERSON VISIT INCLUDING. IN SOME
CASES PAYING OF TELEHEALTH
DOESN'T OUTSIDE THE CAPITATION
NORMALLY PAID. TO THE PROVIDER
THEY'VE DONE GRANT UNTIL
THERE'S BEEN JUST QUITE A BIT
OF ACTIVITY BY THE- MANAGED
CARE PLANS TO SUPPORT THEIR
PROVIDERS. AND THEN FINALLY-
WE'RE CERTAINLY WORKING WITH
HERE APS ON THE CHARACTER-
FUNDING THAT THAT BEEN
MENTIONED IN. IN HIS TALK AS
WELL. THIRD QUESTION WOULD
HAPPEN IN MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
DON'T COMPLY WITH SIMILAR STATE
FUNDS. BACK TO THE STATE AND
THERE'S A COUPLE OF PIECES
ABOUT THAT. DINNER RATE SETTING
PROCESS AND THIS IS AS YOU
KNOW- LOOKING AT INFORMATION
RETROSPECTIVELY- WE DO EVALUATE
UTILIZATION PATTERNS AND COST
EXPERIENCE. GET UP WE SEE
INCREASED OR DECREASED
UTILIZATION CAUGHT IN A PERIOD.
AND WERE ABLE TO ACCURATELY
PREDICT HOW THAT WILL LOOK
GOING FORWARD THAT WILL IMPACT
THE RATES PAID TO THE PLANS.
REALIZING THAT THOUGH THE
PROSPECT OF RATES AND THE DATA
WERE LOOKING OUT HIS
RETROSPECTIVE LIKE. AS DEFINED
BY FEDERAL MEDICAID
REQUIREMENTS- DHS IS REQUIRED
TO DEVELOP OUR RATES OF PLANS
CAN REASONABLY CHEAP AT LEAST
85% MLR THE- LEVEL THAT- DOCTOR
ARE TALKED ABOUT AND HER TALK.
HIM INTO FIND IN STATE LAW. ON
OR AFTER JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WOULD BE THE CALENDAR
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FOUR REDDING
COURAGE OF A PLAN SPEND BELOW
THAT 85% PREMIUM. DHS WILL
RECOUP THE DIFFERENCE REALIZING
THAT SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS GO
BACK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND SOME RETAINED BY THE STATE
DEPENDING ON THE PARTICULAR
EXPENDITURES IN QUESTION AND
THE VARIOUS RATIOS THAT OCCUR.
LIKE THE IMAGE HE ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS- WE RECEIVE
UNAUDITED CALLER QUARTERLY
FINANCIAL REPORTS THERE
PROVIDED FORTY FIVE DAYS FROM
THE END OF THE REPORTING
PERIOD. AND WE USE THOSE TO
MONITOR- PLAN MLR. KEY AND HE
ADMINISTRATIVE CST RATIOS AND
WORKING CAPITAL- AS DIRECTORY
ARE MENTIONED WILL BE GETTING-
THE REPORTS FOR THE FIRST
QUARTER WHICH MAY NOT SHOW THE
FULL IMPACT. OF THE COPA
NINETEEN- CHANGES- BUT WE WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE THAT IN THE NEXT
QUARTERLY REPORT THAT WE WOULD
GET THEREAFTER. JUST AS A
COMMENT- IN TERMS OF LOOKING
AT- DECEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORTS- TWENTY TWO OF TWENTY
TWO PLANS RETREATING EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT. SOME WERE THREE
WERE ABOUT A HUNDRED PERCENT.
ELEVEN WERE FROM NINETY FIVE TO
NINETY EIGHT AND A PAPER FROM
EIGHTY FIVE TO NINETY FOUR SO
CERTAINLY THE PAST HISTORY.
DESCRIBES THE- OUR PLANS ARE IN
MOST CASES WELL ABOVE THE 85%
RATIO. THIS IS THE THOSE.
CHALLENGES AS MANY OF YOU HAVE
MENTIONED- REALLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE SHORT TERM AND
LONG TERM FINANCIAL IMPACT ON
THE MANAGED CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN THE MEDICAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS- PLANTER EMPLOYING A
VARIETY OF TECHNIQUES TO
ATTEMPT TO PROTECT ACCESS AND
THEY'RE CONTRACTED PROVIDERS-
WE'VE ALSO INCREASED OUR
MEETINGS WITH THE PLANS WE KNOW
ME WITH THE MONTHLY. WITH WITH
A SMALL GROUP THAT REPRESENTS
THE PLANS TO REALLY WORK
THROUGH. THE ISSUES THAT ARE
OCCURRING- AND REALLY
CONTINUING TO DISCUSS WHAT'S
HAPPENING DURING COVERED
NINETEEN. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
ACTIVELY REVIEW FINANCIAL
PERFORMANCE AND UTILIZATION.
AND THOSE OTHER PIECES WILL
COME INTO PLAY LATER AS I
MENTIONED. NUMBER FOUR WAS
WHICH COMPONENTS OF THE- YOU
KNOW WHERE WHERE THE REAL
COMPONENTS OF WORKFORCE
PROBLEMS WITH WITH- MANAGE CARE
IN THE PLAN. I WOULD SAY THAT-
DOCTORS- ARE ALWAYS A
SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGE AREAS YOU
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION PUT REPORTS THAT THE
INLAND EMPIRE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
VERTICALLY CHALLENGE. THERE
ALSO SHORTAGES IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PSYCHIATRISTS
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND THERAPISTS AS
WELL AS JUST THE GENERAL
COMPETITION FOR DOCTORS BY
KAISER ANOTHER COMMERCIAL
ENTITY SO I WOULD IT IN TERMS
OF THE SHORTAGES THAT THAT
WOULD PROBABLY BE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT WOULD BE.
POSITIONED AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS. NUMBER FIVE
WAS- TALK ABOUT PROP FIFTY SIX
IN THE PROVIDER LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAMS- THE PROP FIFTY SIX
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS OF GUN
DEFINITELY PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
REVENUE TO PROVIDERS SENSOR
INCEPTION- HOWEVER A STUDY THAT
WAS DONE ABOUT THE ACA
INCREASED A MEDICARE LEVELS IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO TWENTY
FOURTEEN. DID FIND AN INCREASE
IN APPOINTMENT AVAILABILITY
WITH THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS.
BUT DID NOT HAVE AN EFFECT ON
THE PROPORTION OF PROVIDERS
ACCEPTING MEDICAID PATIENTS.
AND I WOULD JUST COMMENT THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF FACTORS THAT
AFFECT YOU KNOW PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING IN MEDI CAL. OR
NETWORK ADEQUACY OF EFFORTS BY
DHS ARE QUALITY PUSH PLAN
PAYMENT STRUCTURE THEIR PAY FOR
PERFORMANCE PROGRAMS- ALL OF
THOSE HAVE AN IMPACT ALONG WITH
PROP FIFTY SIX. IN TERMS OF
AFFECTING WHETHER PROVIDERS DO
MEDI CAL. AND THEN FINALLY IS-
THE COMMITTEE MAY KNOW THE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM WAS- PROVIDED
TO TWO HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN
PHYSICIAN AND FORTY DENTISTS
ACROSS- MULTIPLE COUNTY IS
SPECIALTIES. LAUGHS QUESTION I
HAD WAS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
CONTRIBUTE GOING FORWARD. I
FEEL LIKE RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN
THIS PERIOD WERE REALLY
FOCUSING ON STABILIZING THE
NETWORK AND SO AS I MENTIONED
YOU KNOW ALL THE EFFORTS
PREVIOUSLY BY THE HEALTH PLANS.
ACTUALLY SEEING THE CARES
FUNDING- REALLY ON THE USE OF
THE TELEHEALTH FLEXIBILITY- AND
THE AND THE EQUAL PAYMENT FOR
IN PERSON VISITS I FEEL LIKE
RIGHT NOW OUR FOCUS. NOW BOTH
FROM OUR MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS IN THE DEPARTMENT IS
REALLY STABILIZING THE NETWORK.
I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE LOOKING FORWARD ABOUT
HOW WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON.
SHORTAGES THAT ARE IN GENERAL
STORE HEALTH PLANS THAT HAVE
DONE SUBSIDIES FOR PHYSICIANS
TO BRING THEM INTO THEIR AREA
TO DO MEDI CAL. IT'S A
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS LIKE ABOUT.
TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE AND
OR GROW AT A LOOK AT WE WILL
LOOK AT THOSE OPTIONS AS WE GO
FORWARD. HELLO THERE MY
COMMENTS AND- WILL STAY ON THE
COURSE AND BE WILLING TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
GILBERT NEXT WE HAVE CARMELLA
COIL. HE VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE THANKS FOR YOUR
WORK AND FOR THIS HEARING TODAY
AND FOR BEING THERE IT'S SO
IMPORTANT- WE ARE IN
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES WITH
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES WHICH
CALLS FOR UNPRECEDENTED
SOLUTIONS AND ACTIONS. THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY HAD WE'LL
KNOW IS REELING AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FACE ECONOMIC
DIFFICULTIES FOR SOMETIME TO
COME AND PROBABLY LONGER
PERHAPS THAN ANY OF US WANT TO
CONTEMPLATE. HOSPITALS AND
HOSPITAL CAPACITY ARE CRITICAL
TO OUR ECONOMY AND TO
STRENGTHENING THE CALIFORNIA
WORK FORCE IN TWO IMPORTANT
WAYS FIRST HOSPITAL CAPACITY IS
KEY TO RE OPENING THE STATE'S
ECONOMY WE CANNOT REOPEN THE
ECONOMY UNLESS HOSPITALS ARE
BOTH AVAILABLE AND STAFFED. AND
IF HOSPITALS CAN'T REMAIN
STRONG INSOLVENT WE ARE ALL IN
JEOPARDY WHEN CODED RISES AND
WE ALL FULLY EXPECT IT WILL AS
THE STAY AT HOME ORDER IS
LIFTED AND WE BEGIN TO
INTERMINGLE AGAIN AND IF CODED
RESURGENCE. CALIFORNIA'S
CONFIDENCE IN DAILY LIFE CANNOT
BE RESTORED UNLESS HOSPITALS
ARE FUNDED STABLE AND
OPERATIONAL. AND THE SECOND WAY
IN WHICH HOSPITAL CAPACITY IS
CRITICAL TO OUR ECONOMY AND THE
STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE IS BECAUSE HOSPITALS
ARE ONE OF THE BEST WAYS TO
KEEP CALIFORNIA WORKING.
HOSPITALS ARE AMONG THE LARGEST
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE EMPLOY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS A HALF
A MILLION. WE SUPPORT ANOTHER
ONE POINT TWO MILLION JOBS IN
THE STATE AND WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
TOTAL ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA. HOSPITALS OFFERS
SOLID MIDDLE CLASS JOBS WITH
BENEFITS AND THAT IS WHAT WE
NEED AT THE STATE TO RECOVER
ECONOMICALLY. BUT THE IMPACT OF
CORONAVIRUS ON CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITALS HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE DEVASTATING.
AND I AM NOT ONE WHO IS PRONE
TO HYPERBOLE. I DO NOT USE THAT
WORD LIGHTLY BUT THE IMPACT
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING.
HOSPITALS WERE ASKED TO PREPARE
TWO THIRDS 4250% THAT MEANS TO
CARE. FOR THIRTY. AND WE DID
THAT WE ANSWERED THAT CALL WE
EMPTIED CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS
TO MAKE WAY THAT MEANS
CANCELING SURGERIES AND
PROCEDURES AND MORE IT IS WHAT
WE DO AND IT IS AND WAS AND
CONTINUES TO BE THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. BUT AS WE BEGIN THE
ASSESSED THE DAMAGE OF THE TOLL
IS ENORMOUS AND I WILL SAY IT
IS A TOOL THAT IS DIFFERENT.
THAN THE TOLL TAKEN ON OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND THAT
IS BECAUSE HOSPITALS HAVE NOT
ONLY LOST REVENUE. BUT WE ALSO
HAD TO REMAIN OPEN AND FULLY
STAFFED AS WE WERE DEALING WITH
THIS COVE AND CRISIS. SO
HOSPITAL REVENUE LOST. AN
AVERAGE OF 2230% WE BELIEVE TO
DATE MORE FOR SOME OF OUR
SMALLER RURAL HOSPITALS WHERE
THE LOSS OF JUST A FEW
PROCEDURES OUT REALLY MAKE UP
THE BULK OF THEIR REVENUE. THAT
2230% IN TERMS OF REVENUE
LOSSES FOR US. ACCOUNTS FOR
ABOUT TEN TO FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOSSES BOTTOM LINE
IS HOSPITALS ARE DESPERATE FOR
CASH. SO WE'RE ADDING TO THAT
THE COST OF COVERT PREPARATIONS
AND THAT INCLUDED CONSTRUCTION.
THE PURCHASE OF EQUIPMENT
WHETHER THAT WAS VENTILATORS
WERE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT INTENDED TO KEEP OUR
WORKERS SAFE. AND PARTICIPATING
IN STANDING UP ALTERNATIVE CARE
SITES THESE ADDITIONAL SITES
INTENDED TO BE CAN'T HOSPITALS
A NUMBER OF HOSPITALS WERE
INVOLVED IN- IN SETTING THOSE
UP. AND STAFFING THOSE AS WELL.
AND ALL OF THESE ACTIVITIES OF
COURSE DAMAGE HOSPITALS LONG
TERM FINANCIAL STRENGTHS.
LIQUIDITY HOSPITALS ABILITY TO
BORROW HOSPITAL'S ABILITY TO
TAKE ON CAPITAL PROJECTS AND
MORE. SO HOSPITAL TO DONE THEIR
BEST TO KEEP STAFF THROUGH ALL
OF THIS WE NEED NURSES AN
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES WORKERS
AND RESPIRATORY THERAPISTS AND
MANY MANY MORE BUT FOR LOW'S
AND LAY OFF HAVE BEGUN. WE HAVE
SEEN SOME HOSPITALS NOW
BEGINNING TO CUT OURS WERE
CHOIR PAID TIME OFF BE TAKEN OR
PAY REDUCTIONS AND N SOME
CASES A COUPLE OF LARGE SCALE
POSITION ELIMINATION. AND THAT
IS BECAUSE 60% OF HOSPITALS
SPENDING IS FOR LABOR ANOTHER
15% FOR THE SUPPLIES REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE CARE SO THREE
QUARTERS OF HOSPITAL SPENDING.
IS ON THE PEOPLE AND THE THINGS
NEEDED TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
TO ALL OF US LEADING HOSPITAL
VERY LITTLE ROOM TO DEAL WITH
THESE ENORMOUS IMMEDIATE
LOSSES. SO WE NEED TO DO WHAT
WE CAN TO STOP THE FINANCIAL
BLEEDING. FEDERAL RELIEF IS NOT
ENOUGH. TO DATE HOSPITALS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE RECEIVED A
LITTLE LESS THAN THREE BILLION
WE EXPECT THAT OF THE SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLARS PROVIDED TO
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS OUT WE
WILL FEATURE A SLIGHTLY MORE
THAN THREE BILLION DOLLARS
COMING TO HOSPITALS. IT IS
UNCLEAR HOW MUCH MORE AID WILL
BE COMING TO HOSPITALS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND AS THEY
CONTINUE TO EXPAND NOT CONTRACT
THE POOL OF POSSIBLE RECIPIENTS
IT IS MAKING HOSPITALS SHARE OF
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS SMALLER AND
SMALLER AND SMALLER. SO THERE
IS NO QUESTION THAT WE WILL
NEED THE STATE HELP AND THERE
ARE TWO THINGS NEEDED
IMMEDIATELY FIRST OF ALL YOUR
HELP AND THE GOVERNOR'S HELP IN
BRINGING INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND HEALTH PLANS TO THE TABLE
IN A MEANINGFUL WAY. IT WAS
JUST MENTIONED THAT SOME HEALTH
PLANS ARE PROVIDING LOANS OR
XCELERATED PAYMENTS TO
HOSPITALS FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
WE ARE SEEING THAT IN VERY FEW
CASES MORE IN TERMS OF MEDI CAL
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS- BUT FAR
LESS IN TERMS OF PRIVATE
INSURANCE COMPANIES. HOSPITAL
SHOULD BE PAID FOR THEIR UNPAID
CLAIMS WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
INSURANCE COMPANIES RIGHT NOW
HAVE LARGE SUMS OF MONEY THAT
ARE BEING HELD NORMALLY CLAIMS
THAT ARE PROCESSED AND CAN TAKE
AS MUCH AS NINETY DAYS. MEANING
DOLLARS ARE BEING HELD BY
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND HEALTH
PLANS FOR CARE THAT WAS
PROVIDED IN THE MONTH OF
FEBRUARY WE NEED TO MOVE THOSE
DOLLARS MORE QUICKLY. AND
IMMEDIATELY WITHIN THIRTY DAYS
TO HOSPITALS THAT MONEY NEEDS
TO GET TO HOSPITALS NOW.
VOLUNTARY ADVANCE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS AND EASING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN TO SPEED
PAYMENTS TO HOSPITALS IS ALSO
CRITICAL- WE DID INCLUDE THAT
IN A LETTER TO THE GOVERNOR ON
APRIL THE FIFTEENTH THAT
IMMEDIATE SHOT OF LIQUIDITY IS
NEEDED NOW. AND SECOND WE HAVE
REALLY NO CHOICE BUT TO ASK THE
STATE FOR IMMEDIATE HELP IN
TERMS OF THE BUDGET. AND WE ARE
MAKING A REQUEST FOR ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET
YEAR BEFORE JUNE THIRTIETH TO
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE LOSSES.
THERE IS MORE AND THERE WILL BE
MORE THAT IS NEEDED BUT AS WE
STARE AT JUST THE SHORT TERM
LOSSES IN THE TEN TO FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR RANGE. AND MORE
AT HOSPITALS WILL BE ASKED OVER
TIME TO CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN
SURGE CAPACITY. KEEP BEDS OPEN
AND EMPTY AND CONTINUE TO
PURCHASE AS THE SUPPLY CHAIN
COMES BACK ON LINE. THE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
AND OTHER THINGS NEEDED TO KEEP
US ALL SAFE SHOULD THERE BE A
COLBERT RESURGENCE WE HAVE GOT
TO SOLIDIFY THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM
NOW. SO THERE WILL BE MORE THAT
IS NEEDED WE WILL BE WORKING
WITH THE STATE TO SEEK
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE IN NEEDED
FEDERAL MATCHING DOLLARS
DOLLARS THE STATE CAN PUT UP
AND THEN DRAW DOWN ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL DOLLARS. SO WE HAVE TO-
REPAIR NOW CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITALS THEY ARE KEY TO RE
OPENING THE ECONOMY AND THE
KEEPING PEOPLE WORKING. AND SO
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY- WE
REALLY NEED A CALIFORNIA TO.
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS.
AND HOSPITALS HAVE PROTECTED
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU NEXT WE
HAVE SERRA SUMMER. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
HERE SUMMER I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER FIFTY THOUSAND POSITIONS
THE CALIFORNIA. I'M ALSO HERE
IS CEO OF THE INMATES PHYSICIAN
SERVICES ORGANIZATION WHICH
PROVIDES TOLD THEM SERVICES
INDEPENDENT ELECTIONS AND SMALL
PRACTICES HELPING THEM TO
REMAIN INDEPENDENT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. I WANT TO START
BY EMPHASIZING THAT THE
POSITION WORKFORCE IS FACING AN
ACUTE CRISIS. IN A RECENTLY
SURVEYED OVER TWO POSITION
PRACTICES. BUT WE SALAS
PRACTICES OF ALL SIZES THE
MODALITIES ARE IN CRISIS. 68%
OF PRACTICES HAVE BEEN A
DECREASE IN PATIENT VOLUME BUT
AN AVERAGE OF 54% DECREASE IN
REVENUE. ALMOST HALF OF ALL
PRACTICAL ABOUT DIFFERENT LOWER
LA OPPOSITION IN FACT. AND MANY
POSITIONS ARE GOING WITHOUT A
SALARY AND THAT'S ALL THEY'RE
ALL WORKING EXTRA HOURS. EVERY
WORLD FOR PP AND OFTENTIMES
SOUTH QUARANTINING A SEPARATING
FROM THEIR FAMILIES EVEN
THINKING IN OUR OFFICES. WHEN
IT COMES TO SAVING THE POSITION
PRACTICES IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT A RUNWAY OF BOND
NOT YEARS. 43% OF CALIFORNIANS
GET THEIR HEALTHCARE FROM A
SMALL PRACTICE. AND A SMALL
PRACTICE IS JUST A SMALL
BUSINESS MOST OF WHICH HAVE
SIXTY WEEKS A RESERVE AND WE'RE
ENTERING WEEK SEVEN OR EIGHT OF
THE COPA NINETEEN ENDEMIC. BUT
IS NOT LIMITED TO SMALL
PRACTICES. ACTIVISM A HUNDRED
FIFTY DOCTORS ON THE VERGE OF
CLOSURE AND LARGE SYSTEMS THAT
HELP FACILITIES. ARE LOW IN
FAT. I THANK THE TENDENCY
PERCENT OF PRACTICES MAY END UP
CLOSING DOORS. AND THAT MEANS
THAT THE THIRTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TO LOSE ACCESS TO
THEIR PROVIDER. AND THIS IS
WORSE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
OUR SAFETY. WE ALSO NEED TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE- THIRD. THERE
WILL PENNED OF. FOR AND CHRONIC
INTO. COUPLED WITH HEALTH
IMPACTS FROM SHELTER IN PLACE.
DIET AND EXERCISE ROUTINES HAVE
GONE BY THE WAYSIDE THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
FINANCIAL STRESSES AND FEAR
LEADING TO WORK HEALTH
OUTCOMES. BUT THIS DOES NOT
MEAN THAT POSITIONS WILL MAKE
UP FOR LOST REVENUE. THERE ARE
ONLY SO MANY HOURS IN THE DAY
AND POSITIONS AND PRACTICES.
ALREADY OPERATING AT OR ABOVE
CAPACITY BEFORE KOBE NINETEEN.
INCREASED SAFETY PROTOCOLS
BUDGET PHYSICALLY DISTANT THING
PROVIDING INCREASED CLEANING
BETWEEN APPOINTMENTS REMOTE
TECHNICAL FEATURES AND MORE.
THIS IS WILL BE LUCKY TO BE
OPERATING AT 50% CAPACITY. PLUS
THEY'RE ACTUALLY INCREASED
PATHOLOGICAL THE NINETEEN. BUT
DOESN'T HAVE TO PURCHASE EXTRA
PP IN CLEANING SUPPLIES.
OPPORTUNITY OUR PRE SCREEN
PATIENTS INSTALL TELL HOW
CAPABILITIES AND MORE. IF WE
DON'T MAKE AN EFFORT TO
PRESERVE THE HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW ACCESS WILL
DECREASE QUALITY WILL SUFFER
AND CAUCUS IRAQ IT. ACTIVE WILL
DISAPPEAR. THIS IN TURN
RETIREMENT WILL RETIRE EARLY
AND OTHERS WILL JOIN LARGER
MORE STABLE SYSTEMS ARE
CORRECT. THIS MEANS LOWER
QUALITY WE WILL LOSE LONG
STANDING POSITION PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP. THIS IS NOT
REPLICABLE OR REPLACEABLE.
PRICES LOOK A LOTINCREASED
CONSOLIDATION ONLY TO PRICE
INCREASES ANYWHERE FROM FORTY
TO FIFTY PERCENT. AND
ACCESSIBLE COOPER WE CANCEL
GROW PATIENTS WILL HAVE TO
TRAVEL FURTHER FOR CARE AND IT
WILL HIT RURAL AREAS HARDER AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
GLOBAL POPULATION. WE HAVE TO
ACT NOW TO BOLSTER AND SUPPORT
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. WE
ASK STATE AND THE PAIR CONTINUE
TO PART WITH PARTNER WITH THAT
TO REDUCE REGULATORY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS AND
SUPPORT AND SUSTAIN THE
POSITION WORKFORCE. WE ASK THE
STATE TO PROVIDE PERMANENT
TELEHEALTH PARITY WITH CLEARING
CONFLICTING GUIDANCE ACROSS
LINES OF BUSINESS IMPAIR TIGHT.
WE ALSO ASK THAT THEY LIMóN
EIGHT OR REDUCE BURDENSOME IN
REVERSE IT HAS THE REQUIREMENT
THAT JUST PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
AND COULD ACTUALLY. THE STATE
SHOULD IDENTIFY REAP. ANY ON
SPEND PROPERTY SIX BACK ATTACK
SPENDING. MAINTAINS THE
MAINTAIN TO PRACTICE HIS THEIR
MEDICAL PATIENT. IF THEY WANT
PRACTICES IN DANGER FROM.
DECREASE OUR PATIENTS. I THINK
TEARS DURING AT THE PAIN AND
POURED IF THEY HEALTHCARE.
PROMPTLY PAYMENT A CABLE THE
POINT ADDITION CANNOT WAY TO
STAND THIRTY TO NINETY DAYS
FOREVER. LOAN ADVANCED CLAIM
PAYMENTS ARE RIGHT. THE GIVEN
LONG IN A LIFE AND IT OF A
NINETEEN. IT MADE A PICNIC DOWN
THE AS MY PROVIDER A PRACTICE
WILL NOT BE ABLE GET HIM BACK
MONTHS ARE YOU. IF AT ALL. WE
ASK. IN FORGET LOAN OR FOR
FORGIVE BROADBAND CLAIMS. WE
ALSO THE PAIN PROVIDE INTEREST
AND IMPROVE ACTIVITY. BUT WE
THINK COULD FIT INTO THE
EXISTING MLR FRAMEWORK. THERE
SHOULD ALSO WHO ARE ACTIVELY
RESERVE ARE LEGALLY MANDATED.
THAT EXACTLY SUCH AS THIS AND
THAT. EVEN THE BAR OF UC DAVIS
HEALTH. QUEST THAT I THOUGHT
THAT PARTICULARLY. HOW DO WE
KEEP. HEALTHY BACK CORNER. IN
THE HEALTHCARE. ARE IN. IS TO
ME. STERN IN A SUPPORT ARGUE.
HEALTH IF THE STOCK. THIS IS ON
THE FRONT LINES EVERYDAY.
TAKING HER PATIENT. TAKING CARE
OF THEIR STAFF AND THEIR- THE
LAST THEY SHOULD TO WORRY. KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE LUIS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR A WITH US WITH
THE HELP ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH PLAN ACTIONS TO ADDRESS
COULD BE NINETEEN. THE ONSET OF
THE- CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HEALTH PLANS HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
SUPPORTING A COMMUNITIES
CONSUMERS. AND PROVIDERS.
HEALTH PLANS HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO FREE UP CAPACITY IN THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. COMMUNICATE
WITH THE ROLE IS AN INCREASE
ACCESS TO TELEHEALTH. BECAUSE
THE PANDEMIC IS CAUSING
FINANCIAL STRAIN FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS TESTING AND
TREATMENT FOR COVERT NINETEEN
IS BEING COVERED WITH ZERO
COPAY YOUR OUT OF POCKET COST.
PLANS ARE SUPPORTING LOCAL
CHARITIES FACILITATING DELIVERY
THE PP PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
INCREASED TESTING REACHING OUT
TO LOOK VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
IN SUPPORTING LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
HELP POINT ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL IMPACT
THAT KOBE NINETEEN IS HAVING ON
THEIR CONTRACT NETWORKS. IN
RESPONSE MANY OF OUR PLANS ARE
USING ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS
AND PROVIDING FINANCIAL SUPPORT
TO PROVIDERS. FROM A SYSTEMIC
PERSPECTIVE CALIFORNIANS UNIQUE
SYSTEM GIVES US AN INHERENT
ADVANTAGE BECAUSE IT IS FUNDED
MORE HEAVILY THAN OTHER STATE
ON CAPITATED PAYMENTS BY HEALTH
PLANS OTHER CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS. IN THESE PER MEMBER
PER MONTH CAPITATED PAYMENTS
ARE PROVIDING A CRITICAL
LIFELINE TOO MANY HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS MEDICAL GROUPS AND
INDEPENDENT PRACTICE
ASSOCIATIONS. PLANS CONTINUE TO
MAKE THESE PAYMENTS AND IN SOME
CASES HAVE ACCELERATED THEM.
THIS FINANCIAL SUPPORT IS
CRITICAL TO KEEPING FACILITIES
AND PROVIDERS OPERATIONAL
DURING A PANDEMIC AND BEYOND.
ON TOP OF THIS OUR MEMBERS ARE
TAKING ADDITIONAL ACTION TO
OFFER DIRECT FINANCIAL SUPPORT
TO THEIR PROVIDER. THIS
INCLUDES XCELERATED OR DANCE
PAYMENTS. FINANCING GUARANTEES
THE RESTRUCTURING OF CONTRACTS
AND IN THE MEDI CAL SPACE
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE TO SUPPORT
PROVIDERS OUT TO DO A VARIETY
OF BEINGS. INCLUDING HAS THOSE
PENSION CREEK- PREVIOUSLY
EXPANDED TELEHEALTH CAPACITY
AND CAPABILITY FOR CLINICS
CENTERS AND PRACTICES. THAT
SERVE THE STATE'S MORE HORRIBLE
PATIENT POPULATIONS. YOU HEALTH
PLAN INVESTMENT DELIVER
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT NATIONALLY
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS WHICH ARE
AVAILABLE IN CALIFORNIA.
CAPTION MEMBERS ARE ALSO
PLEASED T SEE THAT BILLIONS
MORE IN FEDERAL FUNDING IS
BEING DISTRIBUTED TO THE HEALTH
SYSTEM. IN FACT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BEGAN ITS
DISTRIBUTION OF PAYMENTS TO
HOSPITALS AND RURAL PROVIDERS
JUSTICE FRIDAY. AS FUNDING
BEGINS JUST TO FOLLOW
CALIFORNIA'S PROVIDERS ARE
PLANTS HAVE COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH THEIR CONTRACT PROVIDERS
TO EXPLORE FURTHER ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES TO SUPPORT THE
SYSTEM THIS COULD INCLUDE
ACTIONS SUCH AS EXPEDITING
CLAIMS PROCESSING ELIMINATING
BACKLOGS REDUCING
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
SOLUTIONS. IT BEARS NOTING
THOUGH THAT THE WIDE ARRAY OF
CONTRACTING ARRANGEMENTS WITH
PROVIDERS DOES NOT LEND ITSELF
TO ONE SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION
BUT EVERY PLANNING CALIFORNIA
HAS COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE PROVIDERS DURING THE CRISIS.
TO THAT END CAP HAS BEEN
MEETING WITH CMA SEE AJ ATG AND
OTHERS TO SORT THROUGH ISSUES
AND TROUBLESHOOT PROBLEMS ON A
CASE BY CASE BASIS. OR MORE
SYSTEMICALLY AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO A CONTINUING THESE
CONVERSATIONS IN PARTNERSHIP.
NOW ALL THIS ACTIVITY IS BEING
CONDUCTED WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF
A FISCAL UNCERTAINTY FOR THE
PRIVATE MARKETS AND PUBLIC
PROGRAM. HEALTH PLANS MUST BE
ABLE TO PLAN FINANCIALLY FOR
THE INCREASING CARE THIS
PANDEMIC. IS BRINGING IN MAY
BRING IN THE FUTURE. MEETING
KOBE NINETEEN PATIENCE IS
LIKELY TO BE VERY EXPENSIVE AND
WE HAVE YET TO FULLY SEEN OF
THE EXACT COSTS. COVERED
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER HAS
ESTIMATED THAT THE ONE YOU'RE
PROJECTED COSTS IN THE NATIONAL
COMMERCIAL MARKET RANGE FROM.
THIRTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS JUST FOR COVERT
NINETEEN. IF THE ALSO IF THE
FIRST OF FOUR YEAR COST OF THIS
PANDEMIC HAD BEEN PRICED INTO
THIS YEAR'S PREMIUMS BECAUSE
FOR TWENTY TWENTY COULD RANGE
FROM ABOUT 2% 221% OF PREMIUM.
ACCORDING TO ANOTHER COVER
CALIFORNIA ESTIMATE. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE PREMIUM INCREASES
FROM KOBE NINETEEN ALONE COULD
RANGE FROM 4% TO MORE THAN 40%
NO BEES WIDE RANGES ONLY
DEMONSTRATE THE SCOPE IN DEGREE
OF UNCERTAINTY WE ARE FACING
RIGHT NOW- AND BEES. YOU KNOW.
THIS UNCERTAINTY OF COURSE IS
INFLUENCED BY THE AYE CURRENT
CODE COSTS. POTENTIAL FUTURE
CODE COSTS AND THE RE OPENING
OF THE ECONOMY IN THE MEDICAL
SYSTEM. NO NO THAT THE CHILDREN
PLACE ORDERS ARE BEING SLOWLY
MODIFIED PENT UP MEDICAL
DEMAND- WILL EVENTUALLY YOU TWO
WERE RESUMPTION OF NON COATED
MEDICAL CARE INCLUDING ELECTIVE
SURGERY IS. AGAIN HEALTH PLANS
MUST BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE TO MEET
THIS NEED- IT'S COMPLICATED
BECAUSE THE PREMIUM IMPACT OF
THIS ARE NOT WELL UNDERSTOOD.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL VARIABLES
TO CONSIDER LIKE. THE TIMING OF
RE OPENING THE MEDICAL SYSTEM
THE COST OF TESTING AND ANY
TREATMENTS INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY A VACCINE- AND THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS PREMIUM
COLLECTION AS A RESULT. OF THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND JOB LOSS.
END OF OURSE THE CALL. OF
POSTAGE CARE. WE'RE SEEING A
TEMPORARY REDUCTION- HAS
MENTIONED IN UTILIZATION AT
THIS POINT IN TIME AND IT'S A
POINT IN TIME IS REASONABLE
VERY REASONABLE TO ASSUME THAT
A PORTION. PERHAPS A LARGE
PORTION OF HIS POSTPONED CARE
WILL RETURN. FANS WILL NEED TO
BE NEED TO BUILD THIS INTO
THEIR PRICING FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SO UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
HERE INCLUDE WILL THERE BE A
SECOND WAVE. WHAT IS THE
PUBLIC'S WILLINGNESS TO SEEK
CARE WHAT WILL THEIR HEALTH
STATUS BE WILL BE WORSE AND
THAT'S MORE EXPENSIVE SO THESE
ARE ALL ANSWER QUESTIONS AT
THIS POINT IN TIME AND HAVE A
DIRECT IMPACT ON THE TYPE OF-
FINANCIAL PREPARATIONS THAT
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED- ON THE
STATE SIDE WE NOTICE PANDEMIC A
LEADING TO BUDGET UNCERTAINTY
AND A CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH PLAN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH DH CS
TO PROTECT THE MEDICAL PROGRAM.
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME SO
YOU KNOW IN CLOSING I WOULD
JUST SAY THE CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH PLANS WOULD LIKE TO
THINK DIRECTORS GILBERTON
REGARD FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP
THROUGH THIS CRISIS. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK CONSTRUCTIVELY
WITH DCS INDIAN HC IN THE REST
OF THE STATE LEADERSHIP TO
ENSURE THAT WHATEVER DECISIONS
WE MAKE TODAY KEEP OUR ENTIRE
HEALTH SYSTEM STRONG INTO THE
FUTURE. AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT WE HAVE MATT
LED. GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING THE
INPUT OF WORKERS ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE MY NAME IS NOT
AS A AND I'M A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH US YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING DOCTORS
NURSES ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND THOSE WORKERS
WHO ARE SERVING ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. HOW
WORKERS HAVE STEPPED UP IN A
TIME OF CRISIS AND WE HAVE A
DUTY OBLIGATION TO BACK IN OUR
WORK FORCE WITH THE FOR. YEAR
YOU OFFERS THE FOLLOWING. THE
LEGISLATURE ONE A LONG TERM
PLAN ON PP. TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENTS TO UPSCALE OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS THREE INVESTMENT
IN OUR COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE INFRASTRUCTURE. FIRST
WORKERS HAVE EXPECTED OF
ADEQUATE PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
WHEN THEY PERFORM THEIR
SCHEDULE JOBS THAT YOU'VE EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT WHAT WE DO NOT
KNOW THE LONG TERM HEALTH
IMPACT OF WORK. ON WORKERS FOR
KOBE NIKE IN THE OPTION OF
LEADERSHIP FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
CALIFORNIA MUST DEVELOP A LONG
TERM PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT PLAN.
THERE'S A STRONG LIKELIHOOD
THATANOTHER PANDEMIC WILL HIT
CALIFORNIAN THERE'S NO EXCUSE
TO BE UNDERPREPARED NEXT TIME.
SO WE CANNOT DEAL WITH THE
FUTURE OF OUR HEALTHCARE WORK.
UNLESS WE TAKE CARE OF THE
CURRENT WORKFORCE SPENDING
WHICH INCLUDES ADEQUATE P. P.
SECOND AB ARGUE FOR FROM
PREVIOUS PANELISTS HOBBLED AND
CLINICS ARE LAYING OFF WORKERS
TO THERE WERE. LOS EMPLOYERS
SHOULD BOUND THERE BUT OFTEN.
OF THAT SUCH A IN MY WE WILL
WORK WITH EMPLOYEES WHEN WE CAN
FIGURE ALTERING SOLELY ALL.
WORKERS WILL ALSO BE SUPPORT IN
THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
NOT LEAVING. THE VERY WORKERS
THAT WE RELIED ON DURING THIS
EMERGENCY. WE MUST YOU OPTION
WORKERS NOW ENSURE WE ARE
AVOIDING LAYOFFS WHENEVER
POSSIBLE YOUR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. ARE FEATURED CAN GET
THE CARE THEY NEED WHEN THEY
NEED IT. WE HAVE A LONG TERM
HEALTH OF. SHORTAGE MORE THAN
HUNDRED THOUSAND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS. IN ME AND WHAT I FOUND
IN WORKFORCE. IS THAT.
EMPLOYERS THINKING IMMEDIATE
TERM. AND AT THE POLICY LEVEL
WE THINK ABOUT IN THE- IN THE
LONGER TERM PROJECTIONS. HEALTH
JOB DEFENDING SUSTAINING JOBS
AND IN ORDER FOR OUR ECONOMY TO
RECOVER YOU MUST HAVE A POP WE-
STILL ARE CURRENT WORKFORCE AND
MAKE NEW WORKERS. TO THESE
GREAT POWER. OUT FAILED TO
TRAIN WORKFORCE WE NEED REAL X.
AND- DELAYS AND THEN OKAY. THIS
IS ACUTELY FELT WIRE BUT HEALTH
PROVIDER BUT SIR STRUCK BUT ARE
IN POWER THERE LOW RUNNING THE
NET SERVER FOR PATIENTS. IF WE
ALLOW PROVIDE TO CALL DURING
THE EARLY STAGES A CRISIS NO
MATTER HOW THE NECESSARY. HELP
SIR. THE WOMAN IT THE MOST.
UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF THE
PROGRAM THAT IS OFF CUT IN THAT
WAS CUT DURING THE RECESSION.
WAS OUR WORKFORCE TRAINING
PROGRAM. PROGRAMS WERE CUT BOTH
BY THE STATE AND BY. THAT HAVE
THE IN WITH FORCING STREAM TO
TURN TO FOR SCHOOL TO TRAIN FOR
HEALTHCARE JOBS. THE RECESSION
FOR PROPER SCHOOLS ARE 100% AND
IN A ROW COMPARED TO ROUGHLY
20% IN IN A ROW BURKE CALL.
MANY OF THOSE STUDENTS TO MAKE
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR HEALTH CARE DEGREES
OFTEN DID NOT MAKE MATERIALIZE
TO HELP DOC. THE OLD ME STYLE
CAL WITH THAT DEBT THAT STILL
STRUGGLING TO PAY OFF. I SEE
THIS YEAR LET TO MAKE AND
ENHANCE. ARE HOPE I. YOU TOO
MANY FOR HEALTHCARE WORK IN THE
LONG AND THE FACT THAT THEY'LL
TURN TO WORKER WITH DAD THE NEW
OPPORTUNITY. LASTLY ANOTHER
AREA OF THE CREDIT MASS ARE PA
HEALTH. WHICH ARE YOU SURE
UNDER. IN APRIL TWENTY NINTH.
THE TRUCKS UP FOR AMERICA'S HOW
ASKING. IT BEING THAT THE PA
HEALTH. NATIONALLY WERE UNDER
BUT WILL POINT FIVE BILLION AND
THAT NATIONAL FIFTY DOLLARS
MISSIONS WERE LET. FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. OR CAN CALIFORNIA
FUTURE HOW CARE WORK COMMISSION
FEBRUARY TWENTY MAKING REPORT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA'S CHRONICALLY
UNDERFUNDED AND MOST LOCAL HELP
THE- AGENCY FLOCK THE PERSON
NOW WITH YOUR KEY AREAS SUCH
AS- THE OPPORTUNITY OLOGY AN
ESSENTIAL SKILL TO DESIGN
IMPLEMENT. AND EVALUATE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH IMPROVEMENT.
IN ORDER TO RE OPEN OUR OUR OUR
ECONOMY YOU WILL NEED TO HAVE A
BROAD SCALE CONTACT TREATING
PROGRAM LED BY OUR COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT. WE
WILL NEED TO DEPLOY THOUSANDS
OF CONTACT TRACERS CONTRACT THE
VIRUS CAN ENSURE THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO QUELL ANY OUTBREAKS
BEFORE THEY TURN INTO EMERGENCY.
COUNT WORKERS WILL WHY AGAIN
OUR CALL IN A WILLING TO READ
TO COUNTY HELP. STORES SUCH
WITH CONTACT TREATING COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
NEED TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR WORK
FORCES. YOU TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO COUNTY
QUICKLY HIGHER. MAKES SENSE
BOTH FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO
MAKES SENSE FROM A FISCAL
PERSPECTIVE. THE ABOUT TRY
REIMBURSEMENT OF UP 275% OR
MORE. I WILL CLOSE BY SAYING WE
HOPE ALL OUR WORKERS APPRECIATE
WRITING BUILDING BLEW TO
SUPPORT FAMILY AND RECOGNIZE
FRONTLINE WORKERS IN ALL THE
ODDS BEING RUN BY A
MULTINATIONAL CORPORATION
RECOGNIZINGOUR WORKERS HEROES.
IT IS TIME FOR A FEW MORE THAN
TALK WE NEED TO INVEST IN OUR
WORKERS ACTUALLY SHOW THEM THE
RESPECT THAT THEY DESERVE WITH
ACTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THESE COMMENTERS
SUGGESTED ME PRESHEAF BUT WE
LEGISLATURE'S LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. AND I'M HAPPY
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE
BETH CAPELL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
BETH CAPELL FOR HELP ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION. THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING ON AN IMPORTANT AND
DIFFICULT SUBJECT IN A
DIFFICULT TIME WE BEGIN WITH
THE PREMISE THAT EVERY SINGLE
PREMIUM DOLLAR PAID FOR HEALTH
INSURANCE IS PAID BY A CONSUMER
OR ON BEHALF OF CONSUMERS BY
EMPLOYERS AND ABOUT A CAL
PROGRAM. THOSE DOLLARS ARE ARE
MONEY PAID TO HELP PLANS TO GET
US THE HEALTH CARE WE NEED WHEN
WE NEED IT. AND THOSE OUR
SHOULD EITHER GO TO SUSTAIN THE
NETWORKS IN THIS DIFFICULT TIME
OR BE REFUNDED TO CONSUMERS AND
OTHER PURCHASERS THROUGH
REBATES AND RIGHT PROTECTION.
WE PROUD TO SPONSOR DR REGULAR
MEASURE AS WELL AS EARLIER
MEASURES THE NECK TO THE
MEDICAL LOSS RATIO HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE LEGISLATION
ON RATE RUBIO. WE HAVE ALSO
FOUGHT FOR MANY YEARS TO ASSURE
THE CONSUMERS HAVE TIMELY
ACCESS ADEQUATE THAT WORKS IN
CARE AND THE LANGUAGE THEY
SPEAK. THE UNPRECEDENTED
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PANDEMIC IS
YOU HAVE HEARD IN THE CONSUMERS
ARE NOT GETTING THE CARE THEY
NEED AND OFTEN NOT GETTING CARE
WHEN THEY NEED IT. WHETHER IT
IS PEOPLE AVOIDING EMERGENCY
ROOMS AND THEY MIGHT HAVE A
HEART ATTACK OR STROKE OR
PEOPLE WHO ARE PUT OFF DESERVES
TO MANAGE THE- THEIR CHRONIC
CONDITIONS FROM ASTHMA TO
DIABETES HEART DISEASE. AND
CANCER AND OTHER SERIOUS
CONDITIONS CONSUMERS HAVEN'T
DEFERRED CARE. THE DROP IN
VOLUME YOU HAVE HEARD ABOUT
TODAY FROM THE HOSPITALS AND
PHYSICIANS AND OTHERS IS REAL
AND SERIOUS AND RAISES
QUESTIONS FOR US ABOUT THE
VIABILITY OF THE NETWORKS ON
WHICH CONSUMERS PATENT. WE DO
WANT TO TAKE NOTE OF THE%
FEDERAL HELP BUT WE ARE
TROUBLED BUT THUS FAR. THE HELP
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED THE
FEDERAL LEVEL HAS NOT BEEN
EIGHTEEN GET THOSE. PARTS OF
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM ON WHICH
ARE MEDI CAL. BEEN ROLE IS. AT
THE SAME TIME THE CLAIMS HAVE
DROPPED IN THE LAST SIXTY WE
HELP CLIENTS AND CONTINUED TO
COLLECT PREMIUMS BASED ON THE
CLAIMS PAID THE LAST YEAR AND
THE COST PREVIOUSLY PROJECTED
FOR THIS YEAR. YES YOU HEARD TO
DATE SUBCLANS HAVE STEPPED
FORWARD TO ADVANCE PAYMENTS AND
PROVIDE OTHER ASSISTANCE BUT
MANY HAVE NOT. WE ARE
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR ABOUT THE
NOTION OF SHIFTING TO
CAPITATION AS A POSSIBLE
SOLUTION. AND WE ALSO ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF TELEHEALTH SO WE
WILL NEED TO THINK ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT
SHOULD ACCOMPANY THE USE OF
TELEHEALTH. WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THE STATE GOVERNMENT HAS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY. IN
MEETING THIS CRISIS. THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD CREATE A FRAMEWORK THAT
ALLOWS COORDINATION AND
DISCUSSION NOT JUST BETWEEN THE
HEALTH PLANS AND HEALTH
PROVIDERS BUT INVOLVING POLICY
MAKERS LIKE YOURSELVES.
CONSUMERS AND OTHER PURCHASERS
WE WOULD NOTE THAT IF
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAD AN
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY ELECTED ONE
CONTEMPLATED DOCTOR BUT STILL
ARE THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL
WE WOULD BE USING IT FOR THIS
PURPOSE. AND TO UNDERSTAND
SYSTEM CAPACITY FROM HOW MANY
STAFF DICEY YOU BEDS WE HAD TO
THE NETWORK IMPACTS OF THE
ECONOMIC CHANGES. AS WE DO
THINK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. WE LOOK FORWARD TO A
SYSTEM WHERE CARE IS BASED ON.
WHERE CARE IS MOST NEEDED NOT
WHERE DOES THE MOST. MINIATURE
OF OR LUCRATIVE. FIRST PLAN TO
RECORD HAVE ADEQUATE NETWORKS
TIMELY ACCESS AND ACCURATE
PROVIDER DIRECTORY AND CONSUMER
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COUNT ON
NETWORKS BEING THERE ONCE THE
PANDEMIC IS OVER. THE
REGULATORS THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE THE
DEPARTMENT'S INSURANCE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. NEED TO
TAKE THE NECESSARY STEPS TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
CAN COUNT ON THESE PROTECTIONS
BEING THERE. SECOND PLAN SHOULD
HAVE RESERVES THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT BUT NOT EXCESSIVE.
THIRD CONSUMERS AND OTHER
PURCHASERS SUCH AS EMPLOYERS
AND TRUST FUND SHOULD NOT FACE.
UNJUSTIFIED RATE SPIKES FROM
HEALTH PANS NEXT YEAR OR PRICE
HIKES BY PROVIDERS TRYING TO
MAKEUP BUT BUT THEY LOST BY
CHARGING HIGHER PRICES. AND NO
ONE SHOULD FACE A SURPRISE
MEDICAL BILL ONE MAY END UP OUT
OF NETWORK BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. FOR UNDERSERVED AREAS
IN UNDERSERVED PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD COME FIRST IN
TERMS OF HELP BEING PROVIDED IN
PARTICULAR CARE SHOULD BE TAKEN
TO ASSURE THAT THE MEDI CAL
NETWORKS INCLUDING COMMUNITY
CLINICS IN COUNTY HOSPITALS
HAVE GOOD RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO SERVE THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO RELY ON THEM
AND THE MILLIONS MORE
CALIFORNIANS SHORTEN YOUR NEWLY
UNEMPLOYED AND TURN. MEDI CAL.
AND WE NEED TO MOVE TO A WORLD
IN WHICH ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS IMMIGRATION STATUS
ALL FAMILIES IN NEED CAN COUNT
ON HAVING HEALTH INSURANCE. AT
A MINIMUM WE WOULD ASK THAT THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL REQUIRE
MORE FREQUENT MONITORING OF
WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING ON VERSUS
WHAT WAS EXPECTED. AS YOU HEARD
WE CAN EXPECT SOME FINANCIAL
REPORTING BOTH IN MID MAY AND
AUGUST BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUGGEST THAT WE LOOK AT
QUARTERLY REPORTING ON THE
IMPACT ON RATES IN THE MEDICAL
LOSS RATIO FOR THE REST OF THIS
YEAR AND FOR THE NEXT YEAR OR
TWO AS WE DEAL WITH THIS
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU AND WITH THE CONCLUSION OF
PANEL ONE I WILL NOW TURN IT TO
MEMBERS TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS. DOCTOR WHAT. YES I'D
LIKE THANK THANK THE EXCUSE ME
HARD TO TALK WITH THIS THING ON
SO THANK YOU TO THE PANELISTS
SO MUCH APPRECIATED- QUESTION.
FOR CARMELLA COIL USE YOU STILL
ON THE LINE KAMALA. YES I AM
SO- I WE HEARD YOUR PLEA FOR
XCELERATED PAYMENTS- ALSO HEARD
MR LOUISE- SAY THAT THERE ARE
XCELERATED PAYMENTS. SO I'M
CURIOUS ARE THERE XCELERATED
PAYMENTS. BECAUSE I'D FEELING
TO DISCONNECT. YES I THINK THAT
DISCONNECT- IS IN THE NUMBER OF
PLANNED TO ARE OFFERING OPTIONS
AND ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITALS- WE HAVE- AND ARE
AWARE OF A COUPLE OF PLANTS
WERE OPERATING OFFERING
XCELERATED PAYMENTS BUT IT IS
BY NO MEANS OF THE MAJORITY OF
PLANS- SO XCELERATED PAYMENTS
ARE KEY- THIS NOTION OF-
PUSHING MORE OF THE INSURANCE
DOLLAR. INTO PROVIDERS IS GOING
TO BE CRITICAL I THINK AS
EVERYONE KNOWS THE WAY THE
SYSTEM WORKS TODAY IS WE HAVE
PROVIDERS HAVE TO SPEND MONTHS
WORKING IN RECONCILIATION
PROCESS SEES WITH INSURERS AND
THEN THE PAYMENT FLOWS WE THINK
THAT OUGHT TO BE FLIPPED IN THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY WE OUGHT TO
HAVE THE PAYMENT FLOW FIRST AND
THEN WE CAN RECONCILE LATER-
BUT WE CERTAINLY DO NOT HAVE
THE BREAD OR SCOPE OF
ASSISTANCE AND HELP. THAT IS
NEEDED RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU-
MISTER LOUISE US JUST A
DIFFERENT QUESTION- ACTUALLY
AND THAT'S- HEARD RECENTLY
THAT- BLUESHIELD IS ACTUALLY-
PLEDGED TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO HELP PROVIDERS ARE
THERE ANY OTHER PLANS THAT ARE
ARE PLANNING TO DO SOMETHING.
YES IN FACT THE PLANT HAVE YES
BESIDE BLUESHIELD- WHICH ONES I
DO. YES THANK YOU LET ME. BY MY
NOTES HERE. I'M GONNA GO DOWN
THE LIST HERE IN A SECOND. I
WILL SAY THAT. IN ADDITION TO
BLUE SHIELD ONE PLAN
NATIONALLY- UAG ON HAVE
DEDICATED A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
NATIONAL PUSH FOR XCELERATED
PAYMENTS AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT
TO THE PROVIDER PARTNERS ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES CAN FOCUS ON
DELIVERING NEEDED CARE ABOUT
FIFTY MILLION OF THAT THOSE
DOLLARS- ARE DEDICATED TO
CALIFORNIA- ANOTHER PLAN IS
DOING A SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
SYSTEMS PACKAGED HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS IN ACCELERATE CLAIMS
PAYMENTS. UNDER THEIR NETWORKS
TO HELP ADDRESS THE FINANCIAL
PRESSURE CAUSED BY THE
PANDEMIC- ONE OF OUR PLANS IN
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM IN IS
DOCTOR GILBERT- STATED EARLIER
SEVERAL PLANS ARE STEPPING UP
IN MEDI CAL- BUT ONE OF OUR
PLANES DOING ABOUT A SIX
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE TO SUPPORT
MEDI CAL PROVIDERS- IMPACTED BY
THE OUTBREAK IN. THAT'S
PRIMARILY FOCUS ON TELEHEALTH
CAPACITY FOR CLINICS CENTERS
AND OTHER PRACTICES- AND I
BELIEVE THAT SEVENTEEN THAT
DOING THAT- WHAT I DID I
DISTRIBUTED A FACT SHEET TO THE
MEMBERS OF OFFICES THAT- LIST
ALL THE VARIOUS EFFORTS OF THE
PLANS ARE DOING ALONG THOSE
LINES WITH THAT THAT'S JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF A SUMMARY OF SOME OF
THE- ACTIVITIES ARE BEING
PERFORMED AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU I JUST. WANNA POKE THANK
THEN AND THERE ARE AS WELL OKAY
I WANNA POKE THANK. THAT'S AT
THE SAVES. EFFORT AND I HOPE
THAT OTHERS IN- FOLLOW SUIT-
THAT'S IT THAT'S PRETTY BIG
ONE- WITH REGARDS TO IN THIS
ALSO WITH MR LOUISE AS WITH
REGARDS TO TELEHEALTH- I'M
HEARING FROM. PEOPLE THAT HAVE
FROM FROM PHYSICIANS ACTUALLY
THAT- IF YOU'RE PART OF A MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE PLAN OR OR OR
YOU'RE PART OF AN FQHC. WITH
REGARD TO TELL HEALTH- THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING- TELEPHONIC-
FEES COMPARABLE THE TELEHEALTH
AND THAT'S SIGNIFICANT FOR
SOMEONE LIKE IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE WE HAVE. A LOT OF FOLKS
THAT DON'T HAVE BROADBAND
ACCESS AND SO- AND OLDER PEOPLE
WHO MAY NOT HAVE THE- HARDWARE
AND KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW TO
ACCESS HOW TO ACCESS
TELEHEALTH. SO BUT ANY PRIVATE
PRACTICE THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THE SAME. BY THE
SAME CONSIDERATION- IS THAT A
PLAN BY PLAN DECISION- AND IT
FEELS A LITTLE UNFAIR TO THOSE
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ACCESS-
TELEHEALTH- BUT COULD ACCESS. A
PHONE. ND THE DOCTOR IN
PARTICULAR IS TO SPEND THE SAME
AMOUNT OF TIME WITH THAT PERSON
IT MAY NOT BE FACE TO FACE BUT
IN THESE TIMES IT'S- YEAH I
THINK IT WOULD IT SEEMS
REASONABLE TO EXPECT A SIMILAR
COMPENSATION- IS. CAN YOU SHED
SOME LIGHT ON THAT. SO. I GUESS
SO THIS IS THE PAYMENT PARITY
ISSUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
GETTING YOUR QUESTION- I'D LIKE
TO HIT ON THE HEAD YEAH YEAH SO
I MEAN BREAK THE ICE OF THE IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE AN FQHC OR
YOUR- YOU'RE YOU'RE GETTING
ONE. OF FORM OF PAYMENT BUT IF
YOU'RE IN PRIVATE PRACTICE IS A
PHYSICIAN. YOU'RE GETTING LESS
OR- YOU'RE NOT THERE'S NO ACT
THERE THERE IS NO PARITY THERE.
IN SOME CASE OKAY WELL I NINE
YEAH I KNOW AND I AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION I THINK
THERE ARE SOME NUANCES THERE
THAT I MIGHT HAVE TO
INVESTIGATE- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
HEARD ABOUT THIS ISSUE FROM
EITHER YOU OR YOUR STAFF AND WE
REACHED OUT TO TRY TO RESOLVE
IT- IN SADDAM'S MORE SPECIFIC
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE HELPFUL. I
MEAN YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE
AGUIAR-CURRY BILL WAS PASSED
LAST YEAR IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE HAS
ACCELERATED IMPLEMENTATION- I'D
HAVE TO REVIEW THE GUIDANCE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
WHETHER THAT EXTEND OUTSIDE OF
THE COMMERCIAL MARKETING TO-
EIGHTEEN INTO INTO THE PUBLIC
SPHERE. ENCOMPASSES THE PAYMENT
RATES FOR FQHCS- IT IF I COULD
KNOW THAT AND GET BACK TO YOU
SO WE'LL MEMBER NOT TRYING TO.
BE OBSTINATE HERE I DON'T KNOW
THE TECHNICALITIES OF THE RULE
OR HOW WOULD APPLY IN THAT CASE
I DO KNOW. THAT YOU KNOW MANY
OF OUR PLANS AND MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE STEPPED UP
INDIVIDUALLY. TO JOB. THE
INCREASE ACCESS TO HEALTH. INTO
SUPPORT PROVIDERS PROVIDING
TELEHEALTH- YOU KNOW BUT I YOU
KNOW I DO CAN BE YOU KNOW
LOOKING INTO IT AND TO TRY TO
RESOLVE- NEAR ANY ISSUES THAT
ARE COMING UP IN YOUR DISTRICT.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE HEARD
THAT. SOME OF THE AND THIS IS
IN AT THIS POINT ANECDOTAL
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBERS BUT I HAVE HEARD. THAT
SOME OF THE MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS HAVE BEEN SOME OF
THE SLOWEST. TO ACCELERATE
PAYMENTS- WHICH- I FIND PRETTY
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE YOU'RE
DEALING WITH OUR SAFETY NET
POPULATION. ALSO DEALING WITH
PAYMENTS TO HOSPITALS IN
PARTICULAR- SO I'D LOVE TO-
HAVE YOU EXPLORE THAT AS WELL.
HELLO YOU DELETE DOING NOTED
THANK YOU- AND THEN FINAL
QUESTION THIS IS FOR- SERRA-
HOW ARE YOUR DOCTORS THAT ARE
IN PRACTICE. ABLE TO GET ANY PP
TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES OBVIOUSLY
WE KNOW THAT- HOSPITALS ARE
GETTING PP COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE GETTING PP- ARM
HOW ARE YOUR DOCTORS DOING WITH
PP. PRIVATE PRACTICE HE IS AT
YEAH THANK YOU TV IS A HUGE
PROBLEM BURKE POSITIONS AND
PRACTICES ESPECIALLY IN THE
SMALLER ONES I THINK WE'VE SEEN
THIS AND THEN PRACTICE THAT
KIND OF POWER THE LITERAL WORLD
TO SEE IF THEY CAN FIND ANY I
KNOW WE'VE SEEN ADDITIONS
ACTUALLY ORDER PP FROM INDIA
FROM CHINA FROM SOUTH KOREA-
AND ARE SPENDING A LOT OF THEIR
TIME ACTUALLY LOOKING FOR IT.
COULD BE VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
HOW THEY USE PP I THINK WE'VE
SEEN WE USE OF PVC IF NOT KIND
OF BEST PRACTICES AT THIS POINT
BUT THEY'RE DOING WHATEVER THEY
CAN TO KEEP ORDER PATIENT FAITH
AND OUR STAFF SAY THE BUG SO IT
IT IS THAT IN A THEY AREN'T
KIND OF AT THE TABLE PRETY
LARGER SO IT MAKES IT HARDER I
THINK THEY'RE WORKING WITH EACH
OTHER AT THE WORKING WITH-
DENTAL OFFICES THAT DONATED
OTHER- PRACTICES WERE NOT. BE
HAVE BUT IT ONLY IS AN ISSUE
NOW KERN AND IS GOING TO BE A
BIGGER PROBLEM AS WE START WITH
MORE PATIENT CAN REOPEN
HEALTHCARE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALMOST. THANK YOU MISTER AND-
MY QUESTION IS FOR- MISTER
GILBERT NAM HOW YOU DOING MR
GOVERNOR WE'VE KNOWN EACH OTHER
FROM SUMMER DEAL COUNTY WORKED
ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
DOWN IN THAT AREA. MY QUESTIONS
ARE- CENTERED AROUND A MENTAL
HEALTH- INSANE- THE NEED FOR
BETTER COMMUNICATION HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO BUILD- BETWEEN
AGENCIES- THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS
THE- ISSUES OF MENTAL HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. ESPECIALLY
SEEN- HERE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CONVERSATIONS- THIS
MONTH. ON MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
HOW DO WE SEE THIS NEED AND HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WERE-
PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE AND
BUILDING- THE COMMUNICATION-%
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK YOU
MEMBER RAMOS IN THE US- CLUTTER
WORKED WITH YOU PREVIOUSLY. I
THINK THERE'S A COUPLE OF
PIECES OF THAT I MEAN ONE IS
HAVING YOU KNOW REALLY
INTEGRATED THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT. ENTER THE PART OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND REALLY
MAKING IT AN INTEGRATED PART OF
US. THAT HELPS A LOT SO YOU
KNOW OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
AN S. U. D. TEAM. HAS BEEN
REALLY REALLY CLOSE CONTACT
WITH THE COUNTIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU KNOW WERE WERE
ASSESSING HOW THEY'RE DOING
WE'VE DONE- A SURVEY OF. WHAT
SERVICES ARE ABLE TO DELIVER-
BUT AND YOU KNOW CONSTANT
CONTACT WITH THEM ABOUT THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO. TO GET FROM NON CMS
AROUND THINGS LIKE TELEHEALTH.
AROUND TURN INTO CARE SIDE SO
THE CARE CAN BE DELIVERED. YOU
KNOW IN LOCATIONS THAT ARE NOT
YOUR TYPICAL YOU KNOW OFFICE
SETTING. AND THEN IN ADDITION
THE OTHER PIECES YOU KNOW IN
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM FOR
DELIVERY OF BEHAVE WELL. IT IS
THROUGH THE HEALTH PLAN. THAT
WE PROVIDE THE CARE FOR. WATER
TERM TO MY TO MODERATE INTO
VERSUS THE SERIES MENTALLY ILL
BUT CARE FOR COUNTY SO. OF ALL
THE STATE LEVEL THE INTEGRATED
UP. YOU KNOW CAN NOW ALL THOSE.
TO AND REALLY CAUSED COMMUNITY.
WITH YOU KNOW BOTH PARTS OF THE
SYSTEM BECAUSE IT IS. YOU KNOW
INDIVIDUALS IN MEDI CAL OR
CARED FOR HIM IN BOTH- HEALTH
PLANS AND BY THE COUNTIES. SO I
DO FEEL LIKE IT AT OUR LEVEL
THE STATE LEVEL IN OUR IN OUR
DEEP CONNECTION. TO THE
COUNTIES IN THE HEALTH PLANS
YOU KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO CONTINUE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
AND KEEP THINKING OF WAYS. FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW HE
SEE AND TALK TO AND CONNECT
WITH. WHAT THE- PATIENTS AND
CLIENTS. AND OF COURSE AS
MENTIONED YOU KNOW TELL HEALTH
OF HEALTH BUT THAT'LL TURN TO
CARE SITES. SO I DO I DO FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THAT LEVEL OF
CONNECTION AND INTEGRATION.
ALWAYS MORE TO DO- THERE'S
ALWAYS THAT MOVEMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS KIND OF BETWEEN THE
TWO SYSTEMS. AND SO YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE BOTH THE HEALTH
PLANS IN THE COUNTIES ARE
TALKING LOCALLY- WHICH IS YOU
KNOW IN THE INLANDEMPIRE WAS
WAS VERY POSITIVE- SO THAT.
INDIVIDUAL THE THEY MOVE AND
GET BETTER OR GET WORSE. YOU
KNOW OR DON'T ALL BETWEEN THE-
THANK YOU THANK FOR THAT AND-
pWE KNOW THE THERE'S A BIG NEED
THEIR- BUT ALSO NERVE WORLD
FULL COMMUNITY. AND AS WE START
THE- PROCESS. I WOULDN'T
REACHING OUT TO THE- INDIAN
HEALTH SERVICES- WITH THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES TO START TO
BRIDGE THAT GAP THAT'S THERE
FOR THE NECESSARY RESOURCES
THAT ARE THERE. I DO HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION- MISTER CHAIR.
AND THAT GOES TO- WITH THE
HOSPITALS- AS WE START TO HEAR-
MOVING FORWARD. WITH THAT THAT
THE- THE WORKLOAD AND ELECTIVE
SURGERIES AND- SOME OF THE-
POST SURGERIES- THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED THAT NOW
WILL TAKE PLACE TO STRESS TO
SEE THAT. THAT COST FACTOR
COMING IN- AND SO WE
UNDERSTAND- THE BURDEN. THAT'S
THERE BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND.
THAT IN ORDER TO BE A FISH IN
THE WORK FORCE- THAT'S ENGAGED
IN THE HOSPITAL'S. ALSO HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO BE PART OF THAT LONG
TERM PLAN. A LONG TERM PLAN OF
PP EASE HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THOSE
ON THE FRONT LINES HEALTHCARE
WORKERS ARE THERE. AND THE DOT
EVERYBODY- MOVING FORWARD WE
SEEN THAT THE SHORTAGE WE HERE-
THE NEED AND WE HEARD IN SOME
OF THE PRESENTATIONS. OF SOME-
PHYSICIANS- GOING AS FAR AS
INDIA TO GET. THE NEEDED PPVS
WE LOOK FORWARD. LONG TERM
PLANNING HOW WILL WE NOW IT
JUST FOR THAT HOW WILL WE BE
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER TO START
TO ADDRESS ALL THOSE ISSUES
FROM THE HEALTHCARE WORKERS PP
LONG TERM- AIDS THAT ARE THERE.
AS WELL AS THE PHYSICIAN SO
I'LL BE LOOKING FOR A SEAT IN.
SOME TYPE OF PLAN COME FORWARD
AT LEAST AT. THAT TALK ABOUT
ALTHOUGH. THERE INCLUDED THE
FRONT LINES. THANK YOU NOT
QUESTION YOUR APPS RIGHT WE GOT
A PROTECT EVERYONE. AND WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AT BEST WE
CAN- THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT WE HAVE JOINED WITH FEI
YOU. IN REALLY ASKING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO THINK ABOUT
THIS LONG TERM PLAN WHAT SHOULD
THE PROCESS LOOK LIKE HOW DO WE
REPLENISH AND NOT JUST
REPLENISH BUT BUILD UP THE
STATE STOCKPILE. AND HOW CAN WE
COLLECTIVELY WORK PUBLIC SECTOR
PRIVATE SECTOR TO THEN ON. AND
WHAT WE NEED AND HOW THAT
SHOULD BE ALLOCATED FAIRLY SO
WE ARE PLEASED TO JOIN WITH ARE
AT THE ARE YOU PARTNERS IN THAT
LONG TERM PLANNING. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER- CHAIR MINE IS MORE OF A
GENERAL I'M A TAKE THIS OFF AS
WELL GENERAL OF THE QUESTION OR
OR COMMENT I DID SOME WORK LAST
YEAR- IN REGARDS TO NURSING
STUDENTS I KNOW THAT WE DON'T
KNOW THE EFFECTS OF THE WORK
FORCE YET BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
GOING THROUGH THIS- BUT MY-
QUESTION REQUEST- IS I KNOW
THAT- WHEN A NURSING STUDENT
GOES THROUGH- PULLING THE
GARMENT. UP TO DO SO THE CALL
OF WORK IN THE HOSPITALS IN
ORDER TO BE A TO EARN THEIR
THIRD CERTIFICATION HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF MBANK THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO TAKE THOSE COURSES AND
I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR- ROUTE
CHANGE THE REQUIREMENTS SO THAT
THEY CAN DO SIMULATION RATHER
THAN BEING IN THE HOSPITALS
FOUR FIVE TO GET BACK TO AYE
TRAINING HOWEVER FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND THE PERCENTAGE IS
ALMOST REACHED AND IT'S
STARTING UP A WHOLE BUNCH OF
NURSES. CAN SEED WITH THEIR
CERTIFICATION BECAUSE NOW THEY
CAN GET THE TRAINING IN THE
HOSPITALS SO IS THERE ANY
CONVERSATION OR ANY- JUST
COMMENTS ABOUT CHANGING THAT
REQUIREMENT GAME I BELIEVE HE
CHANGED IT 250% ON THIRD-
TRAINING TO BE DONE I COULD BE
DONE THROUGH A SIMULATION IF
THEY REACH THAT ONE IS THERE A
PLAN TO CHANGE THAT OR GOING
FORWARD IS DURING THE PLAN ON
MAKING SURE THAT THESE NURSES
ARE READY TO GRADUATE AS SOON
AS THEY THEIR THEIR CLINICAL
HOURS. WE MOVE THEM FORWARD
BECAUSE I THINK. THE D. UP WORK
IS GOING TO CHANGE DRAMATICALLY
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC I'M-
JUST THINKING AHEAD THAT SOME
OF THESE NURSING- NURSES ARE
GOING TO BE EXHAUSTED OR OR A
LOT OF THEM WILL RETIRE GET OUT
OF THE FIELD AFTER THIS- FOR
VARIOUS REASONS AND IS THERE
ANY PLAN TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE NURSING STUDENTS GAP. GET
THE APPROPRIATE CERTIFICATION
SO THAT WE CAN PLAN FOR FUTURE-
WORK FORCE- IF AND WHEN IF THE
SURGE DOES OCCUR OR JUST
LOOKING FORWARD WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT NURSES NURSING
STUDENTS. ARE CERTIFIED SO IF
WE NEED THEM AND THEN FUTURE
THAT THEY'RE AVAILABLE IT'S
LIKE A LONG WINDED BUT AGAIN
BUT THE QUESTION IS- IS DURING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT CHANGING
THE REQUIRED CLINICAL HOURS- TO
DO MORE- THE SIMULATION RATHER
THAN IN HOUSE TRAINING. AND IT
CANNELLA COIL ON AT EIGHT THINK
THAT QUESTION MAYBE OF ME- I DO
NOT HAVE ALL OF THE DETAILS ON
THE LATEST CONVERSATIONS WHEN I
CAN SAY IS WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CAREFULLY TO TRY TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
GET OUR NURSING STUDENTS THE
TRAINING THAT THEY NEED YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE'S
NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT THAN
STRENGTHENING OUR WORKFORCE AT
THIS POINT IN TIME AS WE PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE. OF COURSE IT
HAD BEEN ANYTHING- OTHER THAN
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY AS USUAL-
WHICH REALLY MADE IT THIS FAR
MORE DIFFICULT FOR STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE- THEIR THEIR CLINICAL
TRAINING- BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND DO WHAT WE CAN TO MAKE SURE.
HAVE GOT ALL OF THE NURSES YOU
KNOW. IT APPEARS TO BE ABLE TO
FORCES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THERE'S ANY UPDATE CAN YOU PULL
GET THAT INFORMATION TO US I'D
BE INTERESTED IN AND SEEING- IF
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE
COULD DO TO HELP- BE IT YOU
KNOW WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AND- BUILD A CASE FOR EITHER
YOU KNOW EXTENDING THE
SIMULATION OR MAKING SOME
CHANGES. BUT THAT SHE WOULD ARE
KEEN EXPERT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OR TO
TALK THROUGH THESE THINGS SO I
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR WORK ON
THIS SUBJECT IN KEEPING US UP
TO DATE AND I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR BEING. OF UP FRONT IN
GOING FORWARD WITH THIS- VERY
DIFFICULT PROCESS AND WHERE
WE'RE AT. IT WITH THE SPEND
EMIC BUT MY QUESTION IS AND TO
THE PANEL AS A WHOLE. THE LAST
YEAR SO WE FOUND THAT THERE'S
BEEN OVER A TWO BILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIENCY AND FUNDING FOR THE
SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATIONS RIGHT
TO DEMAND. AND WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR IS. WE ALWAYS HAVE SEEM TO
HISTORICALLY IN THE PAST-
UTILIZE THAT BUDGET LINE TO CUT.
HI THIS IS POPULATION- AND HE
JUST HAD BEEN IN THE NEAR IN
THE NEAR FUTURE RECENTLY AS WE
WERE STARTING TO MAKE STRIDES
FORWARD NO WAS- LOOKING AT DULY
DIAGNOSED INDIVIDUALS WITH
NINETY D. INTERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH. CONDITION WE'RE SEEING
THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED MORE HELP
FROM THE HEALTH PLANS TO POP
YOU HELP THIS POPULATION GOING
FORWARD AGAIN THE RATE STUDY
ACKNOWLEDGED OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF DEFICIENCIES-
GOING FORWARD WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT THE HEALTH PLANS ARE GOING
TO DO FOR THIS VERY VULNERABLE
POPULATION OF AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
COME TO SOME SOLUTION A
BECAUSE- WE CAN'T DO IT IS A
STATE OBVIOUSLY WITH BUT END UP
THANK COMING FORWARD. IT'S GOOD
A VILLAGE I WANNA KNOW WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO BE WITH THAT. I
THINK THE QUESTION MAY BE
DIRECTED AT UNIVAC SINCE HE
SPOKE ABOUT THE PLANS BUT MOST
OF THAT MAY BE- AND CAN BE
SAFER DIRECTOR BARGE MEN
DURING- DDS AND THE NEXT PANEL.
WANTED TO SEE IF- NECK YOU HAD
ANY COMMENTS ON. YEAH NO I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS IN.
YEAH THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER AND MISTER CHAIR INS NO
WHILE- YOU KNOW MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS
TREATMENT PARITY ON IT IS
ESTABLISHED FIRMLY LAW BOTH AT
THE STATE. I'M IN FEDERAL
LEVEL- YOU KNOW. ENSURING THAT
WE ALL HAVE THE TOOLS AND THE
PEOPLE NEED TO DELIVER ON ON
THE PROMISE OF YOU KNOW SERVING
THIS VOLATILE POPULATION IS. IS
CRITICAL IT IN AND WE FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT IT'S A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY WE ARE NOT ONLY
AMONG STATE LEADERS HEALTH
PLANS PROVIDERS. ON END AND OF
COURSE THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ADVOCATES AND- WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE-
ARE THERE CHALLENGES THAT YOU
KNOW ABSOLUTELY THEIR
CHALLENGES AND ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGES. YOU KNOW
THE OUTLINED IN A TWENTY
NINETEEN YOU KNOW WORKFORCE
REPORTS THAT. CALIFORNIA WILL
HAVE 50% FEWER PSYCHIATRISTS
AND 28% FEWER PSYCHOLOGIST. M.
F. T. USE AND LICENSED
COUNSELORS AND SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SO. THAT IS A HUGE
CHALLENGE AND I THINK YOU KNOW.
TO A CERTAIN DEGREE THAT
CHALLENGE MIGHT BE EXASPERATED
EXACERBATED THAT IS. USE ME YOU
KNOW BY THE BY THE EFFECTS OF
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC ENVY
ARE YOU KNOW. A TEMPORARY
SHUTDOWN OF MEDICAL SYSTEM
WHICH IS AGAIN HOLY REOPENING
SO- YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO DIE YEAH
WORK WORK WITH YOU ON YOU KNOW
MOVING FORWARD- YOU KNOW WE-
EATING IN IMPROVING ACCESS TO
CARE SO- IT'S A GOOD QUESTION
SOMETHING THAT- THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE CARE DEEPLY ABOUT AND-
YOU KNOW LOOK FOR HAVING.
RESERVATIONS ONCE THE DUST HAS
SETTLED- AND- AND WE GET A
BETTER VIEW OF THE LANDSCAPE
ONCE OUR ECONOMY AND MEDICAL
SYSTEM OPEN UP AGAIN. THANK YOU
AND- IF I MAY SINCE WE HAVE-
ANSWERED AND ASKED ALL
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS
BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE CHAIR.
AND I'D LIKE TO START IF I CAN
WITH- THE LA IS OFFICE AND YOU-
BEN JOHNSON. BECAUSE I THOUGHT
YOU LAID OUT THE PROBLEM QUITE
WELL AS YOU NORMALLY DO. THAT
THERE WERE INCREASED COSTS THAT
WERE ATTRIBUTED FROM- PP OR
FROM OVERTIME TO HAZARD PAY FOR
PROVIDERS. AS WELL AS MODIFYING
FACILITIES THAT CAME WITH COPA
NINETEEN. AT A TIME WHEN WE HAD
REDUCED VOLUME OF SERVICES AND
REVENUE LOSSES OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. NOW YOU HAD MENTIONED-
MISTER JOHNSON THAT IN THE
FEDERAL CARES ACT THERE WAS
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN RELIEF
AND YOU ALSO STATED THAT THE
FEDERAL- FQHCS HAD RECEIVED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN A SEPARATE
POT OF MONEY. AND THAT THEY
SHOULD KEEP DOORS OPEN AND
PEOPLE EMPLOYED. BUT I THINK MY
QUESTION FOR YOU IS FOR HOW
LONG. HOW LONG CAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT
THAT IS- OCT I QUESTION THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A FIRM ANSWER TO-
BOTH ON THE COST SIDE IN THE
REVENUE SIDE WE REALLY DON'T
HAVE- A LOT. ACTUALLY THE
FISCAL IMPACT ARE HOPEFULLY IN
THE COMING MONTHS YOU KNOW WE
WILL HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION- ON PROJECTIONS
WITHIN THE MEDIC CAL PROGRAM
AND OTHER SOURCES OF
INFORMATION THAT COULD- SHINE
SOME LIGHT ON THE EXACT REVENUE
AND COST- IMPACTS OF KOBE
NINETEEN AND AT THAT TIME- YEAH
NOW IS IT EVEN IF IT'S
UNFORTUNATE WE COULDN'T HAVE
THAT TODAY. AT THAT TIME THAT
WE COULD REALLY BETTER I THINK
UNDERSTAND- DOES THAT SORT OF.
IF YOU KNOW THE PROBLEM THAT
NEEDS THAT IS. ACTS ARE GOING
TO- BECAUSE PROVIDERS TO NEEDED
YOU KNOW WE THINK WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'RE GONNA ONE MAN
OPENED OUR OPEN BACK UP SO
COLLEGE GUYS THAT COULD NOT
SORT OF CLEAR INFORMATION AT
THIS TIME BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR- ASWE AS WE EVALUATE
THE BUDGET AND THE SITUATIONON
THE GROUND. AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE MODEL OF- THIS IS-
RETROSPECTIVE AS WE HAVE TO
EVALUATE **** HAS OCCURRED IN
THE PAST IN TERMS OF SPENDING.
BUT DIDN'T WANT TO COME BACK TO
SOMETHING THAT NICK LOUISE US
HAD SAID WHEN HE SAID THAT THEY
HAVE NOT SEEN COSTS INCREASE
YET SO FAR FOR THE PLANTS. THAT
THEY'RE CURRENTLY WAS A
TEMPORARY REDUCTION. AND WITH
THAT I'M TRYING TO BALANCE WHAT
I'M HEARING FROM THE HOSPITALS
WHO SAY THEY'RE HAVING
DEVASTATING FINANCIAL
CONSEQUENCES AS WELL AS WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY SAYING THAT THERE ARE
FOR ALLOWING EMPLOYEES AND
CLOSING DOORS. AND SO I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF I COULD
AND I DON'T MEAN TO PUT YOU ON
THE SPOT DIRECTOR REALLY AREN'T
OR DIRECTOR GILBERT. BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT. YOUR COMMENTS
ARE QUESTIONING WHETHER
PROVIDER NETWORKS ARE GOING TO
CHANGE AND THAT THESE ARE
TEMPORARY CLOSURES. AND YET I'M
TRYING TO REALLY GET AT THE
FINANCES HERE. IS RE
FOR A MEDIA SUPPORT OF OUR
CURRENT HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO HELP US
BLUEY THROUGH THIS CRISIS. LIKE
I CAN START BECAUSE OF THE-
DOCTOR GO OVER TIME AND I THINK.
I WOULD I KNOW CARMELA'S TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE LEVEL OF
ACTIVITY IN THE VARIOUS PLANS
BUT I MEAN I'M LOOKING AT A-
GRID IN FRONT OF ME OF THE
ACTIVITY FROM. THE MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS ADVANCING
PAPER PERFORMANCE CAPITATION
ARE CLAIMS PAYMENT ADVANCES
CHANGING FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO CAPITATED REMEMBER AND- THAT
MANY OF THE PROVIDERS MANY.
SOME ARE PULLED MANY PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS ARE ALREADY
CAPITATED AND THEREFORE WOULD
NEVER DECREASE IN INCOME YOU
KNOW BASED ON UTILIZATION.
EXPEDITING PAYMENTS- YOU KNOW
PROVIDER GRANTS XCELERATED
CLAIMS PAYMENT SO. WE ARE
SEEING A FAIR AMOUNT OF
ACTIVITY ON THE MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE SIDE OF PLANS
TRYING TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS
WHETHER IT'S CLINICS. HOSPITALS
PRIVATE PROVIDERS BETTER- BUT
I'VE GOT A YOU KNOW FERMENTED
DETAIL ON ON THEM PROVIDING
THAT SUPPORT. TO YOUR POINT
THOUGH I THINK THERE IS A
CONCERN THAT YOU KNOW CLOSURES
THAT ARE HAPPENING NOW. YOU
KNOW KAISER CLOSING CLINICS IN
CONSOLIDATING SOME FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS THAT
HAVE MULTIPLE NIXON ERICA.
CLOSING ONE OR TO CONSOLE THEIR
EMPLOYEES YOU KNOW TO BE ABLE
TO BE MORE EFFICIENT- SO THEIR
TEMPORARY. AND PAUL COMES BACK
ACTIVE STARTED THAT. THAT THEY
WOULD RE OPEN BUT WE CANNOT BE
ASSURED OF THAT AND THAT TO ALL
THE POINTS BY SERRA IN CARMEL
ANOTHER'S. VERY CONCERNING SO.
I WOULD SAY YES FOR UTILIZATION
DECREASING PLANTER RESPONDING
TO THAT CERTAINLY ON THE
MEDICAL SIDE- AND WE HOPE THAT
WILL HELP SUSTAIN THE NETWORKS
AND IN KEEPING VIABLE. MR CARE
THISIS SHELLY RELIED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE JUST TO RESPOND AND
TRY TO ECHO WHAT DOCTOR GILBERT
WAS JUST SAYING WITH RESPECT TO
THE CLAMP ACTIVITIES- FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW THE
ACTIVITIES VERY BY PLAN WE HAVE
SOME PRETTY SMALL PLANTS THAT
JUST DON'T HAVE THE CAPABILITY
TO USE SOME OF THAT- ADVANCE.
AND THEN THINGS THAT ARE THE
PROVIDERS TO BE REFLECTED BUT
THERE ARE PLANS THAT WE ARE
AWARE OF THAT ARE- TRYING TO
GET THOSE BACK CLEAN HEY IT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- AND TRYING
TO- REDUCE SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PARKING YOU KNOW
SO THAT THEY CAN GET MONEY OUT
QUICKER- NICOLINO TO REFERENCE-
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FROM HELP
AND THAT IS. SHORT TELEHEALTH
PARTICULARLY. FOR THE CLUB AND
PROVIDERS TO FOR LARGE
POPULATION OF MEDICARE
PROVIDERS SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE. THAT THAT'LL IT DOES VERY
WE HAVE WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
TO THE PLANTS AT THE POINT TO
SPEND THEIR A- OF THEM THE WAY
THEY WHICH THEY ARE. THE
PROVIDERS WITH LIKE THEM BUT WE
WILL AS I SAID BEFORE YOU KNOW
BE LOOKING AT THEIR FINANCIAL
WILL BE ASKING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING HOW THEY'RE DOING IT AND
WHERE THE MONEY IS. IS GOING
AND THEY WILL NEED TO BE ABLE
TO- RAMP UP. PAYING FOR CARE
ONE. WE KIND OF GET THROUGH
THAT THE RIGHT NOW. IF I MAY
ALSO RESPOND TO OUR DOCTOR
WOULD QUESTION ABOUT
TELEPHONIC- VISIT- WE THE
DEPARTMENT RELEASED AND ALL
PLAN LETTER LAST MONTH THAT
ACTUALLY ABOUT A MONTH AGO-
DIRECTING HEALTH PLANS TO PAY.
UP FOR TELEHEALTH SERVICES
WHETHER IT'S BY VIDEO OR BY
PHONE- AT THE SAME RATE THAT
THEY WORK FOR AND- IN PERSON
DOES IT SO IF YOU HAVE AND
THAT'S IN THE COMMERCIAL WORLD
PARTICULARLY ON THE TELEPHONIC
THAT THERE MAY BE DIFFERENT
RULES FOR MEDI CAL WITH.
CALIFONE. SO IF THERE ARE
PROVIDE HOW THOSEPROBLEMS IN
THEY SHOULD COME. OUR BUT SO
AND SEE AN AD AND- AMERICAN
COME IN A MET. THEIR CONCERN
ABOUT THE BECAUSE THAT IS
SOMETHING WE CAN ENTER WHILE.
YEAH I WOULD BE A DOCTOR BUT TO
THE THAT. MEDI CAL THIS. THE
TELEPHONE IS AVAILABLE IN PAID
THE SAME RATE AS IN PERTH VISIT%
ATTEMPTING IN A NUMBER OF THIS
DONALD THE FACT. AND IF I MAY
DIDN'T. PRESUME THAT WE COULD
DIRECT THE PLANS HOW TO SPEND
BUT MUCH LIKE CARMELLA STATED
IN HER TESTIMONY. I WOULD WANT
TO EMPOWER THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THIS GOVERNOR TO BRING THE
PLANS TO THE TABLE. TO HAVE A
FRANK DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
NEEDS OF OUR HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR STATE.
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT'S
IMPERATIVE TO LISTEN TO THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
BEING HEROES DOING THE WORK
NOW. WHEN OUR HOSPITALS AND
PROVIDERS ARE STATING CLEARLY
TO ME THAT THEY HAVE NEEDS I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO LISTEN TO
THEM IN THE MOMENT. AND I THINK
MY QUESTION IF I COULD IS.
GOING TO BE DIRECTOR THAT YOU
NEXT- HOW COULD WE ENCOURAGE
MORE TIMELY PAYMENTS HOW COULD
WE- ALLOW PLANS TO UNDERSTAND
THE CURRENT NEEDS OF. THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND RESPOND
IN A MOMENT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION-
I THINK OUR MEMBERS DO
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS- AND AS I
STATED IN MY OPENING REMARKS-
OUR DOOR IS ALWAYS OPEN YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THERE HAS TO BE
A WILLINGNESS TO WALK THROUGH
THAT DOOR- OUR STAFF HERE AT
CAP. ON HAS BEEN IN REGULAR
CONTACT WITH THE- PROVIDER
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS OF NOT JUST
TO SORT THROUGH CASE BY CASE
SCENARIOS BUT- TO TALK ABOUT
KIND OF THE MORE A GLOBALIST
TAKE ISSUES- THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING SO- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO SIT DOWN
AND TALK I THINK YOU KNOW
WHERE- YOU KNOW. THINGS GET.
RICKY IS YOU KNOW WHEN WE START
GOING DOWN THE PATH THAT- OF
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE EITHER RISKY
AT BEST OR- YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE
AT WORSE AND I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO BE WE HAVE TO TREAD
VERY DELICATELY HERE I MEAN
HEALTH PLAN GOT A LEGAL
OBLIGATION- TO- MAINTAIN THEIR
SOLVENCY UNDER THE KNOX KEEN
ACT AND I THINK ANY RASH
DECISIONS WOULD BE- WOULD BE
VERY PROBLEMATIC I MEAN THE
SOLVENCY OF COURSE IS A BASIC
CONSUMER PROTECTION I MEAN IT
ENSURES ENROLLEES. OUR CLAIMS
ARE PAID- AT PROVIDERS YOU KNOW
DON'T SUFFER UNPAID CLAIMS AND
POTENTIALLY- CONSULTANCY ON
THERE AND- WE JUST HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL ME WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE CONSEQUENCE OF JOB
LOSS GONNA BE AND IN THIS IN
THIS IDEA THAT HEALTH PLANS YOU
KNOW OUR COULD COLLECTING THE
SAME LEVEL OF PREMIUMS THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN SINCE THE
BEGINNING YEAR IS NOT NECESSARY
WE TO. ON THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
IS WE BELIEVE CAUSING A SHIFT
OF EMPLOYER BASED COVERAGE TO
EITHER SUBSIDIZED COVERAGE TO
COVER CALIFORNIA FOR THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM WHICH IS GOING
TO SEE AN INCREASE OF-
ACCORDING TO SOME ESTIMATES
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE TO TWO
MILLION- ENROLLEES- IN THAT
PROGRAM SO YOU KNOW IT IT WILL
SOON AT LEAST COME PLAY. IN
SOME IF NOT ALL IT'S MY
ACTUALLY BE LESS PREMIUM AS
RESULT OF THE IMPACT OF THE
CORONA SO YOU FACTOR THAT IN
YOU FACTOR IN THE UNKNOWN COST
OF CARE ONCE THE MEDICAL SYSTEM
REOPENS YOU FACTOR IN THE
UNKNOWN COST OF THE OF THE
SECOND SURGE. IF PEOPLE WANT TO
HER- AND EDUCATED STATED YOU
KNOW THE FINANCIAL HAVEN'T COME
IN FOR BE COVERT NINETEEN
RELATED COSTA WE'RE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING SO WE KNOW HOW
EXPENSE THAT IS- SO I THINK
THEY'RE JUST YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
TO BE REALLY REALLY CAREFUL-
DUE TO ALL OF THESE UNKNOWNS
AND ENDS AND. YOU HAVE TO THE
PLANT HAVE TO BE ABLE TO PLANT
MY IN ORDER TO CARE. OF THE
BEAST. COSTS IN IN THE IN.
CHECK THIRD FOURTH QUARTERS OF
THIS YEAR- SO WE WANT TO HAVE
THOSE. CONVERSATIONS BUT YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE TO BE REASONABLE
AND A AND- YOU KNOW AS THE
DIRECTOR YARD SAID EARLIER.
EACH PLAN IS DIFFERENT IS
SITUATED DIFFERENTLY- SOME OF
THEM ARE SMALL READABLE
REGIONAL THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SAME LEVEL. OF FINANCIAL
CAPACITY TO DO THE SAME THING
THIS SUMMER BIG PLANS DO. AND
SO EACH PLANET IS DOING WHAT
THEY CAN WITH IT YOU KNOW
WITHIN THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES AND
SO- YEAH I IT YOU KNOW. IN OUR
DOORS OPEN WE'VE WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE PROVIDER
ASSOCIATIONS. I AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE ALWAYS HAPPY TO CONTINUE
AS CONVERSATIONS. AND I DO
APPRECIATE THAT WILLINGNESS TO-
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS. YOU
KNOW I WOULDN'T- SHARE THOUGH
THAT- THAT PART OF YOUR
CONTRACTUAL RESPONSIBILITY IS
ALSO TO PROVIDE NETWORK
ADEQUACY AND- TIMELY RESPONSE
AND SOME OF THAT IS IN QUESTION
IF OUR ACCESS AND SERVICES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASED. IF OUR
CLINICS ARE FURLOUGHED OR PLOY
THESE ARE ARE FURLOUGHED AND
OUR CLINICS ARE SHUT DOWN I
HAVE A WORRY. THAT OUR PREMIUMS
WILL NOT GO TOWARDS THEIR
INTENDED PURPOSE. AND SO I DO
BRING A BIT OF- BATH COMPELS
APPROACH TO THIS WHICH IS THIS
IS A CONSUMER PROTECTION THIS
IS OUR MONEY IN THE FIRST
PLACE. AND I WOULD WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE PREMIUMS ARE
GOING OWARDS. HELPING TO
SUPPORT OUR CURRENT HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE MOMENT
AND WOULD ENCOURAGE YOUR
ORGANIZATION TO. SUPPORT AS
BEST YOU CAN THE PRACTICES THAT
THE BEST PRACTICES THAT. OTHER
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE DOING
SUCH AS TIMELY PAYMENTS SUCH AS
CAPITATED PAYMENT SUCH AS LOANS
TO. PROVIDERS THESE ARE THINGS
THAT CAN HELP US TO SUPPORT OUR
CURRENT HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN THE MOMENT
AND SO WOULD JUST ASK US TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AS I
THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE RIGHT NOW
FOR US TO SUPPORT OUR HEALTH
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE. WITH THAT
I WILL THANK THE DOCTOR WOULD
ACTUALLY. WELL YOU HAVE TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BUT I
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING- ONE
FINAL QUESTION AND THEN- AND
THIS IS A QUESTION- FOR CARMELO
BUT I WANT TO FRAME THIS A
LITTLE BIT BEFORE I ASK THE
QUESTION. WE KNOW THAT- THE
HOSPITALS ARE FACING-
SIGNIFICANT- DEADLINES AND PUT
AN X. AND LARGE EXPENDITURES
RELATED TO SEISMIC RETROFITS- I
THINK OF- DOCTOR ARAMBULA HAS A
HOSPITAL IN THE PHRASE IN THE
FRESNO COUNTY. THAT 90% OF THE
HOSPITAL IS EITHER MEDICARE OR
MEDIC CAL. AND THE COST FOR THE
SEISMIC RETROFIT IS ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS IF THEY WERE TO
REBUILD THE HOSPITAL IT WOULD
BE TWO BILLION DOLLARS. AT A
TIME WHEN REVENUE IS- SHE HAS
BEEN SHAKEN SO BADLY THAT-
HOSPITALS ARE LAYING OFF. I
BELIEVE AND I I'M I DON'T KNOW
WHY THIS NUMBER STICKS IN MY
MIND BUT IT DOES. THAT TOTAL
COST TO THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM-
HOSPITALS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS. SO I ASKED
THIS QUESTION IN A BUDGET-
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING. OVERSIGHT
HEARING TWO WEEKS AGO-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT- I
WANT TO ASK- TO- OUR FOLKS AT-
DH CS- IN ANYBODY ANYONE ELSE
WHO WANTS ANSWER. AFTER I GIVE
CARMELLA CHANCE TO ANSWER- WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS I THINK
THAT- WE HAVE HOSPITALS ARE ON
THE EDGE RIGHT NOW- WE HAVE
HOSPITALS IT WILL NOT SURVIVE.
AND THIS- YOU KNOW WITHOUT A
CHANGE IN THE DEADLINE OR SOME
RESTRUCTURING OF WHAT HOW WE
LOOK AT SEISMIC RETROFITS-
WE'RE GONNA LOSE HOSPITALS-
GOING FORWARD AT A TIME WHEN WE
NEED THEM THE MOST- CARRILLO I
KNOW YOU. TALKED ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLAR ASK- IS THEY'RE
ALSO GOING TO BE AN ASK AROUND
SEISMIC- BECAUSE I AM REALLY
CONCERNED- IN ONE OF MY
HOSPITALS IN IN OUR HUMBLE
COUNTY- IT'S WITH STOOD-
EARTHQUAKES IN THE SEVEN POINT
OH RANGE- AND NEVER LOST A DAY
OF SERVICE FOR EARTHQUAKE-
BEFORE AN EARTHQUAKE. YES THEY
MAY HAVE HAD TO LAY OFF THE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
AND THAT THEY ARE FACING HUGE
COSTS FOR- FOR RETROFIT SO-
IT'S GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE
ABOUT THE STATE AND OBVIOUSLY
WANT PEOPLE TO BE SAFE-
HOWEVER- I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BE AT A POINT. OF DO WE
BANKRUPT HOSPITALS- OR DO WE-
TO WE TRY WE DO DO WE- TAKE A
LITTLE BIT A DIFFERENT A
DIFFERENT APPROACH SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP HOSPITALS OPEN SO. I
GUESS I'D LIKE TO HAVE CARMELO-
COMMENT ON THAT AND THEN I'M
OPEN TO- TEAMMATE CD EIGHT C.
S. WHOEVER WANTS TO ANSWER THAT
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH DOCTOR WOULD FOR THE
QUESTION- YOUR NUMBERS ARE SPOT
ON- THE CITIES ARE A COST
ASSOCIATED WITH MEETING THE
TWENTY THIRTY. SEISMIC
REQUIREMENTS THAT EXCEED A
HUNDRED BILLION THAT HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
NUMBER. AND WHILE WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THAT CHALLENGE.
AND THE INCREDIBLE- DIFFICULTY
ASSOCIATED WITH TRYING TO MEET
THAT BEFORE CODED. IT REALLY
BECOMES AN IMPOSSIBILITY GIVEN
WHERE WE FIND OURSELVES AT THIS
JUNCTURE. AND SO I WHILE WE'RE
ALL VERY FOCUSED ON THE
IMMEDIATE SHORT TERM FINANCIAL
NEEDS OF THE HOSPITAL FIELD.
THIS TEN TO FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE CONVERSATIONS WITH
INSURERS IT IS TIME FOR ACTION
NOT CONVERSATIONS. IT IS TIME
FOR SYSTEMATIC CHANGE NOT CASE
BY CASE. EVALUATIONS BUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING BEHIND THE SCENES
IT'S NOT JUST THE SHORT TERM
IMPACT. ON THE HOSPITAL AND
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IT IS THE
LONG TERM DEPLETION OF THE
FINANCIAL STRENGTH OF THAT
SYSTEM. SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE SEISMIC
RETROFITTING. THAT REQUIRES THE
FINANCIAL STRENGTH FOR A
HOSPITAL ORGANIZATION TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO THE BOND MARKET.
BORROW MONEY TO DO THAT
CONSTRUCTION. ALL OF THOSE
THINGS REQUIRE A SOLID
FINANCIAL POSITION. IS
REQUIRED. TO GET LIQUIDITY IN
DAYS CASH ON HAND IN ORDER FOR
A BOND LENDERS TO BE WILLING
EVEN WHEN THE HOT. TO DO A
PROJECT OF THIS ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE. SO WHAT HAS HAPPENED
IN TERMS OF THE COVERT NIGHT
INNKREIS. THE ONLY HAVE WE TO
PLEASE BE IMMEDIATELY. OF WE
HAVE TAKEN THEIR LAW TERM FIND.
OUTLOOK AS WELL AND I'M CERTAIN
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE FICTION
MOVIES AND OTHERS I WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT THIS OVER TIME
BUT EVEN THE FEASIBILITY OF
BORROWING MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
THINK OF CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
OF THIS ORDER OF MAGNITUDE.
ADJUST DOESN'T ALIGN WITH THE
REALITY TO HAVE THAT WE HAVE
TODAY SO IMMEDIATE NEED IS
LIQUIDITY- SHORT TERM INJECTION
OF CASH INTO THE SYSTEM. LONGER
TERM WE'VE GOT TO REBUILD THAT
FINANCIAL STRENGTH AND I JUST
DON'T SEE THE FEASIBILITY OF A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS PLUS ON
TOP OF THE LOSSES THAT WE'RE
FACING AND WHAT WE NEED TO
BUILD TO PROTECTTHE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA MOVING AHEAD. DOCTOR
WOULD IT BRAD GILBERT FROM DID
SHOW UP ABOUT WILL TAKE I'LL
TAKE THAT BACK TO THE MAIN GOAL
OF OTHER DEPARTMENTS BESIDES.
DH YET FOR SURE SO WE SHOULD-
QUESTION AND COMMENT ALL I'LL
TAKE IT BACK. MICHAEL J. FROM
PROCEEDING- EDU LONG BAD OF A
PROPONENT OF THE STANDARDS
BECAUSE WE AS BEING THE IMPACT
OF NOT. PREPARING FOR POTENTIAL
EMERGENCY OUR WORK FORCE ATTACK
YOU SEE THAT RIGHT NOW WITH THE
SHORTAGE EP. SO YOU KNOW WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE FINANCIAL
POSITION THE HOSPITAL THEN WE'D
LIKE THAT YOU KNOW CONSIDER.
WORKING WITH THEM TO FIGURE OUT
YOU KNOW HOW CAN YOU CONTINUE
TO MEET THE STANDARDS- GIVEN
THAT HE'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS SO- JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
BAD. YOU THINK THAT THE
STANDARDS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- YOU CANNOT PREPARE FOR
EMERGENCY ONCE IT HAPPENED. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WITH THE IF
I MAY I THINK THIS CONVERSATION
HAS BEEN ROBUST AND I DO THINK
WE WOULD BE REMISS. AGAIN NOT
TO THANK OUR GOVERNOR AND HIS
TEAM FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. I
THINK WE WOULD BE IN A MUCH
DIFFERENT POSITION RIGHT NOW
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
HOSPITALS. AND PROVIDERS IF IT
WERE NOT FOR WHAT HE IS DOING.
AND DO BELIEVE IT NOW ALLOWS US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE PLANS.
BUT WOULD AGREE WITH CARMELLA
FOR THE NEED FOR URGENCY. THAT
TO MANY OF OUR CLINICS RIGHT
NOW WE NEED TO HAVE THEIR DOORS
OPEN TO HELP US TO. ACT AS
PREVENTATIVE CARE HAS IT IS THE
BEST TYPE OF CARE WE CAN DO. SO
WITH THAT WE WILL THANK OUR
PANELISTS FOR PANEL NUMBER ONE
AND NOW WE WILL MOVE ON TO
PANEL NUMBER TWO. AS WE DO I
WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT
THERE IS A CLUSTER OF QUESTIONS
ON THE AGENDA THAT DESCRIBE THE
FOCUS OF PANEL TO. WE HAVE
ASKED OUR PANELISTS TO RESPOND
TO THOSE QUESTIONS AND TO FOCUS
ON HOW THE SAFETY NET PROGRAMS.
ARE RESPONDING. AM TO TELL US
WHAT THEY SEE AS DIFFICULTIES
AND NEEDS IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS. NOW I WILL ASK OUR
OPERATOR TO OPEN THE LINE UP SO
THAT WE CAN START TO HEARFROM
PANEL TO. STARTING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES DIRECTOR KIM JOHNSON.
WELCOME TO PANEL TO DIRECTOR
JOHNSON. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS AT
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM JOHNSON
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES I WANT TO.
AGAIN BY JACK THANKING YOU ALL
FOR THE PARTNERSHIP- THIS HAS
BEEN A TREMENDOUS EFFORT ACROSS
THE BOARD IN COMMUNITIES AND
HAVE A WAYS TO GO TO WORK
TOGETHER- I WITH THE
DEPARTMENT'S PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITIES TO OUR
ADMINISTERED THE MAIN CRITICAL
THINKING THAT PROGRAMS THE
COCKCROFT CALIFORNIA COMMUTER
BOTH BASIC NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS
AND ALSO. ART WORLD PROTECTING
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY AVAILABLE
CALIFORNIANS DURING
EMERGENCIES. ARE DEPARTMENT
STAFF I HAVE BEEN ADAPTING AT
AN EXTRAORDINARY PASTEBIN
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
MANY OTHERS TO CARRY OUT THE
MISSION DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
SOME EXAMPLES AT ALL- PROVIDE A
HIGH LEVEL- ONE IS OUR PROJECT
ROOM KEY EFFORT WHICH IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ACROSS
STATE AGENCIES DEPARTMENT THEN
TRIED TO PROVIDE SUPPORT- TO
REALLY AT LOOK FOR ISOLATION
AND NON CONGREGATE SHELTERING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHO
ARE EITHER COPEPODS THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED. OR EET THE
CRITERIA FOR BEING AT RISK AND
THAT HAS RESULTED IN OVER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND OUR HOTEL
ROOM TO CARED. ACROSS OUR STATE
FOR THAT PURPOSE. WE ALSO BEEN
TO THE HEALTH AND- OF THE
RESIDENTS ACROSS OUR COMMUNITY
CARE SETTINGS- ALSO OUR STAFF
BETTER LOOKING EVERY DAY AS
WELL AS OUR DEPARTMENT STAFF
WHO ARE SUPPORTING A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE COMPONENT. THIS IS
NOT ONLY ADD THROUGH
PARTNERSHIP WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
AND OTHERS TO PROVIDE THAT
INFECTION PREVENTION CONTROL
BUT ALSO JUST TO ENSURE ALL OF
THESE ACCESSING THE- ST HAVE
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED. IN
ADDITION I WE HAVE BEEN-
ABSOLUTELY IMPACTED BY A
SIGNIFICANT LOSS OF LIFE IS
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE HAPPEN OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND FACILITIES HAVE BEEN
LOCKED SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH- EMPLOYERS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE IN SUPPORT
POP UP CHILD CARE SIDE-
INSURING THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. IN ARE AT RISK
POPULATIONS HAVE ACCESS OR
LEARNING THAT THEY NEED. IN OUR
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM WE ARE CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT VOLATILE CALIFORNIANS
DURING NUMBER EFFORT. BUT IT'S
PROVIDING UP TO EIGHTY HOURS A
FEDERALLY ESTABLISHED PAID SICK
LEAVE FOR I TOOK THAT'S
WORKERS. AND SHORING UP IN
EXPANDING OUR BACKUP SYSTEMS
FOR RECIPIENTS ANY PROVIDERS ON
AN EMERGENCY BASIS. WE HAVE
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
DIRECT SUPPORT TO AT RISK
FAMILIES INTO FAMILIES CARING
FOR FOSTER CHILDREN DOCTOR USES
WELL AS PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY
IS TO MAINTAIN STABILITY.
FRENCH FOR TRANSITIONAL AGE YOU
CAN EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. WE
ALSO ARE ARE WORKING ON
WATCHING ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR AND
DOCUMENT CALIFORNIA TO DON'T
OTHERWISE QUALIFY. FOR ANY
OTHER RELIEF TO IT DISASTER
RELIEF FUND WHICH WILL BE
DISPERSED THE COMMUNITY BASED
REGIONAL NONPROFIT. I WITH
EXPERTISE YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
EXTRACTED MESSENGERS TO THE
COMMUNITY. WHAT TO CAL WORKS
AND HOW FRESH PLEADED THE FIFTH
THE CASH ASSISTANCE AND ONE
OBSERVERS PROGRAMS WE HAVE SEEN
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE. IN NEW
APPLICATIONS AS MANY
CALIFORNIANS FACE JOB LOCKED IN
GROWING CHALLENGES ACROSS.
OTHER ADDED- CURRENT
RESTRICTIONS WE HAVE SEEN AT
THE LOCAL COUNTY LEVEL THIS
INCREASE- AT THE SAME TIME-
IMPACTING OUR COUNTY STAFF WHO
ARE ALSO IMPACTED DUE TO SCHOOL
CLOSURE- ILLNESS AND WHO ARE
NEEDING. TO LIMIT THEIR IN
PERSON CONTACT. THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ALSO IN. MANY FLEXIBILITY
CROP THESE PROGRAMS AB FOR
EXISTING RECIPIENTS SO THEY CAN
MAINTAIN THEIR SUPPORT. I'LL TO
REDUCING WORKLOAD FOR COUNTIES
ALLOWING THEM TO PROCESS THE
SURGEON APPLICATION IN THE
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT IN DOING
THAT CAN TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTION.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO WEIGHED
CERTAINLY PUT REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO ALLOW COUNTY
THREE DIRECTOR DRESS THE
INCREASE APPLICATION THROUGH AT
STOPPING THE COW WORKS FORTY
EIGHT MINS TIME CLOCK FOR THE
MONTH OF MARCH THIRD JUNE. I
WITH RESPECT TO FOOD AND
NUTRITION WE'RE PROVIDING A
NUMBER OF SUPPORT INCLUDING
EMERGENCY FOOD THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA FEEDBACK PARTNERS.
ALSO PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL
ASSISTANCE THROUGH CALTRANS
PANDEMIC AB T. OUT TO MILLIONS
ACROSS OUR STATE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MANY OF THE EFFORTS
THAT I JUST OUTLINED HAVE BEEN
IN PARTNERSHIP- THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ARE AT SECTION
THIRTY SIX LETTERS THAT HAVE
ALLOWED US TO QUICKLY AND
SWIFTLY. I RESPOND TO THE
CRISIS AND AS WE NAVIGATE THE
CHALLENGES AHEAD. SO I WILL GO
INTO THE QUESTION THE AD THAT
YOU HAVE HEARING FUNDS AND THE
FIRST ONE BEING OUT HOW OUR
ACCOUNT A RECESSION AT THAT
PARTY PROGRAM HOW WORKING HOW
FRESH WORKING DURING THIS TIME.
AND WHAT ARE WE SEEING IN TERMS
OF THAT LIMITATION IS THAT I
JUST MENTIONED INTO ENTERED THE
COUNTY OFFICE CLOSURES. AS I
MENTIONED THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE THE NEW APPLICATIONS
IN BOTH PROGRAMS AT THE
COMPARISON IN MARCH OF LAST
YEAR. EIGHT THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED FAMILIES APPLY FOR CAL
WORKS. AT THAT NUMBER THIS YEAR
WITH FOURTEEN THOUSAND FAMILIES
APPLYING. FOR CALIBRATION AT
MARCH OF LAST YEAR THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL THE PRIDE.
AND THAT NUMBER THIS YEAR IS
ALL THE WAY TO NINETY SIX
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THE MORE
THAN DOUBLING YOUR SCREEN WE'RE
STAYING ACROSS THE BOARD- IN
INDIVIDUALS LOOKING TO ACCESS
THESE PROGRAMS. WE HAVE BEEN
SERVING COUNTIES TO DETERMINE-
WHAT- SERVICES IN CAPACITY THEY
HAVE. ENTERED THE MEETING WITH
NEED WE'VE IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL
CLICK AGAIN FLEXIBILITY IS TO
ENSURE THAT EXISTING RECIPIENTS
CAN MAINTAIN AID. BUT WE'RE
ALSO SUPPORTING IN CONNECTING
AT DUE TO THEIR NEW
TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTIONS WE'VE
SEEN THAT THIRTY SIX COUNTIES
ADDITIONAL COUNTIES COMING ON
IMPLEMENTING ELECTRONIC
INTERVIEWING AT APPLICATION. WE
ARE BEING AT MANY TELEPHONIC
AND WEB BASED SOLUTIONS ONLINE
QUARTER PULLED PORTAL AND ALSO
A DROP BOX WITHIN MAIL SLOTS
WITH PEOPLE APPLICATIONS READ
ANYTHING AT DRIVE THRU HOURS
WERE AT INDIVIDUAL BEGAN. TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING IN PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING CAN PROVIDE
THEIR INFORMATION I TO THE
COUNTY STAFF THOUGH A LOT
HAPPENING AT IN THAT. SPACE
MEDITATION ACROSS THE BOARD. IN
TERMS AT THAT SECOND QUESTION I
HAVE THE OF POLICY TO THAT.
LIKE THAT HAVE BEEN COMMITTED I
JUST WANT TO GET A GOOD
KNOWLEDGE THE TREMENDOUS- WORK-
MATCH AT THIS FLEXIBILITY THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PRVIDE HAS
REQUIRED EXCUSE THAT MAKE THEM
PREPARE FEDERAL WAIVERS AND
WANT TO. THANK OUR PARTNERS AT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALSO FOR
QUICKLY VERY VERY QUICKLY
EXPEDITING THE APPROVAL OF MANY
OF THESE. I REQUEST AND ALSO OF
COURSE TO THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS
AT THE GOVERNOR IN MAKING
CHANGES. WE HAVE IN HEALTH
FRESH- WE HAVE A TEAM THEIR
REPORT WAY FOR EXTEND
CERTIFICATION PERIOD SO IT'S-
INSURING THAT CALPERS
RECIPIENTS DO NOT NEED TO
COMPLETE THEIR MARCH APRIL OR
MAY SEMI ANNUAL REPORT. FOR
ANNUAL RE CERTIFICATION TO
CONTINUE BENEFITS THEY'RE BY
REDUCING ANY TURN IN THE
PROGRAM. I FELT THAT CAPITA
RECIPIENTS- THE- CERTIFICATION-
WILL BE DONE ON THE SIX MONTHS.
SIX MONTHS CERTIFICATION
CARRIED EXTENSION. FOR INTER
WAIVERS HELP FRESH APPLIQUE
APPLICANT NOT YOU CAN AN INNER
IF PROVIDE. I TO BE TO. AND
OTHER REQUIRED PROOF INCLUDING
PROOF OF EARNINGS WITH THEIR
APPLICATION. AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED WE SING TELEPHONIC
SIGNATURE- ACROSS THE BOARD
WERE ALSO- POSTPONING BEEN
REVIEWED IN TERMS OF OUR
QUALITY CONTROL PROPHESIED. I
IN TREMENDOUS ADMIT DIFFERENCE
AS HAPPENED IN THE CALPERS
SPACE IS THE ABILITY ASK FOR
CALPERS RECIPIENTS TO UTILIZE
THEIR EBT CARD FOR ONLINE
PURCHASING WE'RE STARTING WITH
THE AMAZON AND WALMART AND
LOOKING TO. EXPAND TO OTHER
RETAILERS BUT THE BEGIN ALLOWS
FOR HOMES. ONLINE PURCHASING IN
HOME DELIVERY AS AS FOOD WHICH
MAKES A HUGE DIFFERENCE THAT IT
FOR INDIVIDUALS ABILITY TO
REMAIN AT HOME. IN ADDITION WE
HAVE AGAIN AS I AS I REFERENCE
THAT THAT TIME CLOCKS AND CAL
WORKS WE STOPPED AT HOWARD
FORTY EIGHT MONTH TIME CLOCK
FOR THE MONTH OF MARCH APRIL
MAY AND JUNE. AT **** WITHOUT
FORTY EIGHT MONTHS OR WHO HAD
FEWER THAN FORTY EIGHT MONTH IN
MARCH- AS WELL THERE'S A NUMBER
OF ADDITIONAL CHANGES THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN THAT HOW WORK
THERE'S BEEN MATTER EXECUTIVE
ORDER AT THAT WAS RELEASED JUST
LAST WEEK- IN THE GUIDANCE WILL
BE COMPORT COMING THIS WEEK. AT
PROVIDING SOME- ADDITIONAL
APPLICABILITY THE CROP THIS
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF
INTERVIEWING ALBUM I WOULD
VERIFICATION FELT ACTIVATION.
AT DIVERSION AND MORE. ALTHOUGH
ONE COULD NOT THAT WE- LAUNCH
ARE POWERFUL INITIATIVE WHICH
IS A CRITICAL VOLUNTARY AS
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES ACROSS OUR
CASELOAD IN FAMILIES AND- WILL
HAVE MOVED THAT THAT CONTINUE
THAT THE PORT COLLUDED TO A
TELE HEALTH OR TELL US- CALL
INFO. AGAIN THAT CONTACTED THE
MAINTAIN CAN BE DONE THE VIDEO
CALL TEXTING AND MESSAGING- AND
OTHER COMMUNICATIONS THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO MAKE SURE
THAT SUCH POINTED OCCURRING
BETWEEN HOME VISITORS AND
FAMILY. AT TO CONNECT THEM TO
ANY RESOURCES THAT THEY MAY
NEED. IN TERMS OF POWER STAGE
ONE. CARE WE'VE MADE SOME
CHANGES IN AWAITING ATTENDANT
TO THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
HOW WAITING FAMILY FEES AND
ALSO EXTENDING THE TRUCK BLIND
AS BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
PROCESS TO ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
TIME. WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
AND COMPENSATION TO SOME OF THE
FACILITIES THAT HAVE CLOSED FOR
THIRTY DAYS AT LOOKING TICKET.
AGAIN PRESERVE THE CHILD CARE
ACCESS ACROSS THE STATE- AND
I'VE BEEN AS I MENTIONED ADAM
TO CHANGES TO OUR AT FAMILY FEE
STRUCTURES. ON THE THIRD
QUESTION ABOUT AS WE LOOK AT
CROP BUT MANY OF THE
FLEXIBILITY TO CRACK THE
PROGRAM- WHATEVER OUR FUTURE
PLANS PLEASE KNOW THAT WE ARE
VERY CLOSELY LOOKING AT- EACH
OF THESE CHANGES THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE PUT INTO
PLACE. A LOOK BACK I DIDN'T
FIND WHERE WE WOULD WANT TO
EVALUATE AND POTENTIALLY THINK
ABOUT FURTHER EXTENDING- AND OF
COURSE IN SOME CASES
PARTICULARLY THOSE RELATED TO
CALIFORNIA'S BILLS ARE SUBJECT
TO FEDERAL APPROVAL. I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING REMARKS
SOME OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS OUR STATE.
I WE HAVE BEEN THE LEAD FOR
PROJECT ROOM HE- ADDED IS A
MULTI AGENCY EFFORT LED BY
SOCIAL TO PROVIDE NON
CONGREGATE SHELTERING OPTIONS
FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IT'S DESIGNED TO
SAVE LIVES REDUCE TRANSMISSION
AND RELIEVE PRESSURE ON THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM. I PROVIDING
SAFE SHELTER FOR THOSE WHO ARE
COPING POSITIVE HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED ARE WHO ARE AT HIGHER
RISK OF MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS
IF THEY WERE TO BECOME
INFECTED. AS YOU KNOW- LACKS IN
MARCH MARCH EIGHTEENTH THE
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS EVAN
INVESTMENT. A HUNDRED MILLION
OF WHICH WOULD ADMINISTERED BY
THE BUSINESS CUSTOMER SERVICE
AT THE HOUSING AGENCY. AT AND
WHAT ALLOCATED DIRECTLY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND CONTINUUM
OF CARE AND THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ACTIVE SOCIAL SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY FOR PROJECT
RANKING FOR USE BY COUNTY AND
TRIED. IT ALSO INCLUDES THE
ACQUISITION OF A TRAILER
COMPONENT AS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY. FOR ISOLATION.
SUPPORT WE HAVE BEEN DOING IT
FROM AMOUNT OF TECHNICAL TO.
THAT AGAIN THE UP AND OVER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND BRINGS IN
THAT SPACE IN ADDITION IT IS A
PLACE WHERE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DROP DOWN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FINES. AND WERE ABLE TO SECURE
APPROVAL FROM FEEDBACK. TO HAVE
A 75% COST SHARE FOR THIS
EFFORT. IN OUR OTHER
HOMELESSNESS WITH THE THANK YOU
HOUSING AT PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
BOARD WHETHER THEY BE FOR
SUPPORTING FAMILIES AND CAL
WORK OR REUNIFYING FAMILIES
THAT CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. ARE
THOSE MAYBE WITH A DISABILITY
OR SSI AT PROGRAM OR ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAMS
ARE OTHER PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
BOARD WHAT WE HAVE DONE HERE IS
REALLY- EMPHASIZED- THE GUY
THAT APPLICABILITY TO CLOCK
THESE PROGRAMS- SO THAT
COUNTIES CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE REALLY LOOKING AT
LEVERAGING AND BLENDING IN
BRITAIN. BREAKING FLAT FIND AT
TO ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS
OF POPULATIONS ACROSS THE BOARD.
THE NEXT QUESTION THANKS TO THE
COUCH TIME CLOCKS I WANNA-
OUTLINE THIS AGAIN TO CAO WORKS
FORTY EIGHT MONTH TIME CLOCK
WAS STOPPEDFOR THE MONTH OF
MARCH APRIL MAY AND JUNE. ARE
CLOCKED WITHOUT FOR THOSE WHO
HAD REACHED FORTY EIGHT MONTHS
OR HAD FEWER THAN FORTY EIGHT
MONTH IN MARCH. THAT EXEMPTION
COLD ALSO STOPPED THE WELFARE
TO WORK TWENTY FOUR MONTH TIME
CLOCK. THAT FEDERAL SIXTY MONTH
TIME CLOCK WAS NOT STOPPED AS
THERE'S BEEN NO ADDITIONAL FEC
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ON THE FEDERAL RULE.
SO WE ARE IN THIS WITH. WOULD
NOT KNOWLEDGE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALREADY EXERCISES
THERE'S BEEN FLEXIBILITY TO
STATE FUNDED BENEFITS FOR SOME
FAMILIES WHO QUALIFY FOR AND
FORTY EIGHT MONTH CLOCK
EXTENDER AND OF COURSE WE HAVE.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR OUR
CHILD ONLY AT CASES. SHIFTING
OVER TO OUR IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM- WANT TO AGAIN
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP IN ALLOWING US TO
PUT OUT IN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. I WE DID HAVE ALSO A
PLACE WHERE THAT THAT AFTER
WHICH FIRST AT CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE ACT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. AND THAT IS- EIGHTY
HOURS OF ADDITIONAL FRANKLY AT
FOUR FOUR- ALL I JUST AS
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE. WE
HAVE AGAIN EXPANDED BACK UP
PROVIDER SYSTEMS. AS WELL AS
PROVIDING A AT WHAT AGE
DIFFERENTIAL FOR THE BACKUP
PROVIDERS. IT IS ALSO A IN
PARTNERS NOT ONLY FOR AYE. BUT
ALSO ALL FOR THE WHO ARE THE IN
THE PROTECT SERVICES. WHERE WE
PROVIDED OVER TIME FOR COUNTY
SOCIAL WORKERS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL THAT TOUCH POINT THE
CONNECTION POINTS OF THE
POPULATION. IT WILL BE JUST THE
THING AGAIN WITH ANY ADDRESSING
ANY I MET NEEDS- AND YET STILL
DOING AN OVERALL WELL BEING
CHECK. WE HAVE ALL THE DENTIST
WINDING UP IN ROME PROCESS IS
NOT. ABOUT THAT. OUTPUT
ADDITIONAL LIKE. EAST WILL. ADD
TO OCCUR REMOTELY. AS WELL. FOR
INTO THE- WHO MAY BE RECEIVING
THE FIVE THAT THE HE AGAIN I
THE SOME OF THE EFFORT YOU'LL
HEAR ABOUT IN TERMS OF SUPPORT
FOR THE FAVORITE AT SET UP TO
REALLY RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO
MIGHT BE SOCIALLY ISOLATED-
THEY NEED CONNECTION POINTS
THAT YOU'LL HEAR BACK AT THE
WELLNESS CHECK TO KEEP THAT THE
FRIENDSHIP LINES AND OTHERS
THAT I THINK YOU'LL HEAR. AT
pAT A JUST A MOMENT. ALL THAT
PROJECTED SERVICES MENTIONED IT
THINGS HERE INCLUDING THE
OUTRAGE. THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
OUT REACH COUNCIL WORKER. WE'VE
ALSO CREATED A ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED LINE THAT HELPED
FACILITATE THE CONNECTION FOR.
MAY NOT KNOW WHICH THERE CAN
CONTACTED- IN THAT FIRST WEEK
OF STANDING UP THAT LINE YOU
HAVE WELL OVER AT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED CALLS. FOR WE HAVE
SEEN- IN TERMS OF OUR EIGHT
HERE AT NUMBERS TO BE SEEN AS
THOSE ARE GO DOWN A BIT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO COLLECT THAT MAKE
THAT DATA AVAILABLE REAL TIME-
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT IN PART
DUE TO NOT HAVING CONTACTED
MANDATED REPORTERS- ADHERE ABLE
TO MODIFY STATE HOME WE WOULD
EXPECT THOSE NUMBERS. ACTUALLY
INCREASED- BUT AGAIN AT ALL ALL
HANDS ON IN MAKING SURE WE'RE
HAVING TOUCH POINTS- CONNECTION
POINT AT TO OUR- TO OUR ELDERS
ACROSS THE STATE. TURNING TO
CHILD WELFARE THERE'S A FEW
QUESTIONSFOR IT HERE-
SIMILARLY AS I MENTIONED WITH
APS ARE CALLED TO THE CHILD
ABUSE HOTLINE ARE DOWN ALMOST
40% THAT SIGNIFICANT. IT MEANS
THERE ARE LAST CHILD ABUSE
REPORTS COMING IN EVEN DURING
THE TIME OF WHAT WE KNOW- IS
EXTREME STRESS ON FAMILIES.
AGAIN A BIG PART OF THAT- IS
DUE IN PART TO ADD TEACHERS
EDUCATORS BEING AT A MANDATED
REPORTER- AND ADD THAT THE
DISTANCE LEARNING AND LACK OF
IN PERSON ACCESS. TO CHILDREN
IN THE IS A BIG PIECE OF THAT
FOR THE DC LAW ENFORCEMENT AS A
PRIMARY MANDATE REPORTER. I AN
ID TO AT THIS POINT. BUT WITH
ANOTHER. WHERE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTNERSHIP FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCE THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL MATERIAL
DID BEEN TOUCH POINTS TO FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTERS. EXPANSION OF
HELP ONE BUT TWO ONE ONE PARENT
THE NON MATH WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
FOR A FOSTER YOU PUT THE
PROJECT AT THE LAPTOP CELL
PHONES THE NEW HOT SPOT.
ANOTHER PLACE WERE AT SOCIAL
WORKERS WE'VE ASKED TO DO
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH OPTION
POPULATION AND HAVE- CREATED
SOME ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY IS
RELATED TO READ THE
TERMINATION. THAT ALLOWED CASE
WORKERS TO REALLY BE FOCUSING
ON THE EMERGENCY WORK AT HAND.
WE ARE PARTLY TWO HUNDRED ADULT
A JOB THE FOSTER SYSTEM EVERY
MONTH AND- TOO MANY OF THEM ARE
AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS AND
STUDENTS IN SECURITY SAID
DURING THE CRISIS. I WE HAVE
EXTENDED THE- THEIR ABILITY TO
REMAIN AT ACCESS TO RESOURCES
AND THEIR LIVING ARRANGEMENTS
AND PUT IT INTO PROVIDE.
SECURITY WE'VE ALSO AT PROVIDED
SOME FUNDING TO SUPPORT
RESOURCE FAMILIES WHO ARE-
SERVING SOMEOF THE YOUTH WITH
THE HIGHER COMPLEX NEEDS AND
ALLOW THEM TO HAVE A HIGHER
MONTHLY REIMBURSEMENT RATE TO
ACCOUNT FOR THAT- IT ALSO
EXTENDED THE TIME FOR CARE
GIVER APPROVAL. ACROSS THE
BOARD. WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
EARLY ON AND ARE GLAD TO SEE
SOME CHANGE IN THE SPACE- BUT
THE CHALLENGES WITH OUR COURT
WE HAD- AT VARIANCE ACROSS THE
STATE. IN TERMS OF MONTHLY
VISITATION AT THAT WAS RESOLVED
BUT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES IN TURN AS- THE
COURT CAN REALLY BE ADD DELAYED
FAMILY REUNIFICATION DELAYED
OPTIONS AND GUARDIANSHIP. AS
THERE HAS BEEN BEEN BACKLOGS
CREATED SAID THAT SIR AND AT.
THAT HUGE FOCUS OF OURS TO-
CONTINUE TO LIFT UP WHAT WE
WOULD WANT TO SEE S. SUPPORTED
IN OUR COURT SYSTEM TO KEEP. AT
THESE PROCEEDINGS MOVING IN
ALSO ABOUT. TO KNOW IN THAT
SPACE THAT I THAT THAT THE OF
THE WOULD WORK PARTNERS WITH
YOUR ACCOUNT AND WILL BE WITH
THE CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL AS
WELL. TWO MORE QUESTIONS HERE
SO- HOW ARE RESPONDING TO THE
NEED FOR EMERGENCY FOOD THE AND
THAT AT GREAT QUESTION A LOT
OF- EFFORTS IN THE FRONT IN THE
SPECIALLY. FEDERALLY AT BOTH AT
PROVED WAIVERS BUT OFTEN YOU
RESOURCES HERE SO. EMERGENCY
CALTRANS ALLOTMENTS THAT
ALLOWS. FOR THE MONTH OF MARCH
APRIL AND MAY CALPERS
RECIPIENTS TO RECEIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT UP TO
THEIR MAXIMUM- ON APRIL TWELFTH
OVER ONE POINT THREE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS RECEIVED A TOTAL OF
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS. AND
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS WITH AN
AVERAGE INCREASE THAT ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE DOLLARS PER
HOUSEHOLD- THESE AGAIN WE HAVE
APPROVED MARCH APRIL AND MAY
AND WHAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM OUR
PARTNERS AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTED ADDS THAT- WE
WILL CONTINUE ISSUING EMERGENCY
ALLOTMENT INTEL CALIFORNIA'S.
AT STATE OF EMERGENCY IF LEFT
AT THAT THE HUGE- SUPPORT FOR
FAMILIES THAT WE FOR DIRECTLY.
FROM THEM MAKE THE TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE. WE HAVE ALSO. A
LARGE DARK. HE BEAT SHE AND
THIS IS WHY. OUR CHILDREN WHO
ARE EL FOR EVERY PRICE MEALS
CAN GET UP TO THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS. IN
ADDITIONAL- PANDEMIC EBT FOOD
BENEFITS. ARE THOSE ABSTAINED
LEGAL CHILDREN WHO ARE ALREADY
RECEDING HEALTH FRESH MEDI CAL
OR FOSTER CARE BENEFITS DO NOT
NEED TO APPLY THAT'S GOING TO
BE AN AUTOMATIC ISSUANCE AT
THEIR PANDEMIC EBT CARD IN THE
MAIL. AT LATER THIS MONTH. I
AND THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS
BUT AS- I MAYBE REN'T ON OUR
CALPERS PROGRAM WILL NEED TO
APPLY THEY HAVE THAT
APPLICATION PERIOD THROUGH THE
END OF JUNE. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES THAT WILL
ISSUE UP TO ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN BENEFITS TO
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION ELIGIBLE CHILDREN. WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCE SCHOOL CLOSURES
OVER THE MONTH OF MARCH TO JUNE.
IN ADDITION- WE HAVE PROVIDED
AS SUPPLEMENTAL STATE FUNDED
FOOD BOXES IN IT AT- TWENTY
POUNDS- THAT SHELF STABLE FOOD
IS ENOUGH TO FEED THE FAMILY OF
THREE TO FOUR THOSE BOTH BOXES
OF FOOD- HAVE GONE OUT TO NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES STATEWIDE THAT'S
WITH A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. ABOUT YOU SUPPORTED
US WITH THE BACKSPACE DO NOT
SUPPORTING OVER FIFTY FOOD
BANKS ACROSS THE STATE WE ARE
ANTICIPATING ADDITIONAL AT
FUNDS COMING FOR FOOD BANKS IN
JULY NOT ONLY FOR. ADDITIONAL
FOOD TO BE DELIVERED TO THE
EMERGENCY FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT ABOUT OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH CAL VOLUNTEERS
NATIONAL GUARD AND OTHERS TO.
HELP ACTUALLY COME HAVE YOU
KNOW WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
VOLUNTEERS AND COULD ACTUALLY
CREATE THOSE BOXES THE SORT
THAT HE- THEY HAVE BEEN GREAT
PARTNERS THE CRAFT WITH THE
BANK STATEWIDE. BEFORE THIS IS
BEFORE AND THEY MAKE IT TO THE
TO THE BUSINESS PROGRAM THIRD
OVER ONE POINT SEVEN GET
BILLION PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
CONTINUING TO COLLECT THE PAY
ON JUST HOW. MANY MORE-
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACT HE-
CERTAINLY HEARING A LOT ABOUT
THAT ACROSS. THE STATE AT THE
CONTINUED NEED. SOCIAL SERVICES
MANY BUT- SETTLEMENT FOOD
PROGRAM FOR. OLDER ADULTS AGE
SIX AND OVER WITH THE BOX WITH
EACH THE AND THAT WORK AT COULD
BE FAN CAL. THIS PROGRAM THIRDS
WANT THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS EACH
MONTH. I AM AT THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH A US BE A AND PARTNER
FEEDBACK WE'VE BEEN LOOKING TO
RELAX A BIT OF THESE WILL THAT
WILL. ADD TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THE TWO BANKS TO GET THE FOOD
OUT TO THOSE OLDER ADULTS EACH
MONTH. AND FINALLY ON THE PARTS
WE HAVE RECEIVED YOU SCA
APPROVAL TO REPEAT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS BUT THE NEWLY ANNOUNCED
FARM TO FOOD BANKS PROGRAM. I
WILL TO THE OPERATING AT MUCH
THE SAME S THE FOOD BANKS AND
AS CDS BASIC THIS BILL PART OF
FAMILY PRODUCE SO THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT ENSURING THAT
THAT. WE'RE NOT WASTING ANY OF
THE FOOD AND WERE ABLE TO
CONNECT. THE FAMILY TO A NEED
IF SUPPORT WITH THE FRESH
PRETTY COULD PRODUCE- THAT THE
FARMERS HAVE BEEN CREATING WERE
PAYING THE PAST PICKING PACKING
SHIPPING COSTS A GOOD GUY BRING
THAT THAT PRODUCE. FROM. THE
FIELD TO HOMES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THEN. QUESTION RELATED TO
LET. BLUR ACT FROM PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCE DURING THE LAST
RECESSION. A VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGET AND POLICY DECISIONS
WERE MADE REFLECTING ON THIS
AND WHAT. WHAT MAY NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THE FUTURE TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET IMPORTANT.
WHERE POSSIBLE TO IDENTIFY THE
REDUCTION OF THAT IMPACT THE
LEAST NUMBER OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE ABOUT PROGRAMS- WE
ALSO WANT TO BE COGNIZANT OF
HOW ONE'S PROGRAMS REDUCTION
INTERPLAY'S WITH. OTHER
PROGRAMS SO REALLY LOOKING AT-
THE INDIVIDUALS ACROSS OUR
STATE WHO MAY BE AT
BENEFICIARIES OF MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS AND HOW- ANY POTENTIAL
CHANGES. WHAT IMPACT THEM ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS. WORKS AS YOU
HEARD ME SAY THEIR- IT'S TIME
QUE CONTINUE TO MAXIMIZE ALL OF
THE FEDERAL RESOURCES- BAD
ENOUGH I ANY SPECIAL BY THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS WE
CAN LEVERAGE UP PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO MAXIMIZE
EFFICIENCY. AND ULTIMATELY
SAVING MONEY WITH IMPACT
IMPACTING THE FEWEST NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. ALONG THE WAY. SO I
WILL STOP WITH THOSE REMARKS
AND AT BE AVAILABLE HERE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
JOHNSON AND NEXT WE HAVE
DIRECTOR PARCHMAN. THE DOCTOR
REGULAR AND MEMBERS- HAPPY TO
BE HERE DANCE DEPARTMENT
DIRECTOR IDEA- IF YOU TO FOCUS
ON THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE IN
THE AGENDA- I WILL- PROVIDE YOU
AN OVERVIEW OF THE TAKING THAT
AND THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE IN
RESPONSE TO COLD AT NINETEEN-
WHEN WE FIRST. STARTED HE BEING
OUR OUR ROAD MAP FOR HOW TO BE
RESPONSIVE DURING THIS CRISIS
IT BECAME REALLY APPARENT THAT
WE REALLY NEEDED TO FOCUS ON A
NUMBER OF EALLY KIND OF KEY
AND RITICAL AREAS. THE FIRST
OF WHAT YOU THINK THE AND THEN
AND MINIMIZING THE RISK AND
EXPOSURE TO- OUR POPULATION
WHICH- IS FREQUENTLY IDENTIFIED
AS SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
AND CERTAINLY WANTED TO BE-
MINDFUL OF THE FACT THAT WE HAD
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO- ENSURING
THE SAFETY AND PROTECTION OF
THE INDIVIDUAL. THE OTHER AREA
WITH FLEXIBILITY TO PROVIDE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT FLEXIBILITY TO REGIONAL
CENTERS BECAUSE WE REALLY
NEEDED TO IDENTIFY WAYS THAT WE
COULD GET SERVICES- TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE- IN A
WAY THAT IS DIFFERENT- BUT ALL
OF THE RESPONSES AND BEING-
AWARE OF THE MOST. URGENT AND
IMMEDIATE NEEDS. ALSO A LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN DO THAT THROUGH
SERVICE ALTERNATIVE. AND IT'S
BORING OR THEIR WAYS SO
CERTAINLY MAXIMIZING THE
FEDERAL FUNDING LOOKING AT THE
WAY THAT WE COULD HAVE THOSE
ALTERNATIVES WITH OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES. WE HAVE A REMARKABLE
COMMUNITY THAT IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT- TO OUR CONSUMERS- IN
WAYS THAT- WE CERTAINLY HAVE
FOUND RECENTLY THAT ARE VERY
CREATIVE. AND VERY NIMBLE AND
RESPONSE THE- BUT ALSO ONGOING
EVALUATION OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE WORKING IN OUR RESPONSE TO-
THE CRISIS AND THE THINGS THAT
ARE NOT WORKING AND THINGS WE
HAVE TO BE AWARE OF TO BE ABLE
TO ADJUST. AND HEAD THAT AND
MAYBE TAKE A LOOK AT
ALTERNATIVE STRATEGIES- LASTLY
WE REALLY WANTED TO BE VERY
FOCUSED ON COMMUNICATION NOT
ONLY COMMUNICATION THROUGHOUT
THE MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE THE
DEPARTMENT. WORKS OUT THE BALL
TO THE REGIONAL CENTER THE
FAMILIES TO PROVIDERS TO
ADVOCATE- BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT WE WORKING KIDDING ABOUT
THAT. TO GIVE YOU SOME
ADDITIONAL. AROUND THE EXTRA.
SO AND IN TAKING A LOOK AT
SAFETY WE WERE THE- A I SAID
WANTED TO TAKE A LOOK AT HOW WE
CAN. THAT RISK ANDEXPOSURE TO
THE INDIVIDUAL THE FAMILY THREE
DON'T CENTER STAFF AND ALSO TO
PROVIDERS- WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE DIFFERENT STRATEGIES ONE
FIRST AND FOREMOST WHAT WE
NEEDED TO DO WAS TO MINIMIZE.
ANY EXPOSURE IN CONGREGATE
SETTING AND SO HAVING THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO RESTRICT-
ADMISSION AND- GETS CHARGES
FROM CERTAIN STUDYING SO WE CAN
REALLY TAKE A LOOK AT HOW CAN
WE- TAPE THAT HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO STABILIZE. AND NOT PROVIDE
THAT EXPOSURE TO A VULNERABLE
POPULATION. THAT BAD WE ALSO
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE LOOKING AT- CAPACITY TO
SUPPORT THEM AN ALTERNATIVE
WAY. WE DON'T CENTERS WORKING
VERY VERY HARD AND IDENTIFYING
CAPACITY THAT THEY COULD
DEVELOP IS WHAT WE CALL FOR
STORAGE CAPACITY. WHICH ARE
WE'RE GOING TO BE ALTERNATE
THAT FIGHT. FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
EITHER WERE COLD AND POSITIVE
OR EXPOSED OR EVEN WITHOUT A
DETERMINED- EXPOSURE WHERE CAN
WE SAFELY SUPPORT THEM.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WAS REALLY
CRITICAL WE HAD A REALLY
REMARKABLE- CLINICAL TEAM AT
THE DEPARTMENT REGIONAL CENTERS
DEPLOYED- THEIR CLINICAL TEAM
WE ACCESS THE REMARKABLE TEAM
THROUGH- PT PH AND THE AT THAT.
THAT ALSO PROVIDED SUPPORT TO
OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS. AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE
PROVIDING THE BEST TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP FOLKS. THINK
THROUGH WHAT ARE THE BEST-
STRATEGY THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH GUIDING. THE DAY HOW DO
YOU ISOLATE HOW DO YOU MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MINIMIZING THEM
WRAPPED. BOTH SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES WHAT WE HAD PROVIDED
GUIDANCE TO OUR PROVIDERS
PARTICULARLY THOSE- IN A HIGH
RISK AREA- OUR ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES FOR
PERSONS WITH SPECIAL HEALTHCARE
NEEDS. WE KNOW THAT WE HAD
INDIVIDUALS. WITH MOST. BIG AND
COME. THREE DIED THE NAME. BUT
ALSO ARE I OF PDF AND BEING. SO
WHAT WE DID VERY ON IS THAT WE
ON STOPPED ALL. VISITORS GOING
INTO THOSE HOMES AND WE STOPPED
ALL PLACEMENT GOING AND
WITHOUT- OVERSIGHT BY THE
DEPARTMENT- WHAT WE DID WAS WE
TOOK A LOOK AT WHAT WITH A
STRATEGY THAT THE PROVIDER WAS
ABLE TO DO TO. MINIMIZE THE
REST THROUGH ISOLATION WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WAS REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR FAMILIES AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND NOT HAVE THOSE
THAT THAT. I OTHER PANELISTS
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF EVERYBODY BUT AGAIN I DO I
DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
INCREDIBLE CREATIVE APPROACHES.
THAT ARE PROVIDERS HAVE REALLY
TAKE AND MAKING SURE THAT EVEN
IN THAT THEY'D BE CLOSE
REMARKABLE CHALLENGING TIME.
THAT THEY REALLY DID OPEN UP
THEIR MINDS AND STAND HOW THEY
CAN HAVE THAT THAT THROUGH
VIRTUAL VISIT. X. BETTER TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE REMAIN
CONNECTED- ALBEIT NOT IN THE
SAME TRADITIONAL WAYS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY BUT THEY REALLY
DID I MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
MAKING. THE BEST OF WHAT THEY
COULD DO WITH THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM. WE ALSO.
TOOK A LOOK AT HOW WE COULD-
PROVIDE CONTINUE OVERSIGHTAND
MONITORING- WHEN THAT SITE
VISITS WERE NOT ABLE TO BE DONE
WE ALSO- DID THE SAME AS OTHERS
HAVE DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE USING TECHNOLOGY FOR THE
VIDEO. VISITING AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE WERE DOING A REVIEW
THAT WE NEEDED TO CONTINUE TO
DO IN ON THE DIFFERENT-
RESIDENTIAL SETTING- DARK
CHRISTIAN BY YEAH OTHER
SETTINGS AND HAVE BE ABLE TO
PORT PROBLEMS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WERE. A PROVIDING THE
SUPPORT TO THE PROVIDERS BUT
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE WERE
MONITORING. ON THE SERVICES
THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO BE
DELIVERED- WE ALSO TOOK A LOOK
AT HOW WE CAN WORK WITH THE
STATE LOCAL- RESOURCES. TO
PROVIDE THOSE REPORT THIS TO
THE RESULT CENTER TO INCLUDE-
P. P. AS WELL AS MAKING SURE
THAT WE WERE PROVIDING THE- THE
NETWORKING THAT WAS AVAILABLE
THROUGH THAT AREA COMMUNITIES.
BUT THE ABILITY WAS- FIRST AND
FOREMOST ONE OF THE AREAS IN
WHICH WE NEEDED TO MAKE SURE WE
HAD DIRECTED THEM RESOURCES OUT
TO THE COMMUNITY. ONE OF THE
AREAS THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
WITH TO MAKE SURE THAT I
DELEGATED MY AUTHORITY- THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY WAIVERS. ONTO
THE LOCAL LEVEL SO FOR
PARTICULAR SERVICES- THAT
DELEGATION WENT TO THE RESULT
CENTERS SO THEY CAN BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE RESIDENTIAL
PROVIDERS. AND OF THE PORT
SERVICES THAT WERE ESSENTIAL TO
GET IN- IN A TIMELY WAY- WE
ALSO TOOK A LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
MAXIMIZE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
TELE SERVICE- PARTICULARLY WITH
THE NON RESIDENTIAL PROVIDERS
WHO WHO FOUNDED IMPORTANCE. ON
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THOSE
CONNECTIONS WITH THE PORT. I'M
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD GET
THOSE SERVICES INTO THE HOME
WITH THE- FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
LIVE. WHETHER IT WAS LIKE A
FAMILY OR. AND THE RESIDENTIAL
CUTTING. WE A NUMBER OF
OPPORTUNE. TO MAXIMIZE THAT THE
WHAT BUT EARLY. SERVICES NOT
ONLY WITH THE EARLY START
SERVICE COORDINATORS FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTER- BUT ALSO OUR
EARLY START SERVICE PROVIDERS
QUICKLY ADAPTED AND WENT TO AND
TELL A THERMOS OPTION. WE ALSO
RECEIVED WHILE IT WAS
CHALLENGING FOR SOME FAMILIES
THAT I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT AS FAR AS ACT THAT'S
BEING THE- ACTUAL EQUIPMENT
RESOURCES. THAT WE REALLY DID
HERE- THAT THAT FAMILIES AND-
THE EARLY START SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOUND THAT TO BE. A
REALLY GREAT ALTERNATIVE- AND
IT ALLOWED THE FLEXIBILITY NOT
ONLY TO BE ABLE TO DELIVER THAT
SERVICE. BUT ALSO AND-
ALTERNATIVE TIME FRAME WHETHER
IT WAS ON THE WEEKEND OR
EVENING. ON BECAUSE THE
FAMILIES WERE TAKEN FROM- VERY
CHALLENGING TIME AND IN THEIR
SCHEDULES. AS THEY WERE
ADAPTING TO- NEW NEW WAYS OF
HAVING TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY-
WE ALSO TOOK A LOOK AT HOW WE
COULD YOU REMOTE AND TAKING
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY FOR.
ANY NEW CASES COMING INTO THE
RESULT. THAT OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. BECAUSE IF YOU
CAN IMPORTANT. WHILE WE
RECOGNIZE ARE NOT ABLE TO DO ON
SITE- ELIGIBILITY ASSESSMENT-
WE COULD TAKE A LOOK AT AND
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY TO HAVE
INSURANCE. THAT WE WERE NOT
ELAINE- SERVICES TO THOSE NOT
NOT ONLY CURRENTLY IN- THE
RESULT CENTER- SYSTEM BUT THOSE
THAT WERE JUST ENTERING INTO
IT- WE ALSO TOOK A LOOK AT
THOSE IMPACT TO SERVICE
PROVIDERS EARLY ON WE HAD
HEARD. FROM SERVICE PROVIDERS
THAT- THE DEADLINE OF GETTING
SELF ASSESSMENT FOR
REQUIREMENTS AT THE AGE TO BE A
COMPLIANCE. TAKING A LOOK AT.
AND BEING FOCUSED ON AND THEY
COULD FOCUS ON THE ON THE
IMMEDIATE CRISIS AT HAND-
LOOKING AT COMMUNICATION THIS
WAS ALSO AN AREA. THAT WAS
REALLY CRITICAL WE IMMEDIATELY
REACHED OUT TO OUR SYSTEM
PARTNERS- TALK TO THE CONSUMER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TALKED A
FAMILY GROUP. WORKED WITH- MANY
OF OUR MEMBERS WITHIN OUR JOB-
BELT MENTAL SERVICE THE TASK
FORCE WORKGROUP. AN AREA THAT
WAS REALLY REALLY CRITICAL WITH
OUR OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO WERE ON THE
FRONT LINES THE WORKING OUR
WITH OUR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO HEAR WHAT THOSE
CHALLENGES WERE. ON TO SEE HOW
WE COULD HELP CONNECT THEM TO
THOSE IMMEDIATE MAIN. AND
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE DIALOGUE IN THAT
PARTNERSHIP AND LISTENING TO
WHAT THE NEEDS WORK. WE HAVE
ALL BEEN OUR WEBSITE AND THE
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE- FOR THOSE TWO ACT
THAT WHEN I JUST KINDA WANT
WANT TO WALK YOU THROUGH SOME
OF THOSE RESOURCES. SO MAKING
SURE THAT OUR WEBSITE WAS
EASILY ACCESSIBLE TO. ALL
WORKING WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAD ACCESS. TO THEIR
COMMUNITY WITH INFORMATION AND
ALSO A LINK TO OUR DEPARTMENT'S
WEBSITE BUT ALSO MAKING SURE
THAT WE WERE. COMMUNICATING THE
LINK TO THE EIGHTY THREE.
EIGHTY P. H. TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THE MOST CURRENT
INFORMATION FROM THE STATE AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. ALL OF
OUR DIRECTED THAT WE HAD GIVE
AND- AS WELL AS COMMUNICATION
WE HAD JUST OVER- TWENTY FIVE
THAT HAD BEEN GIVEN OUT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS- IS
MANY AS WE COULD WE WERE ABLE
TO WORK WITH A- A SMALL
WORKGROUP. ON ENSURING THAT OUR
DIRECTIVES WERE- TRANSLATED
INTO MULTIPLE LANGUAGES WHERE
WE COULD AND THEN MAKING SURE
THAT WE ADDRESS IT AT TO PLAIN
LANGUAGE. WE WERE VERY VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF OUR PARTNERS IN
WORKING WITH US ON THE PLAIN
LANGUAGE. WE ALSO FOUND THAT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO ALSO THINK
DIFFERENTLY AND FIGURING OUT
HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
ARE DIRECTORS WERE AVAILABLE TO
THE COMMUNITY IN VARIOUS. THAT.
WE STARTED A I KNEW I. WHERE WE
YOU CAN AN AUDIO VERSION. WHERE
WE HAVING READ THAT PLANE
LÏNG YOUR AT THEM WE JUST A
REQUEST TO HAVE ALL OF OUR FULL
LENGTH VERGE DIRECT. ALSO ON A
VIDEO AN AUDIO VERSION- SO IT
WOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO THOSE
WHO COULD LISTEN TO IT AS
OPPOSED TO READING THAT- WE
ALSO HAVE ADDED- VIDEO FOR
THOSE- WHO ARE USING AMERICAN
SIGN LANGUAGE. AND SO ALL OF
THE- ARE. ON OUR WEBSITE WE
CONTINUE TO UPDATE ON A DISPLAY
MAKING SURE THAT WE WERE
RESPONSIVE TO ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT CAME IN THROUGH
A DEDICATED EMAIL LINE. THAT
THE- FAQS WERE UP ON OUR
WEBSITE WE CONTINUE TO UPDATE
THOSE A COUPLE OF TIMES A WEEK-
THE OTHER KEY STRATEGIES THAT
WE RELATE ON HAD TO FOCUS ON IN
AND DELIVERY OF CRITICAL
STRUCTURE- AND RESPONSE WAS
WITHIN HEADQUARTERS WE CREATED
A CO GOOD RESPONSE TEAM TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THE REAL CRITICAL
AREAS THAT. WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITY
EVERYTHING FROM- DOING
ASSESSMENT OF OUR- CONSUMERS
WHO HAD- HAD JOBS PRIOR TO CO
GOOD NINETEEN. AND TO AT THAT
IF ANY OF THEM HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS IF THEY BALK THEIR JOB-
WORKING WITH THE PROVIDERS AND
THE INDIVIDUAL TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE ACCESSING THOSE
RESOURCES TO UNEMPLOYMENT THE
OTHER RESOURCES. THAT THEY
COULD- TAPPED INTO THAT IT'S
BEEN- PUT. FORWARD BY THE STATE.
I JUST THAN WORKING. SUPPORTED
AND PROVIDERS FOR FLEXIBILITY
THAT THEY CAN ALSO FOR THIRD.
THROUGH SOME VIDEO SERVICES AND
ALTER. REPORT WE ALL HAD A TEAM
LED THE THIRDS DEVELOPMENT
WORKING WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTERS WE WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY. JUST OVER TWELVE
HUNDRED CAPACITY FOR THIRDS
DEVELOPMENT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. REGIONAL CENTER DID
THAT THROUGH- LIKE THE-
STUDYING- WE APPRECIATED OUR
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND HELPING
US IN EXPEDITING ANY OF THE
LICENSES THAT WE NEEDED TO DO.
DAY PROGRAM STEPPED UP IN
IDENTIFYING RESOURCES THAT THEY
COULD USE. UNTIL WE CAN
ESTABLISH THEM THIRDS
DEVELOPMENT ALSO LOOKING AT
HOTELS MOTELS. I'M LOOKING AT
SECURING APARTMENT SO WE CAN
PROVIDE DOES ALTERNATIVE
ISOLATION FIGHT SHOULD THAT
NEED TO BE THERE- WE ALSO WORK
WITH DEVELOPING FAIRVIEW
IMPORTER BILL AS THIRDS
LOCATION- WE'RE PROUD OF THE
FACT THAT WE ARE ABLE TO-
CLOTHES. AND BE POPULATE THE
GENERAL TREATMENT AREAS. BUT
WE'RE ALSO REALLY PLEASED THAT
WE HAD THESE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO US. TO ESTABLISH
JUST OVER THREE HUNDRED- SAID
THAT COULD BE ACT THAT RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT. SHOULD WE NEED IT
WE ALSO MET WITH RESULT IN A
DIRECTORS ON A WEEKLY BASIS AND
CONTINUE TO DO SO TO HEAR WHAT
THEY'RE- ON COMMUNITIES ARE ARE
TAKING AS PART CHALLENGES-
REGIONAL CENTER AND HAVING THE-
ASSURANCE THAT THEY WERE ALSO
DOING PROACTIVE OUTREACH- THEY
WERE. WERE HAVING TO BE NIMBLE
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEIR
SERVICE COORDINATORS WERE DOING
A TELE SERVICE AND I'M REACHING
OUT TO THEIR COMMUNITY- I'M
REALLY REALLY PLEASED WITH THE
WORK AT THAT SERVICE
COORDINATOR CAN OUT HAD DONE IN
MAKING SURE THAT. OUT WHICH WAS
DONE ON A PROACTIVE WE
RECOGNIZE AND BIRDS FROM FROM
FAMILIES THAT THEY'VE HAD
CHALLENGES IN GETTING THOSE-
CALL BACK WHEN THEY PULLED
THEIR REGIONAL CENTER AND WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE
CHALLENGE THAT CHANGING PHONE
SYSTEMS. AND MAKING SURE THAT.
THAT I THAT THE THERE WE DO ON
SENDS OUT ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE
TO HAVE THE RESULT. WHERE BACK
TO US IS TO THEIR MITIGATING
THAT REP WHEN. ARE ARE UNABLE
TO ACCESS OUR SERVICE
COORDINATOR. WHEN WE TAKE A
LOOK AT THE PROS BETTER NAY TO
A THAT. THAT PEOPLE IN NEED YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE A FELLOW THAT
THAT AT THAT YOU KNOW AS I
SHARED WITH ON OF THE DIRECTOR.
BY THE BILL THAT IS REALLY.
CERTAINLY AGAIN WITH THE- WITH
OUR STATE GROUPS AND I. THOSE
AREAS THAT WE NEED TO CAN TO.
BUILD ON OUR OUR OUR BUILDING
BLOCKS WE STARTED USE- ALSO
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW DO WE
MONITOR AND FOLLOW UP ON
COMPLAIN- SO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US. TO MONITOR ANY COMPLAINT
THAT COME TO THE DEPARTMENT SO
WE CAN BE RESPONSE THAT AND
HELP- NAVIGATE. THOSE ISSUED TO
A PROBLEM RESOLUTION AND- IN
ADDITION WE PROVIDED- ALTERED
SAYS A WAIVER REQUIREMENT-
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS
FEDERAL- FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THESE WAIVER
REQUIREMENT WHICH HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL NOT FLEXIBILITY AS AN
IMPORTANT TO FAMILIES. I HAD
SHARED WITH YOU IT AS FAR THE
INTAKE SERVICE AN ELIGIBILITY
FOR NON RESIDENTIAL SERVICES WE
HAVE A PROVISION IN OUR
REGULATIONS THAT ALLOWS FOR
RETAIN OURPAYMENT- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE- SERVICE
PROVIDERS- AND CONTINUE GUYTON
FOR COMING OUT. TO HOW TO HELP
THEM- IDENTIFIED THEIR THEIR-
ONGOING- MONITORING OF THEIR
DOCUMENTATION TO BE ABLE TO
CLAIM- FOR THOSE NON RESIDENTS
ARE THOSE- A RETAINER PAYMENTS
FOR NON RESIDENTIAL SERVICES-
WE ADDED ONE OF THE AREAS THAT
HAS HELPED A NUMBER F FAMILIES
IS THE ADDITIONAL. FLEXIBILITY
TO PARTICIPATE AND DIRECTED
SERVICE SAYS- ALREADY DEAD
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS IT FOR RESPITE SERVICES
WE EXTENDED IT THE PERSONAL
ASSISTANT INDEPENDENT LIVING
SKILLS. AND THAT'S BAD I HAD
SHARED WITH SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT- HAS ALSO BEEN
pDIRECTED CERVANTES. WHEN WE
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT. THAT WERE.
WERE HEARING FAN AND REYES
OFTEN ALL ALL SOME OF THOSE WE
YOU AND WE CAN. TO AND- WITH
THEM TO WE WERE. THAT WE HAVE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH
STRATEGIES. AND IDENTIFY
AFFECTED MEAN TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS SOME. OR ALL OF THESE
ISSUES- FAMILIES AND REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE SHARED I'M OUT
CONCERNS AS FAR AS- FOOD AND
SECURITY SOME OF THE BASIC
NEEDS AND SO THAT'S WHERE IT'S
BEEN REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
STAY IN CONTACT WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
WITH THE REGIONAL CENTER TO SEE
IF THOSE RESOURCES CAN HELP
CONNECT TO- THAT STATE AND
LOCAL RESOURCES FOR FOOD
ACCESS- ALLOWING FOR
FLEXIBILITY FOR DAY PROGRAM
PROVIDERS AND OTHER NON
RESIDENTIAL TO BE ABLE TO. USE
THEIR SERVICES- AS AN
ALTERNATIVE APPROACH TO CONNECT
THEM TO PICKING UP FOOD
DELIVERING FOOD CHECKING ON
FAMILIES- AND CONTINUING THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
FAMILIES ARE HAVING ACCESS TO
THOSE BASIC NEEDS. TECHNOLOGY
HAS ALSO BEEN AN AREA OF A
CHALLENGE FOR SOME OF OUR
FAMILY- IF THEY HAVEN'T ALREADY
HAD THE TECHNOLOGY RESULT THAT
ARE TO THEM WORKING WITH THEM
TO SECURE ALTERNATIVE
APPROACHES TO TECHNOLOGY. BEING
ABLE TO BE HOW THEY CAN LOAN
AND GET RESOURCES FOR- IPAD.
AND THEN LOOKING IN EXPLORING
HOW TO ACCESS- WIFI TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL FAMILIES
CAN ACCESS BOTH ALTERNATIVE-
VIRTUAL SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
THAT WE ALLOWED THROUGH THE
FLEXIBILITY THERE'S BEEN AND-
CONTINUED. FOR BROADER AND- IN
PLAIN LANGUAGE WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THAT AN AREA THAT HAS
BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR FAMILY.
AND HOME SERVICES DURING SCHOOL
CLOSURES- RESULT THAT ARE HAVE
BEEN RESPONSIVE AND LOOKING AT
HOW TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESPITE SERVICES AND SUPPORT
SERVICES. AND AGAIN THE
PARTICIPANT DIRECTED SERVICE.
IT'S REALLY AT A KEY AREA OF
FAMILY THAT THEY ARE NOT ABLE
TO ACCESS. HAVING SOMEBODY COME
INTO THEIR HOME THAT THEY COULD
DO DOWN MEMBER AND THOSE ARE
CLOSE TO THEM. TO PROVIDE
TEMPORE THAT THEY NOT A BEEN
ABLE TO. ACCESS PRIOR TO COPE
NIGHT. AT FIFTY RESULT ENTERED
AND CERTAINLY UNSERVED PROVIDER
THE CONCERN IS AS FAR AS
ACCESSING ON I THINK WE- TO AND
THAT'S- WELL WE STILL HERE
CONCERN. ABOUT BEING ABLE TO DO
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SEND
OUT PP THROUGH THAT STATE THAT
THE- THAT HAD BEEN AVAILABLE TO
REYES CENTERS AND WE CONTINUE
TO- FOCUS ON THIS AREA. MANY
PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS THEIR THEIR OWN THROUGH
DIFFERENT CHANNELS- BUT THIS IS
AN AREA THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE AND EXPLORE HOW TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH- WHEN WE LOOK
AT. WHAT IT WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO
MOVING FORWARD RIGHT NOW WITH
THE- RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC-
AND LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT- BEAT
EFFORTS WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO-
MAKE SURE THAT WERE. NOT A
TRAINED THE HIGH RISK
INDIVIDUALS- WE ARE YOU SEEN
OUR INTERNATIONAL SPECIAL
INCIDENT REPORTING TO BE ABLE
TO TRACK TRENDS AND TAKING A
LOOK AT HOW- ANY COMPLAINTS ARE
TRENDING AS WELL AS- INCIDENT
REPORT. TO SEE A FOURTEEN BY
THE DIFFERENT AREAS. THAT WE
CAN BE RESPONSE TO OUR RISK
MANAGEMENT TEAM IS LOOKING AT
ALL OF THOSE INCIDENT AND
MONITORING THOSE THEN IF WE
NEED TO- GO. PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. WE WILL NEED TO DO
THAT. LOOKING AT WE HAVE TO CAN
TO LOOK AT INNOVATIVE AND ALTER
A BUT ALSO CAN OUR ENGAGEMENT
WITH OUR COMMUNITY SO WE CAN
LISTEN TO THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED. ON AND SEE IF THERE'S
ADDITIONAL STRATEGIES- THAT WE
CAN DO PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. THOSE
ARE THE ONES THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
STAYING CONNECTED TO HEAR HOW
THEY'RE ACCESSING SERVICES OR
WHETHER OR NOT UNABLE TO ACT
THAT THAT WE CAN BE RESPONSIVE-
SO I. WANT TO ALSO NOTE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE WAIVER
AMENDMENT ANYTHING THAT WE CAN
DO TO DRAW ON FEDERAL DOLLARS.
AND THE FLEXIBILITY AND TO THE
SERVICE DELIVERY DURING THE
TIME THAT IT CONTINUING TO BE
AN AREA THAT WE- WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON. THOUGH I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO- ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
BARGE MAN AND NEXT WE HAVE
DIRECTOR MCCOY WEIGHED. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CHEMICALLY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A DIALOGUE
WITH YOU- IN THE PUBLIC THIS
AFTERNOON I APPRECIATED
SPECIALLY THE WAY YOU HAVE
FRAMED THE CONVERSATION ABOUT.
THREE THINGS THE CO THE
NINETEEN CRISIS THE
UNEMPLOYMENT CRISIS AND THE
CHALLENGES IN THE HEAD I DON'T
THINK THE BOOK ALL THREE OF
THOSE THAT. PHONE TWO OF THE
HEALTH CRISIS FOR OLDER. WHO WE
SERVE AHEAD OF HER OF THE- THIS
WITHOUT THEY ARE THE MOST AT
RISK IN SO MANY. FOR OF WE KNOW
FROM FIFTH BEING THE FIRST TO
ASK THE STATE. OF THE MEDICAL
RECORDS AGING AND OTHER UNDER
CRIME CONDITION OF THEIR- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT AS YOU AGE THE
QUEUE MOTHER EFFECT WITH. AND
HOW. IN MOUNTAIN AND WE'RE
SEEING TO IN THE KEY. AND
THIRDLY WE KNOW THAT CAMINO.
COVER GETS. UP SPECIAL RED OF A
IN MAKE FACT BECAUSE VERY CHEN.
AND OLDER. ARE LIVING THOSE
BETTER. BECAUSE OF THOSE
DIFFERENT RISK- WE ARE SEEING
DEATHS IN OUR STATE OUR OF OUR
FAMILY AND OUR FRIENDS AND OUR
NEIGHBORS WHO ARE OVER SIXTY
FIVE. THE LATEST DATA IS IN THE
HIGH SEVENTIES EIGHTY PERCENT-
AND OF COURSE TAKE THE FLUID IN
FLUCTUATING BUT- IT'S CLEAR
THAT OLDER ADULTS. ARE BEARING
THE BRUNT OF THE FROM THE
HEALTH PERSPECTIVE.
ECONOMICALLY THERE ALSO CURIOUS
ISSUES FOR OVER CALIFORNIANS
OUT- OLDER CALIFORNIA'S OVER
FIFTY FIVE. OR ABOUT ABOUT A
20% OF THE WORKFORCE IN
DOMINATED EDUCATION AND HEALTH
AS WE HEARD EARLIER TODAY.
BUSINESS MANAGEMENT- AND ARE
STAYING HOME FROM WORK. A
LIVING WORK ARE GOING TO HAVE A
GREAT I CAN AND THAT WILL. IN
BOTH THEIR SHORT TERM NEED TERM
LONG TERM RETIRE PROF. BECAUSE
OF. CONCERNS FOR OLDER HEALTH
FOR IN OUR WE WERE TO. AND
COURSE THE- LET A MOST OLDER
ADULTS ARE LIVE IN PART FAMILY
WORKING. AND AT THE- CAN BE.
AND SO THE ENTIRE ECONOMIC
IMPACT MULTI GENERATIONAL. ON
OLDER ADULTS WHO MAY NEED MORE
CARE DIFFERENT HAIR CHANGING
HERE. ARE REALLY OF THE WHOLE
FAMILY WHOLE COMMUNITY IMPACT.
AND THEN THIRDLY THE CHALLENGES
AND NEEDS. ARE THE GOVERNOR THE
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZED THAT
THEIR WORK CHALLENGES THE NEEDS
AND THE AGING. SYSTEM AND
SERVICES IN OUR STATE I AM
CALLING FOR THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING LAST YEAR IN THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND
IT'S AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH YOU ALL. AND
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE CABINET
WORK GROUP AND THE PUBLIC TO
REALLY LISTEN ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES. FACING OUR SYSTEM-
OUR STATE AS WE WANT TO BE THE
BEST STATE THE GOLDEN STATE FOR
THE GOLDEN YEARS. BUT WE DO
HAVE CHALLENGES THE NEEDS AND
THIS CRISIS REALLY HAVE. THROWN
THOSE THOSE ARE CHALLENGES INTO
SHARP RELIEF- WHERE WE ARE
STRONG WE HAVE EXCELLED IN
WHERE WE HAVE GAP WE HAVE HAD
TO REALLY- DOUBLE DOWN- TO
ADDRESS THAT AND SO I WILL GO
GO TO THAT A MORE SPECIFIC. BUT
REALLY THE STATE HAD BEEN SET
BY THE PRIORITY- AND BEGINNING
TO EMERGE IN THE MASTER PLAN
PROCESS. ARE THE PRIORITY THAT
WE ARE FOCUSING. ON IN OUR
RESPONSE. IN TERMS OF THAT
APART RAPIDLY. TO A I WOULD
POINT YOU TO WALK THROUGH OUR
STRAT. BUT THEY ALSO. IN OUR OF
SPECIAL OF NEW THAT WE RELEASED
ON FRIDAY. MATTERS IN THEIR
NEWSLETTER. AND YOU CAN FIND IT
ON OUR WEBSITE AGING DOT CA DOT
GOV LONG WITH OTHER. HELPFUL
INFORMATION WE THANK OUR FOR.
OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE DISABILITY
FAMILY AND FRIENDS RESPONDING
TO THE CODE RED. OF CRISIS BUT
THERE ARE FOUR STRATEGIES THAT
WE HAVE FOCUSED ON FIRST AND
FOREMOST SERVING PEOPLE
REDESIGNING OUR SERVICE IS
EXPANDING OUR SERVICES TO MEET
THE MOMENT. OUR LARGEST
PROGRAMS ARE OLDER CALIFORNIANS
NUTRITION PROGRAM. ARE THEY
HAVE BEEN BOTH HOME DELIVERED
MEALS. AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
DELIVERED MAIL THE COMMUNITY
CENTERS OF COURSE THOSE CENTERS
ARE CLOSED. AND HAVE THE MEAL
WHO VOTED TO DELIVERY SO NOW
ALL OF OUR DEAL PRO. ARE TO. OF
THE LAST WEEK WE HAVE DATA FOR
THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEALS
WERE SERVED IN MID APRIL. OF
40% HIGHER THAN THAT OUR USUAL
AVERAGE THAT WE ARE SERVING
MORE PEOPLE MORE FOOD. FINDING
NEW VOLUNTEERS ARE USING OTHER
WORKFORCE. OF OUR NETWORK OF-
COUNTY. AND NONPROFIT. AGENCIES
ON A HAVING RISEN TO THAT. AND
COLLABORATIVE WAYS MOVED MORE
FOOD MARK AND IF THEY WAY. OF
COURSE WE ALSO PARTNER WITH THE-
WITH YOU JUST. CRITICAL NEED
COMPORT HEALTH PROGRAM FOLDER.
AND PEOPLE DISABILITY AS WELL
AS THE GOOD BANG PROGRAM. AND
THE NEW PARTNER OF THE PARTNER
COMING OUT OF THE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES WITH OUR AGENCY AROUND
GREAT PLATE. AND WORKING AT THE
PORT BOW RESTAURANT AND ADULTS
AT HOME. A AREA OF OUR PRO. IS
WE PROVIDE OUR HEALTHCARE AND
HEALTH SERVICES. BUT LET'S
OLDER ADULTS A STADIUM HOMES OF
THEIR CHOICE. TO THE ONES THAT
ARE THE LARGEST OUR- BE
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
ARE FORMALLY KNOWN AS ADULT DAY
HEALTHCARE- THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
NOW BEING CERTAIN YOUR SERVICES
BEYOND THE WALLS. ARE VISIT
CONSERVATIVE THAT USED TO BE IN
PERSON AT THE COMMUNITY CENTER
ARE NOW OVER THE PHONE ARE NOW-
DRIVE BY WHICH THEY DID
SOMETHING REALLY HAD TO
REINVENT WHAT A COMMUNITY
CENTER MODEL LOKS LIKE WHEN WE
ARE NOW ALL STAYING AT HOME.
THE OUR MULTI SERVICE FINGERS.
LIKE PERFECT GIVE ME HOPE
PURPOSE YOUR SERVICE PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDE BOTH SOCIAL AND
HEALTH. SUPPORT FOR SOME OF THE
OUR MOST FRAIL. OLDER OF FOLKS
LIVING AT HOME ON THEIR OWN WHO
OTHERWISE MIGHT NEED TO BE IN A
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY HAVE
DOUBLE DOWN TO ON THEIR
TELEPHONE CONTACT TELEPHONE
SUPPORT CARE COORDINATION
WRAPAROUND- MAKING SURE IT'S
EVERYTHING IS CHANGING AROUND
THAT. BUT THEIR HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SUPPORT A REMAIN STRONG.
ALTHOUGH THOSE PROGRAMS AGAIN
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
AND MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES ARE REINVENTING
REDESIGNING TO KEEP SERVING
FOLKS. A THIRD MAJOR CLUB AREA
US INFORMATION THAT THE BOYS
NEW PUT INFORMATION IS HI. I
KNOW WE WANTED BE PART OF WITH
OF COURSE NEW CODE LINE
TELEPHONE LINE AND THE NIGHT
WEBPAGE. BUT THE MINISTRY SET
UP. BUT WE BOTH AGREE OUR ADULT
INFO LINE THAT CAN YOU TO YOUR
LOCAL AGENTS ARE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT. THE ACT AND QUICK
ROUTING FOLKS NEED AND WE PUT
RESOURCES OUT OF A RANGE
NUMBERS. A PROTECT SERVICES
WITH OUR CALL AT THE THAT.
ALZHEIMER'S HOTLINE FRAUD
HOTLINE A ARE P. PUT THAT OUT
INFORMING DIFFERENT. RECKON
THAT THE- OF OUR STATE WE HAVE
NEWSPAPER AL RUNNING A L. G. B.
Q. WE HAVE RADIO ADS RUNNING IN
SEVEN. EIGHT L<c.cyan>G. WE HAVE</c>
HOPE GOING OUT PARTICULARLY
TARGETING PEOPLE OVER EIGHTY. A
RATE RADIO PRINT DIGITAL AS
WELL. ARE GETTING YOUNGER OLDER
ADULTS WHO ARE ONLINE- SO
REALLY TRYING TO REACH ALL
CORNERS OF OUR STATE-
COMMUNITIES OF OUR STATE AND
MAKE SURE PEOPLE HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED. A FOURTH
PARTICULAR AREA OF CONCERN IS
STAYING AT HOME. IN GETTING
LONELY. THIS INTERFERING WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH FOR ALL OF US. NOW WE
IMMEDIATELY- WERE ABLE TO STAND
UP WITH SUPPORT OF OUR LOCAL
AREA. AGING AGENCIES THE
FRIENDSHIP LINE THAT. A
NATIONAL TREASURE THAT EXIST IN
THE BAY AREA FOR YEARS WE WERE
ABLE TO EXPANDED STATEWIDE A
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ONE ONE NINE.
FOR ANY OLDER ADULTS WHO JUST
WANT SOMEONE TO TALK TO. AT
ANYTIME PERSONAL DISABILITY A
CARE GIVER THE FRIENDLY LINE
THERE FOR YOU AND ABLE TO DEAL
WITH A CRISIS AS WELL. WE'VE
ALSO THIRTY CONFERENCE CALL
CHECK THEM WITH FRIENDS AND
FAMILY TO SUPPORT ALL THE CARE
GIVING HAPPENING THIS WEEK WILL
BE ON SELF CARE I COMMEND YOU
TO ADD N WEDNESDAY IF YOU
CAN'T. AND WE'RE TAKING A LOOK
ALSO DIGITAL DIVIDE AD SOME OF
THE CONVERSATION HERE ABOUT
TELEHEALTH AND OTHER- CRITICAL
CONNECTION VIDEO CHATTING WITH
YOUR GRANDCHILDREN WILL YOU
NEED TO HAVE. A BE ONLINE AND
HAVE ACCESS AND HAVE TOOLS THAT
ARE AFFORDABLE ACCEPTABLE. WE
HEARD THE SAN DIEGO GROUPS ON
THE WEB IN OUR LAST WEEK IN
WITH HEARING CONTEMPLATIVE
COULD GROUPS. ARE NEXT WEEK
ABOUT HOW PEOPLE ARE BRIDGING
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE FOR OLDER
ADULTS THERE'S SO MUCH MORE TO
DO IN THAT AREA. AND THE FIFTH
PROGRAM AREA THAT WE'VE WORKED
ON. OF COURSE IS THE
RESIDENTIAL. ARE THAT THE
RESIDENTIAL RIGHT OF OUR
NEIGHBORS AND FRIENDS AND
FAMILY WHO ARE IN RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY YOUR LONG TERM CARE ON
BIRDS PROGRAM. WE HAVE A FAQ
AND OTHER RESOURCES TO HELP
FAMILIES. WHO REALLY TRYING TO
NAVIGATE VERY CHALLENGING TIME.
GIVEN GIVEN THE INABILITY TO
VISIT. GIVEN THE RISK OF
INFECTION GIVEN THE- ALARMING
NEWS NATIONALLY AND ABOUT SOME
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES. IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE INFORMATION AND RESOURCES
AVAILABLE. FOR THOSE THAT ARE
FIVE PROGRAM AREAS THAT WE HAVE
REALLY OKAY SAID. WE'RE
DELIGHTED EXPANDED TO MEET THE
MOMENT. I DO WANT TO TOUCH
BRIEFLY ON OUR OTHER THREE
STRATEGIES. THAT WE ARE DOING
TO RESPOND. THE SECOND STRATEGY
IS ENGAGE OF THE IS REALLY BEEN
AMONG. OFFER OLDER TOLD. OF
THERE'S MORE COMMERCE. OF OUR
AGING THERE MAY BE HOW BEEN AND
IN IN C<c.cyan> A LONG TIME.</c>
THERE'S CAMPAIGNS WE HAVE BEEN
LEADING WITH MANY MANY PARTNERS
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR
INCLUDING ME. THE CAUCUSES- OF
BOTH HOUSES HERE. OTHER
CHECKING CAMPAIGN FIRST AND
FOREMOST ON BEGAN MARCH
FIFTEENTH ONE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS WERE OUT TO STAY
HOME AND HOW. OF AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE
FOOD. THE MEDICINE. YOU
CONNECTION OUR STATE WATER
DOING. FOR THE CHECKING
CAMPAIGN HAS BROUGHT IN ON
HEALTH PLANS DONE A WONDER JOB
ON I WANNA THANK OR HEALTHCARE
DEPARTMENT AND PARTNERING IN
REACHING OUT TO THE PLAN. FOR
THE CALL ALL OF OUR PROGRAM OF
COURSE THE WORLD TRYING TO
REACH NEW FOLKS WHO MAY NOT BE
CONNECTED SO PARTNERING WITH L.
TIMERS ASSOCIATION HEART LUNG
CANCER. A NEW PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WE STILL
CALIFORNIA TO INVOLVE COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND UNITED EMPLOYEES
AT THE AIRLINE EMPLOYEES AND
MAKING CALLS. UP WE WANT TO
JUST GENERATE MORE AND MORE AND
MORE CALLS IN THE FIRST MONTH
WE WERE ABLE TO COUNT THE ONES
SEVEN MILLION LPL CALLS MADE.
AND OF COURSE THERE ARE
CONGREGATIONS AND COMMUNITIES
AND NEIGHBORHOODS MAKING CALLS
ALL THE TIME BUT WE'RE NOT
COUNTING AND WE JUST NEED TO
KEEP THAT UP. THANK YOU
CAMPAIGN THAT WE HAVE OUR WERE
ON AND ONE SHOW FRIDAY. YEAH
FOUR MAY WHICH IS OLDER
AMERICANS MONTH AND THIS. YEAR
THE THING IS MAKE YOUR MARK WE
CAN OF NO THEME FOR THE WAY TO
CELEBRATE LIFT UP ALL THE WAY
THE OLDER CALIFORNIANS ARE
MAKING. YOUR MARK STAYING HOME-
AND WE SAY YOU MAY BE STAYING
AT HOME BUT YOU'RE NOT SITTING
ON THE SIDELINES PEOPLE ARE
DOING. ALL KINDS OF THINGS TO
COMMUNITY. YOUR TO THEIR
COMMUNITY AND THEIR FAMILIES
TAKE CARE OF THEIR HEALTH- AND
REALLY MAKE THEIR MARK. ON OUR
STATE THAT CRITICAL TIME AND WE
THANK THEM AND- WHAT LIFT UP
THE STORY. AND UP SACRIFICE AND
LEADERSHIP AND PURPOSE AT THIS
MOMENT. THE THIRD STRATEGY WE
HAVE EMPLOYED IS REALLY. OF
REPRODUCING FOR THE MOMENT OF
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. ARE
WE AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WE WERE
FULL STEAM AHEAD HEADING-
WORKING ON- RECOMMENDATION FOR
AREAS ACROSS THE TEN YEAR PLAN
BIRTH STATE AND LOCAL
BLUEPRINTS. WELL WE'VE GOT ON
PAUSE IN LATE MARCH. WE KNEW
THAT- MANY OF OUR PARTICIPANTS
MANY OF THE PUBLIC. I NEEDED TO
FOCUS. LASER FOCUSED ON ON
PUBLIC RESPONSE AND THAT HAVE
BEEN WHERE WE'VE BEEN THE PAST
SIX WEEKS- THAT SAID. IT WILL
IT IT IS A TABLE OF SOME OF THE
STATE'S LEADING EXPERTS AND SO
IT MAKES. PERFECT SENSE THAT
THEY ALSO WERE ABLE TO GIVE IT
TO. THE RAPID RESPONSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND HAVE BEEN
PRODUCING. BOTH FOR THE EQUITY
WORKGROUP AND A FULL
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS. OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM SECRETARY.
ALLEY TO CONSIDER ON EVERY FOR
I FULLY TO RESIDENTIAL. PP
TESTING ARE THEY BEEN RIGHT
THERE WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
AND NOW WE ARE READY TO COME
BACK TO THE MASTER PLAN TABLE
WE HAVE JUST ANNOUNCED THAT ARE
PREVIOUSLY SCHEDULED MEETING OF
MAY TWENTY EIGHTH WE WILL BE
KEEPING RECONVENING OF COURSE
IT'LL BE VIRTUAL AND A HALF DAY
INSTEAD OF I PERSON IN A FULL
DAY. AND WE'LL HAVE MORE
INFORMATION OUT ABOUT THE
PUBLIC ABOUT HOW WE CAN ALL
PARTICIPATE SAFELY BUT WILL BE
REALLY LOOKING OUT WHAT WHERE
DOES THE MASTER PLAN GO FROM
HERE GIVEN ON THE LESSONS THAT
WE ARE ALREADY BEGINNING TO
LEARN FROM THE CODE BUT
EXPERIENCE HOW WILL THAT
INFORM. AND DIRECT THE MASTER
PLAN THE WAY FORWARD. AND ALSO
HOW WE CAN PARTNER MORE DEEPLY
BUT THE GOVERNOR DEL TIMERS ARE
PREPAREDNESS AND PREVENTION
TASK FORCE LOTS OF OPPORTUNITY
THERE. TO COMBINE AND- AND BE
BETTER TOGETHER. THE MASTER
PLAN YOU'LL BE HEARING MORE
ABOUT. AGAIN AND WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL FOR THAT PROCESS AND
THAT PARTNERSHIP ALREADY BEING
IN PLACE TO HELP US MAKE THIS
MOMENT. AND THEN THE LAST THING
ON SAY VERY BRIEFLY- MANY OF
YOU HAVE BEEN. ASKING ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT PHONE EFFORTS TO
REINVENT AND STREAMLINED AND
I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT WE WERE
ABLE WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO. THE
FIRST FEDERAL FUNDS FASTER THAN
EVER BEFORE CHORE COUNTY AND
NONPROFIT. AGING AGENCIES. WE
HAVE A NEW DATA DASHBOARDS BUT
WE CAN SHARE THAT'S REAL DATA.
REAL TIME DATA. YOU KNOW
QUICKER IF YOU CAN SEE THE TO
THE RISING. ALL OF THEM THE
RIGHT NEIL THE RISE. HEALTH
COSTS. AND WE ARE TECHNOLOGY IN
WAYS WELL SO. MORE TO DO THERE
BUT CVA ON IT WAY. I THINK THE
LAST THING ALSO BEFORE UP HERE
QUESTION I DO ALL THE FALL FOR
QUEST AND HOPE I HAVE. SPOKEN
TO THEM AT LEAST IN SOME WAY
AND HAPPY TO TAKE MORE. IS JUST
TO. THE LEFT OF. GETS RECESSION.
AS WE ENTER THIS ECONOMIC
MOMENT THESE ARE PARTICULARLY
PAINFUL. MEMORIES FOR THOSE AN
AGING AND DISABILITY CMMUNITY
BECAUSE OF- THE DEPTH OF THE
CUTS THAT WERE MADE BAD AND
HELD BILL THE MEMORY OF THAT
LINGERS WITH ALL OF US. AND I
THINK AS WE ENTER. WHAT IS.
CLEARLY A TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES-
I THINK SOME OF THE THOUGHT
LESSON BUT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING AND DISCUSSING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS- AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF COURSE IS THE
FOCUS ON THE WHOLE PERSON. THE
WHOLE FAMILY AND THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY. THAT WE THINK ABOUT
ALWAYS THINK ABOUT PEOPLE- IS
THE SUM OF ALL OF THEIR PART-
AND HOLD THAT IN MIND. THAT WE
DO BRING THE VALUE TO THE TABLE
THAT WE ALL SHARE INCLUDING
COLLABORATION INCLUSION WITH
LEGISLATURE. AND STAKEHOLDERS.
A EVEN IN VERY TOUGH TIME YOU
LOOK FOR THOSE OPPORTUNITIES-
TO IMPROVE COORDINATION TO
IMPROVE DESIGN- PERHAPS FORCED
TO UP FOR CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE CHOSEN
BUT NONE THE LESS OPPORTUNITIES
TO. TO MAKE TO MAKE PROGRESS
EVEN EVEN EVEN IN. EVEN IN THE
VERY VERY TOUGH TIME. SO WE
WILL BRING LOOK LOOKING
FORWARD- AS WE ENTER A ON
CERTAIN AND UNCLEAR ECONOMIC
PICTURE- BUT KNOW THAT WILL DO
THAT THE PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND OF COURSE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE PERSON FOR
MOST. WITHOUT ZERO POINT STOP
AND I'M GLAD TO ADDRESS THE
PANEL AND TAKING YOUR COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR MCCOY WEIGHED NEXT WE
HAVE FRANK MECCA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
FRANK MCCONNELL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS THE NATION ARE
MEMBERSHIP MINISTER THE
MAJORITY OF THAT THINKING THAT
PROGRAMS THAT WERE MENTIONED BY
DIRECTOR JOHNSON IN HER
TESTIMONY. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
AND THAT MAKE IT ONE LIKE
ANYTHING AT THE END OF MY
THIRTY YEARS WORKING IN
SERVICES. THANK YOU EVERY
PROGRAM THE- AND EVERY CLIENT-
THAT WE SERVE ALMOST FIFTEEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WERE
TOUCHED BY COMMUNITY SERVICES
AGENCY AT SOME POINT IN THE
YEAR. WE'RE REALLY PROUD TO
LIVE IN A STATE WHERE THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED REALLY EXCELLENT AND
HUMANE LEADERSHIP INDICATE THE-
PANDEMIC. AND I'D BE REMISS IF
I DIDN'T ACKNOWLEDGE THE
EXCELLENT PARTNERSHIP OF THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES. AS
WE MET UNPRECEDENTED TIME THAN
I SHOULD SAY. I CAN JUST TAKE
COUNTY PARTNERSHIP ALL PERFECT
THAT IS ALWAYS THE KEY THAT
THAT WOULD SERVICE BROKE. BUT
NEVER MORE URGENTLY THAN DURING
A CRISIS. CAN I HELP FOCUSED ON
WHAT WE'RE SEEING THE COUNTY
MISTER LEVEL AT THE GRAY LEVEL.
WITH THE NIGHT OF THE BUT ALSO
A YOU TO GET RECOGNITION OF THE
LESSONS THAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM
THE PRIOR RECESSION. THAT WE
LIVED THROUGH WE'VE ALSO
PROVIDED A MEMO TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND TO THE GOVERNOR
THAT OUTLINES COMPREHENSIVELY
ARE THOUGHT. ABOUT HOW THE
STATE CAN MOVE FORWARD IN MEET
THE HUMAN SERVICES THE
POPULATION. MICHAEL OBSERVATION
WOULD BE THAT SIX. THINKING UP
THIS FOR TRY BLACK. IF THEY
WORK WELL JAMIE TO GROW DEMAND.
AND I THINK THAT THE TAP OF
YOUR STATE BEING ADDED AS- AND-
PEOPLE FALL UNEXPECTEDLY- INTO
ECONOMIC AND SECURITY ARE WE
THERE TO MEET THEIR NEEDS AND I
SHOULD SAY THAT. I'M I'M PROUD
IN CALIFORNIA THAT- ARE
SPEAKING AT HAS BEEN QUITE
RESPONSIVE. TWO THE
UNPRECEDENTED. DIRECTOR
JONATHAN MENTIONED THE APRIL
YEAR OVER YEAR NUMBERS OF
INCREASE APPLICATION A DOUBLING
ALMOST IN CALIBRATION- ABOUT A
33% INCREASE IN APPLICATIONS
FOR CAL WORK. DIRECTOR JUMP NOT
TO MENTION HOW THE COUNTY THERE
SOARED MEETING THE CHALLENGE WE
VERY QUICKLY AND NIMBLY HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO PROVIDE.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED OUR SERVICES ACT THAT THE
SERVICES ALL AT THE SAME TIME.
AREN'T MANAGING THROUGH
SHELTERING ORDERS IN KEEPING
OUR STATE STAFF AND- A LOT OF
CREATIVITY AND HARD WORK- AND-
I SHOULD POINT OUT- SEXUAL
SHOUT OUT TO THE PEOPLE WHO RUN
THAT COMPUTER SYSTEM THE
THOUGHT THAT. WHO WORKED
INCREDIBLY QUICKLY AND NIMBLY
TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT ALL OF
THE MANY EXCELLENT CHANGES THAT
HAVE COME THROUGH THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT ONE TIME RESOURCES ALSO
THAT THE GOVERNOR ADDED- WITH
THE FUNDS APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP BUT-
ACCOMMODATE THIS REALLY
DRAMATIC SPIKE IN AN INCREASED
DEMAND FOR OUR SERVICES- WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO CONTINUE THAT
BECAUSE THIS COMING AND WE
BELIEVE IT'S CERTAINLY NOT.
GOING TO- RICH. AS QUICKLY AS
ANY OF US WOULD LIKE- I'D ALSO
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE A WORKLOAD UBBLE
BECAUSE SOME OF THE WORKLOAD.
MODIFICATION THAT WERE MADE FOR
EXAMPLE THE GOVERNOR ISSUED A
MORATORIUM ON ITS CONTINUANCE.
BUT AT SOME POINT THE WORKLOAD
HAVE TO BE DONE BY COUNTY SO
THE WORKLOAD WITH JUST HEARD
NOT A LIMITED COMPLETELY FELL
AS WE EMERGE FROM EXECUTIVE
ORDERS THAT THEY EXPIRE AND AS
WE SEE AN INCREASE DEMAND FROM
PEOPLE WHO NEED OUR SERVICE
SAYS ONE OF THE THINGS WE
LEARNED FROM THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT IS THAT IF WE HAVE TO
BE INTENTIONAL INTENTIONAL
ABOUT UNDERSTANDING IN MANAGING
THE WORKLOAD BUBBLE SO THAT WE
CAN TIME WE NEED. WE NEED THE
PEOPLE PER LIFESAVING LIKE OF
STAVING ASSISTANT THAT BEING.
AND ONE LAST THING THAT WE CAN
LEARN THE HARD WAY FROM THE
GREAT RECESSION IN RESPONSE TO
THE GREAT RECESSION BUDGET
DECISION SIGNIFICANTLY DAMAGE
THE HUMAN SERVICES
INFRASTRUCTURE. MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT IN A MOMENT FOR THE
HUMAN SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE
BE TO BE ABLE TO NEED TIMELY
AND ACCURATELY THE DEMAND OF
PEOPLE. FOR YOU CHRISTIAN AT
THE INTERNET CANNOT MAKE IT THE
AND THE THING THEY NEED TO FEED
THEIR CHILDREN AND KEEP A ROOF
OVER THEIR HAT- WE SELL
DECIMATED THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT AND YOU WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES- TO RESUME
SERVICE SAID. YOUR WITH STEP
GET THAT IT NEEDED TO BACK UP.
AND SO THE WHIPPED FOLLOWING.
BETWEEN DEEP CUT AND THEN THE
DESIRE TO RE EMERGE- I THINK
EXACERBATED THE RECESSION.
LENGTHEN THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
TOOK FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
RESUME MEETING PEOPLE'S NEEDS
IN THE WAY THAT ANYONE WOULD
HAVE ONE. MY SECOND OBSERVATION
IS ONE THAT YOU KNOW WELL
MISTER CHAIR- AND BE HEALED THE
HUMAN COST OF THE PROPERTY
THINKING IT IS SIGNIFICANT-
WE'VE SEEN THAT NUMBER COULD I
TALK ABOUT IN DIRECTOR JOHN
GOING T TALK ABOUT REALLY
SPEAKS TO. THAT THE LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
TEETERING ON THE EDGE IN HER
EXPERIENCE BEING ECONOMIC AND
SECURITY. ARE COUNTY BROUGHT
THAT WOULD NOT SIGNIFICANT
PLAYERS IN THE ADMINISTRATION
OF HOMELESSNESS SERVICES
INCLUDING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROJECT ROOM KEY. AND WE ARE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS. THAT HAD MADE IT EASIER
FOR PEOPLE TO GET AND TO KEEP
THEIR BENEFIT. WE STRONGLY
ADVOCATED FOR THEM AND WORKED
REALLY HARD TO IMPLEMENT THAT
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR- LEADERSHIP AND
PUTTING THEM FOR. WE THINK THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY
SHOULD EXTEND BEYOND JUNE- AND
I THINK WE NEED TO- LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE ECONOMY
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING- IN THE
ECONOMY THAT FAMILIES AND LOW
INCOME PEOPLE TO SEE. WHICH OF
THOSE. FEATURES THAT WERE
ISSUED THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO CONTINUE
AND THE CABLE CALVET TIME
LIMIT- I THINK THAT THE-
RECESSION IN THE PANDEMIC.
DEMONSTRATE CONCLUSIVELY THAT
THEY DON'T HELP. ARM AND THEY
SHOULD BE PERMANENTLY REMOVED
FROM THE CAL WORKS PROGRAM. BUT
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
EXTRA RESOURCES THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PUT INTO
HOMELESSNESS THE CREATIVITY THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. I'M WE BELIEVE
THAT THOSE LESSONS THAT WE
LEARNED IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THOSE PROGRAMS- THAT MIGHT
SUBJECT PERMANENT WAYS THAT WE
CAN- COME TO THINK THAT WE CAN
DO AS WE MOVE FORWARD- TO KEEP
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LEARNING THAT ARE WORKING. ACT
AS- AS ARE A PART OF OUR
HOMELESSNESS. COMBAT EFFORT TO
THAT WE MOVE FORWARD. SO WE
LOOK AT FUTURE WE'RE NOT WELL
CUNNINGHAM INTERPRETED EIGHT
NOW PERHAPS BETTER THAN. THE
TYPICAL POSITION MY HAT AND WE
URGE YOU TO MAINTAIN BENEFITS
LEVEL THE MOST VULNERABLE.
DON'T LEAVE OUT ON DOCKING
PEOPLE ARE UNIQUELY VULNERABLE
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO IF YOU WERE
SUPPORT AND I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT MOST OF THEM ARE ARE YEAH
IT'D BE AM PLEASED WITH IT THAN
CHILDREN WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT PROVIDED
VITAL SUPPORT. FOR UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE AND I THINK WE THIS CAN
GO FURTHER BY ALLOWING PEOPLE
FILE. THAT COULD INDICATE
NUMBERS. TO ACT AT THE STATE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT- WE
ALSO THINK THAT WE SHOULD
LEVERAGE OUR HUMAN SERVICES
LINKS HOME WITH MATH PROGRAM
BUILT WITHIN THE COWL WORKS
PROGRAM IN THE CHILD WELFARE
PROGRAM AND YOU DAHLE
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM-
YOU THE LEGISLATURE AND AT AN
AD ENACTED PROGRAMS THAT ARE
USED TO PREVENT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACCESSING THOSE PROGRAMS THOUGH
CALLARD FAMILY FOR EXAMPLE THE
ACCENT THAT CALVERT COUNTY
SUPPORT PROGRAMS TO PREVENT.
HOMELESSNESS AND CAN. RE HOUSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCESSING THOSE
PROGRAM ON ONE OF THE BIG
FEARS. ARM AND LEGITIMATE
THREAT THAT THE PANDEMIC LED
RECEPTION- THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
OUT FOR IS THAT POSSIBLE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN ALMOST
AND WE HAVE AFFECTED PROGRAM AS
PART OF OUR HUMAN SERVICES
NETWORK THAT WE CAN LEVERAGE.
I'M IF I SAY ANYTHING TODAY
THAT DEBT I HOPE YOU REMEMBER
IT THERE. THE DAMAGE OF DEEP
POVERTY TO CHILDREN IS OFTEN
TURNING. SO AT THE CHAIR
POINTED OUT IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS EVEN ONE SPELL A DEEP
POVERTY CAN AFFECT A CHILD'S
FOR THEIR LIFETIME. WE DON'T
GET A DO OVER WE DON'T GET TO
DO GOOD WE DON'T GET TO DEFER
THE MAINTENANCE ON A CHILD TO
BRING IT'S NOT LIKE FIXING A
ROUTE. SO WE HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE POSSIBLY
CAN. BUT FOR THE TOXIC EFFECTS.
OF NOW TREATMENT OF ECONOMIC
INSECURITY AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T- DO ANYTHING TO
EXACERBATE. THAT AS TROUT
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE
THE THAT THE MINISTER TRIAL
MIKE CHANT THE- PERMANENTLY- WE
DIDN'T DO THAT ARE COMING OUT
OF THE GREAT RECESSION- WE MAKE
CUT. TO BENEFIT LEVEL. WE DID
NOT PROVIDE INFLATION
ADJUSTMENT COULD BENEFIT LEVELS
AND WE DID BECAUSE IT IS ONE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN
IN THE POVERTY. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S ATTEMPT OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS TO MAKE IT
SO THAT NO CHILD IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA EVER LET THEM BE
POVERTY WE SHOULD CONTINUE
THAT. ARE THAT EFFORT- AND WE
SHOULD NEVER DO WE DID- IN
RESPONSE TO THE GREAT RECESSION
AGAIN. THE THIRD POINT I'D LIKE
TO MAKE AND THAT SAFETY NET
SERVICES ARE COUNTER
RECESSIONARY. WE KNOW THAT
BENEFITS RECEIVED BY LOW INCOME
PEOPLE HAVE TYPICALLY HAD A
HIGHER MULTIPLIER EFFECT THAN
OTHERS- TRACK THE GOVERNMENT
AID. BUT BECAUSE LOW INCOME
PEOPLE SPEND THEIR MONEY. THEY
HAVE TO I'M GONNA GET. INTO
COMMUNITY THAT HAS A MULTIPLIER
EFFECT. ONE OTHER LEFT AND WE
LEARN FROM THE GREAT DEPRESSION
FROM THE GREAT RECESSION IS THE
TARGETED EMPLOYMENT YOU'RE
GETTING YOUR GAME. CAN ACTUALLY
HELP BUSINESSES GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET PARTICULARLY I AM
SPEAKING ABOUT SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT- IN THE WAKE OF THE
GREAT RECESSION PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S STIMULUS PROGRAM. SO
CALLED ARE- GAVE SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA THAT WE
USED TO RAMP UP SUBSIDIZED
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM WHERE WE
TEMPORARILY AND PARTIALLY
SUBSIDIZE THE WAGES OF
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE WILLING TO
HIRE OUR CLIENT. WE PUT ROUGHLY
TWENTY THOUSAND FAMILIES
INTERCEPT THAT I'D BEEN POINTED
JOB. IT'S GOOD FOR CLIENTS
BECAUSE THE ABSENT THE OF THE
ABILITY TO GET IN ON A NON
THOUGHT THAT I JOBS YOU GIVE
THEM WORK EXPERIENCE WE GIVE
THEM REAL WAGE BATESINCOME
THAT THEY CAN'T DâN PAR LES
INTO EVEN MORE RESOURCES VIA
THAT FEDERAL AND STATE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT. FOR
BUSINESSES THAT REDUCES THE
RISK OF REDUCES THE COST FOR
THEM. TO DO WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO WHICH IS TO RE EMPLOYED
PEOPLE. TO GROW THEIR BUSINESS
SAYS- AN INCREASE THEIR WORK
FORCE. AND SO WHILE WE MAY NOT
GET ADDITIONAL FEDERAL MONEY AS
WE DID DURING THE OBAMA
STIMULUS PROGRAM WE DO HAVE A
STATE SEVEN THAT THAT THAT I'D
COMPLAIN THAT PROGRAM AS PART
OF IT AS PART OF CAL WORK. WE
HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
SIMPLIFY AND STREAMLINE
EXISTING PROGRAM- AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE TARGETED CALL
THAT RESPONSE RELATED TO
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN LIGHT AND-
THE RECESSION THAT THAT WE'RE
ENTERING INTO- WE SHOULD THINK
WE SHOULD CONSIDER. LEVERAGING
SUBSIDIZED EMPLOYMENT AS A
STRATEGY THAT WORK NOT JUST FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE BUT ALSO
FORGET. AND THE FINAL POINT I'D
LIKE TO MAKE MISTER CHAIR. ONE
AT THE RECTOR JOHNSON ALLUDED
TO. AND I'M TURNING MY
ATTENTION NOW TO THE PROTECTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ADMINISTERED BY COUNTY
MATERNITY AGENT. PERHAPS OUR
BIGGEST FEAR ADDED PANDEMIC.
THE REALITY THAT ABUSE AND
NEGLECT FLOURISH IN ISOLATION.
WE RELY ON OUR COMMUNITY TO BE
THE EYES AND EARS TO BE ON THE
LOOKOUT FOR BOTH CHILD
MALTREATMENT AN ADULT MALE
TREATMENT- WHEN CHILDREN AREN'T
IN SCHOOL WHEN ELDERLY PEOPLE
ARE SHELTERED AND PEOPLE THAT
NORMALLY WOULD BE LOOKING IN ON
AND CAN- CHILD. MALTREATMENT
CAN INCREASE- AT DIRECTOR
JONATHAN POINTED OUT WE ARE
CHILD WELFARE AGENCY THAT IN
ABOUT A 50% REDUCTION IN
REFERRAL TO OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE HOTLINE LARGELY
ATTRIBUTED TO THE FACT THAT
CHILDREN LEARN IN SCHOOL THAN
THAT SCHOOL THAT THE BIGGEST
THREAT. REPORTER OF AN EVENING
LACK. WITH RESPECT TO EL BEAT
AND NEGLECT WE KNOW FROM
RESEARCH ISOLATE. IS THE NUMBER
ONE RISK FACTOR FOR ABUSE AND
NEGLECT INCLUDING SELF NEGLECT
FOR THE ELDER FOR ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT. I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT-
YOU KNOW FOR THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE. THAT COUNTY
REALIGNMENT FUN PROVIDE THE
LION'S SHARE OF NON FEDERAL
CAUGHT. BY CHILD ABUSE AND
ELDER ABUSE DOES REALIGNMENT
BONNIE IN SOCIAL SERVICES
CONTACT ARE LARGELY FAILED BACK
FUND. COUNTIES ANTICIPATE A
STEEP DECLINE IN THE IN THAT
FUNDING NUMBER THINKING IT
COULD BE AS MUCH AS AND 20%
THEM WE HOPE NOT IT IT SEEMS
OBVIOUS THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE A VERY SIGNIFICANT DECLINE
ANOTHER SEVEN YEARS. THAT THE
REALIGNMENT LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED BOTH THE NINETEEN
NINETY ONE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT PROGRAM
NEVER ANTICIPATED. THERE IS NO
STATUTORILY REQUIRED OR
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED
GENERAL FUND BACKSTOPS. RELIEF
PROGRAM SO DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE LARGELY
STATE AND FEDERAL MANDATE
COUNTY ONLY HAVE THE
REALIGNMENT REVENUES WITH NO
GUARANTEED PROTECTION FROM THE
STATE- TO SURPRISED TO PROVIDE
A SAFETY NET BETWEEN THEM. ON
HOW HE GENERAL REVENUE- ARE
DECLINING SIGNIFICANTLY AS WELL.
THE REALIGNMENT STRUCTURE ONE
NOT BUILT TO HANDLE A STEEP
DECLINE IN REVENUE OF THE LIKE
OF THE AMOUNT THAT WE'RE LIKELY
TO SEE UNDERSTATEMENT COUNTY
SIMPLY HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER
ABOUT YOUR NEEDS REVENUE THAN
YOUTH PROGRAM. IN ADDITION TO
THE FEELING OF STATE OBLIGATION
TO TRUE UP COUNTY CAUGHT UNDER
THAT CPR INITIATIVE. OR IF
NEVER DOUBLE THAT SERVICE ARE
GOING TO BE DE CUT SIR A FEW
PEOPLE ARE BEING ABUSED IN A-
OVER AT RISK OF BEING ABUSED
NEGLECTED INCLUDING CHILDREN.
WITH RESPECT TO THE CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES PROGRAM IN
FOSTER CARE I THINK WE NEED TO
PARTICULARLY FOCUS. ON
SUPPORTING CARE GIVERS SO THAT
WE HAVE SAFE LOVING PLACES FOR
CHILDREN TO HEAL FROM THE NOW
TREATMENT THAT THEY SUFFERED.
WE ANTICIPATE. A BUBBLE IN KID
COMING INTO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM WHEN KIDS GO BACK TO
SCHOOL. AND WE WILL GET MORE
REFERRAL FOR THE HOTLINE. AS A
DIRECTOR JOHNSON POINTED OUT-
WE DO HAVE- SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS THAT COURT CLOSURES
HAD CAUSED SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD
BACKLOG ON IN THE DEPENDENCY
COURT. SO FAMILY REUNIFICATION
NOT HAPPENING OR- GUARDIANSHIP
SIR ADOPTION- THE BACKING UP OF
THAT WORK IS ALSO GOING TO
CREATE A WORKLOAD BUBBLE. AND
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE- I THINK A
TICKET AGAIN ISSUE WITH HAVING
AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF A GOOD
LOBBYING RESOURCE FAMILY. IN
ORDER TO SURE UP- WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THOSE RESOURCE
GAMBLING ARM AND BRING THEM
INTO THE SYSTEM IN A THAT
STREAMLINED AWAY IF POSSIBLE.
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR-
CONTINUE TO AGGRESSIVELY AND
EXPEDITIOUSLY IMPLEMENTED. THE
CHAIRS PLEDGES LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM THE FIRST
SYSTEM WHICH PROVIDES AN
EMERGENCY HOTLINE AND A MOBILE
RESPONSE FOR CHILDREN-
FAMILIES. THAT ARE HAVING AN
URGENT SITUATION THAT OTHERWISE
COULD RESULT IN A PLACEMENT
DISRUPTION OR A CALL TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WE ALSO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
STREAMLINING THE RESOURCE
FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS THAT
THE PROCESS BY WHICH WE BRING
FAMILIES THEN AND THAT THEM ON
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN BE-
EXCELLENT CARE GIVERS- AND WE
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THAT
EFFECT. IN THE LETTER THAT WE
PROVIDED TO YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WITH RESPECT TO VICTIMS OF
ELDER ABUSE WE'RE CONTINUING TO
DO ALL WE CAN APPRECIATE THE
RESOURCES THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CHECK IN ON
PEOPLE- WHO ARE WHO CAN'T BE-
CHECKED IN BY THE PEOPLE WHO
NORMALLY COME IN CONTACT WITH
THEM BECAUSE OF SHELTERING
REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO INTERVENE AS WE EMERGED FROM
ISOLATION AND WE INEVITABLY
THE- ABUSE AND NEGLECT
INCLUDING SELF NEGLECT THAT
OCCURRED. ON DURING THE
SHELTERING PERIOD. WE ALSO IN
THAT POPULATE IS UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE TO HOMELESSNESS- MOM
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
SHOULD LEVERAGE THE HOME STATE
PROGRAM. WHICH ARE HOMELESSNESS
SERVICES THAT WE CAN USE TO
PREVENT. AND TO RE HOW VICTIMS
OF ELDER ABUSE AND NEGLECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE NOW- I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
PANEL. THANK YOU MISTER MAC
ISLAND NEXT WE HAVE A MORE I'LL
DO JOLLY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COULD GIVE
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL WORKS OFFICE
AT AMERICAN WERE COLLEGE AND ON
BEHALF OF. OTHER MILLION ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE SUFFERING
THE SAME. BOB HARDSHIPS THAT
I'M GOING THROUGH SPECIALLY
DURING THIS ON CERTAIN TIMES
I'LL START BY SAYING THAT YOU
CAME FROM IRAQ IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN TO CALIFORNIA. I WORK
WITH THE USA FOR THREE YEARS ON
A HUGE PROGRAMS. THAT WILL BE A
GREAT HELP TO BEST POPULATIONS
SUCH AS SOCIAL SECURITY
PROGRAMS AND RETIREMENT PROGRAM
AND MANY OTHERS. I WAS
THREATENED BY ON PUBLISHERS BUT
WORKING WITH THE AMERICANS.
THERE WERE A FEW ATTEMPTS TO
KIDNAP AND KILL ME BECAUSE OF
THAT. BUT THANK GOD I WAS ABLE
TO ESCAPE EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
THE- I HAVE APPLIED FOR. THAT'S
A. B. SPECIAL PROGRAM LEADER.
AND I GOT ACCEPTED ME AND MY
WIFE AND MY SON. WE CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES WHICH IS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM VARMINT SOLDIER
ECONOMICS AND WORK SPACE. WE
CAME HERE WITH NO MONEY WOULD
NOT SO MISSION ABOUT ANYTHING
OR ANYONE. THE ONLY THING THAT
KEPT US ALIVE AND PROVIDE AT
LEAST OVER OUR HEADS. WAS THE
PUBLIC BENEFITS. HELLO TO
ACCOMPLISH PROGRAMS WHAT THE
GIFTS THANK YOU A SECOND
CHANCE. AFTER I SAW THAT WE ARE
DOING. UTILIZING THOSE PROGRAMS
GAVE US SOME HOPE AND TIME TO
GET YOU KNOW I'M BLIND INTO THE
SYSTEM. WE WERE SOMEWHAT STABLE.
MENTALLY AND ECONOMICALLY WHICH
GAVE US A BOOST TO CATCH OUR
BREATH AND GET THE BILL WOULD
BE TO SEARCH AND DISCOVER THE
RIGHT WAY IT LOOKS LIKE. ANSWER
OUR THOUGHTS ON THE RIGHT TRACK
TO BE SOLD JUST INDEPENDENT
FOLLOWERS TO PROVIDE. AT THAT
LIFE FOR US AND FOR OUR KIDS.
AND ALL TO HELP WITH YOU AROUND
US AND GIVE BACK TO THE SOCIETY
AND RETURN THE FAVOR. TELL ONCE
WHAT I WANT ONE THIRD THAT HELP
US TO WALK. THROUGH THE TRIAL
LOS MY WIFE AND I. WERE ABLE TO
GET A PART TIME JOB. AT THE
SCHOOL AND MANAGE TO GAIN TWO
IMPORTANT THINGS. FIRST AND
YOUR FAMILY AT WORKS THAT
HELPED US TO GO TO GO THROUGH
TOUGH TIMES. AND SECOND IF
SINUS YOU NEED TO PROVIDE FOR
OUR KIDS WITH ALL WHAT THE
NEEDS OF THE SYSTEM WHICH ABOUT
THE PAST. WITH THE HELP OF
TROUBLES I WAS ABLE TO MAINTAIN
A BALANCE. BETWEEN MY STUDY
WORKS HOME NEEDS AND SPENDING
TIME WITH MY PRECIOUS GETS. I
WILL CHOOSE THE SHIP THAT
SAILED US THE ON. LINED UP
DREAMS. BUT ONE FOR. SHOP
BEFORE THAT LINE. UNFORTUNATELY
THE FOR YOU OF AGE ARE NOT IN
THE HOUSE. FOR THAT DREAM TO
COME TRUE. INNOCENT MASS MOST
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ONE AGAIN
SCHOOL AND THEY JUST I COULD.
THEY HAVE TO WAIT FOR A YEAR TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE CELTS
COMMUNITY PROBLEMS. BOX YOU.
THE WAY THE CLASSES TO. AND TO
PAY SO MUCH MONEY FOR THE CLASS.
AND ALL THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ENGLISH AS THEIR SECOND
LANGUAGE IN ORDER STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE SCHOOL THEY NEED TO
FINISH SEVEN COURSES SELECT
WITH. IT TAKES PLACE IN THE
MOBILE ALL PREVIOUS. AND EACH
COURSE IS THE PREREQUISITE FOR
THE FOLLOWING ONE AND MUTUAL IS
FOR YOU. AND NEEDS AT LEAST
WEEKS UNLESS TO BE A TO SENATE
THAT FOR. ONE YEAR FOR BLOCKING
OF AND MORE THAN YEARS THE DE
IS FOUR YEARS TOTAL OKAY. ONLY
TO GET THE A BEFORE SO THE
UNIVERSITY GET THE PATCH THAT
THE- I'M A COMPUTER SCIENCE
MAJORS. I WILL INVOLVED ALMOST
ALL THE SENATE YOU ABOUT SKIP
ANY YOU CAN SUMMER. I HAD A GPA
OF POINT NINE FIVE. AND I NOT
TAKE ANY BECAUSE- AND I CHURCH
TEACHING SERVE SMALL TO TWENTY
ONE. JUST TO FINISH WHILE I'M
STILL ON A BUT UNFORTUNATELY
THAT TIME WAS NOT ENOUGH. MY
FORTY YEARS OF SALAS RECENTLY.
WHICH FORCING THE TO FIND AN
EXCELLENT JOB. AT THE DELIVERY
DRIVER SO AMAZON. AND
JEOPARDIZE MY LIFE BEING
ASTHMATIC IF YOU'RE IN THIS
UNCERTAIN. WITH THE OUT OF THE
NINE. AND JEOPARDIZING THE
LIVES MY SAM. THE SPECIAL MY
SON WHO'S AT TO. ONLY TO PAY
RENT. THAT ALSO AFFECTED MY GPA
NAY GETS. AND FORCE. NOT TO
FOCUS ON MY ACADEMICS. NOT TO
MENTION NOT HAVING A HEART A
JOB AND OPEN TWENTY ONE UNITS
IN THREE DIFFERENT COLLEGES AT
THE SAME TIME. NEVER GAVE ME
ANY TIME TO SPEND WITH MY WIFE.
AND MY TEN YEARS ALL BOY AND
LIKE FIVE YEARS OLD DAUGHTER. I
REALLY MISS THAT. TO CLOSE MY-STATEMENT. I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
THAT CARLOS BUT WE MORE TIME
WITH MY KIDS. OUR STATE NEAR
FAMILY AT WORK WHEN I THIS IS
MY FAMILY'S. CARLOS GAVE ME A
HOPE. OF GETTING THIRTY WORKING
CAREER YOU BUY A HOUSE. THAT
HAS A BACKYARD TO MAKE THE
CHANGE OF MY KIDS COME TRUE.
AND THAT IS TO HAVE A NICE
BACKYARD THEY CAN PLAY IN IT.
AND TO BE ABLE TO OWN A SMALL
DOG. ADDING ONE MORE YEAR TO
ALL THE TIME CLOCK. WOULD BE
LIFESAVING. IT WILL GIVE ME THE
ENERGY TO FINISH MY SCHOOL
FASTER AND TO DEPEND ON MYSELF
FOR THE LIKES OF MY FAMILY. IT
WILL HELP ME TO PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO MY KIDS NEEDS.
SOME DATA COULD ANNEX TO THEIR
PARENTS IN GAME DYNASTIES. MY
FAMILY AND I. ON A CASE I'M ON
MILLIONS OF OTHERS CASES. THAT
NEEDS ATTENTION AND ASSISTANCE
TO DO MUCH BETTER. WE NEED TO
ADD. HELP YOU THE- TO BUILD A
BETTER FUTURE FOR US AND FOR
OUR COMMUNITY AND FOR OUR
COUNTRY AMERICA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT NEXT WE OF
TIA OR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT HERE OR HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY THANK YOU TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
IN CREATIVITY AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. CAN JOHN
KANNAKI PARCHMENT PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM AFTER THE LAST CHANCE
DR GRANT DELIVERY. LIKE YOU
WANT TO THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
OUR MEMBERS FOR THE COMIC IF
YOU HAD MADE THE TYPICALLY OVER
THE LAST FEW WEEKS. HAVE REALLY
SPOKEN TO THE FELLOW IN THE
HEART OF OUR MEMBERSHIP ON THE
FRONT MIGHT I JUST WANTED TO
GIVE A SPECIAL THANKS FOR THAT.
I WANT TO SPEND MOST OF MY TIME
TODAY JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A TO SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS AT FTA
YOU REPRESENT ON THE FRONT
LINES. AT THE PANDEMIC TODAY-
AND ALSO TO TALK ABOUT THE
IMPACT IT HAD ON THEM ON THE
CLIENTS THEY SERVE BUT I ALSO
WANT TO SPEND SOME TIME TALKING
ABOUT THE RECOVERY THAT WE
ENVISION. REALLY ENCOURAGING AT
THE OP. A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
TACK BEFORE. AND UTILIZED THE
LEFT. LEARNED THE PAST. I'M
STARTING A LITTLE BIT WITHOUT
WORK UP. I WON'T TRY I WILL BE.
TO A LOT OF THE- THAT YOU HEARD.
OR BUT- WE HAVE HEARD THAT OVER
FOR ME. K. ARE UNEMPLOYED RIGHT
NOW. AND THE CRISIS THAT THAT
IT HAD ON. MOST VULNERABLE IT.
COME OUT OF. WE SEE AN INCREASE.
NOT ONLY IN OUR LOCAL. DIRECTOR
CAL FRESH. CAL WORK. MEDI CAL
IN GENERAL ASSISTANCE WE'VE
ALSO SEEN A HUGE INFLUX. AND R.
ET DE OFFICE WHERE. OUR STATE
WORKERS HAVE STOOD ON THE FRONT
NINE. ELEVEN AFTER THAT TO THE-
WORKING. AND THE COMMON.
INTERESTS RIGHT. THE MANNER. IN
A RECESSION BE KICKING.
INCREASE AND THE MAN OF OUR
STATE. SERVICES AND- I THINK MR
MEGA ALLUDED TO THIS. MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT. OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT PREPARED
FOR THE INFLUX AND-
UNFORTUNATELY OFTENTIMES BACKED
BY CHOICE. AND HOPEFULLY IN THE
CRISIS WE MAKE DIFFERENT
CHOICES THIS TIME. PROJECT LOOP
KEY I THINK OF AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW. WE CAN BE CREATIVE AND YOU
CAN OPERATE THE STATE. DELTA
MOST VULNERABLE. WE ALSO NEED
TO INVEST IN OUR ELIGIBILITY
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. WE'VE
BEEN VERY CREATIVE OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS TO DO
THAT. BUT AGAIN AS OUR PARTNERS
IN THE WELFARE DIRECTORS MAKE.
IT BACK WORK THAT HAS TO BE
DONE AND INVESTMENT THAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO ATTRACT THAT
BACKLOG. WE HOPE THERE'S SOME
ATTENTION THE TORONTO. AT
DECISIONS ARE MADE IN THE NEAR.
FUTURE I THINK IF THE MAC ALSO
ALLUDED TO THE NEXT. AND TO THE
IMPACT WE PROTECT. CAN AN OUR
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES ADULT
BUT- SERVICES UNIT. WE
REPRESENT THE SOCIAL. USED THE
FOR LINES THERE. YOU CAN AND
TOTALLY COMMITTEE TO GETTING
THE JOB DONE. BUT THERE IS
GOING TO NEED TO BE ADDITION
INVEST IN A TENT THERE. AGAIN
THAT. THAN THAT. THAT WE'RE
SEEING BALK AT THE CRACKED
RIGHT. NOT TO OUR OWN THOUGHT
BUT JUST AS- A RESULT OF THAT.
IN THE SECOND. THE SOCIAL TO
COMPLETE THE THING. IT IS GONNA
WRECK. ADDITIONAL IN. ALSO
HEARD THE MENTION OF OUR FRONT.
I IF THAT'S WHAT. REMEMBERING
THAT WERE THE- WORKERS TO GO
OUT A THE FRONT. WITH THIS.
SOCIAL GIFTED TO POLICY WHAT
COULD. THEY REPRESENT A- BONE A
POPULATION OF. THAT ARE.
LARGELY SIXTY. AND PLUS. THEY
INCREASE THE FOR THE- WITH A
THEY PROVIDE. FOR THE CLIENT TO
BE. THAT THEY- SOMETIMES NOT IN
WITH THE THEIR ORIGINAL A- THAT
WE HAVE TO DRAW. A SPECIALIST
IN THERE. AT WE PROTECT THOSE
MOST WANTED CLIENTS THAT WE
HAVE. AND WE ALSO TO BE MINE.
AND I THAT THE BARGAINING. THAT
OF OUR REACH. OUT WE HAVE TO
HAVE ENHANCE OVERSIGHT
ESPECIALLY. BUDGET TIME. THEY
ARE. OFTEN KIND OF PRIVATE
RANDALL. I HOPE SHE- STATE
OVERSIGHT AND I KNOW. THAT
BUDGET SUB ONE COMMITTEE BEEN
SPECIFICALLY INJURED. IN TO
ENHANCE THAT OVERSIGHT. ALL.
ONE THAT I DO WANT TO MAKE THAT
I HAVEN'T. ACT CRIED. NINETEEN
THE COLOR BLACK AND BROWN THE
EQUATE AND I'M- FOLKS I'M MORE.
I THINK IT'S EXPO AND WE SEE
THE GREAT EX. OTHER OUT ANY
CA. THAT OUR SYSTEM. AND IF
THEY'RE REALLY EXPOSED OF THE
IN. ARE AT THE STRUCTURES HAVE
IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
DISMANTLE THAT UNFAIR STRUCTURE
IN WILL REPEAL AND YOU AND I
THINK WITH THE THAT IN. THAT
NOT JOHN ATTENTION THAT OVER
THE YEARS. I THINK OVER MISTER
CHAIR OUR MEMBERS HERE THAT
THERE COULD A WEEK OF TO THE
AND EIGHT. WE'VE SEEN A BUDGET
THAT WAS BALANCE ON THE BACK OF
MOST ON. AND BALANCE ON THE
BACKS OF WHO LOOK THE- ARE
ABOUT THE NUMBER. A OF WEEKS
AGO WE CAN'T CALL OUR FRONTLINE
WORKER ESSENTIAL HEROES TODAY
AND THEN. THE BUDGET ON BACKS.
AND TO LET YOU GO LOOK INTO
THAT THERE DIFFICULT DECISION
MAKING. TO PLAN WE WOULD GET.
YOU ARE CAN MAKE CHOICES ARE
GET THAN CUTTING THE NEED TO
THE SERVICE THAT THE WORK. THAT
HAVE TO PUT THE MOST WILL OUT
THERE WE'VE LEARNED COCKED. TO
OUR CHOICE. AND UNFORTUNATELY
WE .COM KIND OF RIGHT. TODAY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ACTUALLY
THE CAR ON THE JOB I THE
DIRECTOR. TO CREATE. WE HAVE
WHAT'S UP THE BY THE IN IT OKAY
HAVE TO BE VERY CREE AND THAT.
TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T ASK FOR
HELLO CAN BE QUITE A- ADVOCATE
AND HELP. AND. LIVE IT BUT HAVE
A LIMIT AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE
COULD BE COME BACK BILL AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. AND WE ALSO KNOW
AND WERE FULLY COMMITTED TO THE
REVENUE OPTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
EXPLORE. WE HAVE TO MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WILL BE
INSTRUMENTAL AT THAT TO GET YOU
CALIFORNIA WITH THEIR SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS TO DO
THAT. WE WANT TO CONSIDER ALL
OPTIONS BIG AND SMALL. BEFORE
WE CAN FEDERAL BUDGET THAT HURT
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO SHOULDERS
WE CANNOT TODAY. AND WHO
SERVICES WE WANT TO DELIVER TO
THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
SOCIETY. AND MEDICARE AND ALL
THE FOLKS HERE TODAY WE LOOK TO
PARTNER WITH YOU AGAIN CAN'T
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR INCLUDING
FRONTLINE WORKERS IN THE
CONVERSATION. WE KNOW THAT WILL
HAVE TO GET OUT OF THIS
TOGETHER AND. HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE TOGETHER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I
NOW WANT TO TURN TO THE MEMBERS
AND SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL AND
WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
DIRECT THE QUESTIONS TO A
SPECIFIC PANELISTS AND FOR THE
PANELISTS PLEASE ON MUTE
YOURSELVES WHEN YOUR NAME IS
CALLED AND RENEW YOURSELF WHEN
YOU'RE CONCLUDED. LOOKING FOR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS. THANK.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THIS
QUESTION IS GEARED TOWARDS-
FRANK MECCA. AND BASED ON THE
UNDER THE GUARDIANSHIP IN
FOSTER CARE NOW YOU'RE IN YOUR
PRESENTATION YOU TALKED ABOUT
HOW THE COURTS NOW AREN'T
GRANTING GUARDIANSHIP ARE
REUNITING THE FAMILIES DURING
THIS TIME AND WE KNOW THAT'S OF
A VITAL STEP IN REUNITING-
FOSTER CARE- CHILDREN WITH WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. AND YOU ALSO
MENTIONED THAT. AS THIS ERA
MOVES FORWARD AND THE FOCUS IS
GOING TO BE GIVEN ON COVERT
NINETEEN ISSUES. THAT
BASICALLY- WE DON'T. START TO
TAKE AWAY FROM THOSE SERVICES
THAT ARE THERE THAT ARE
PROTECTING- SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND IN FOSTER CARE
IN MOVIE IN THOSE AREAS
CONTINUALLY TO MOVE THOSE
FORWARD SO HOW WOULD WE- BE
MORE EQUIPPED TO ADVOCATE ON
THOSE POSITIONS. YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR QUESTION. NUMBER
MEANT- THAT DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
TARGETED THE COUNTY THEN THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL I HAVE BEEN
WORKING. TO TRY TO ADDRESS ARE
YOU GET HIGH PRIORITY IMPORTANT
JUDICIAL ORDERS NAY. WHEN
COURTS OF CLOTHES- THEIR
PHANTOM PAST PRACTICE WITHOUT
THEIR REGARDING- REMOTE REMOTE
COURT- UP PROPERTY. THE CHIEF
CHAPTER OF THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF
THE SUPREME COURT HAD ISSUED-
AN EMERGENCY RULE OF COURT
ASKING COURTS TO PRIORITIZE-
SOMEBODY SHE IF THEY CAN FOR
LIKE A GUARDIANSHIP FOR A
REUNIFICATION. I'M IT ARE
EXPERIENCE THAT I'M IN SOME
AREAS NO THE COURTS ARE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
TECHNOLOGY- AND IN AND SORT OF
KEEP THE KEEP THE WORKLOAD
MOVING THROUGH THE COURT AND IN
OTHER PLACES. ON ANY BLACKING
SO- WE HAVE A LETTER TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WITH SOME
RECOMMENDATION- OPT FOR.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND RULED
CLARIFICATION- THAT WE THINK
WOULD BE HELPFUL AND I'M HAPPY
TO SHARE THAT LETTER- WITH THE
COMMITTEE. OF MORE BROAD
SPEAKING LAST ABOUT HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE THAT WE
MAINTAIN- CHILD PROTECTION IN
FOSTER CARE IMPORTANT SERVICES
FOR ABUSED AND NEGLECTED KIDS
AND FAMILY I THINK THE BIGGEST
RISK- IN THE NEAR TERM THE
PROGRAM IS THE FUNDING FOR. THE
LION'S SHARE OF THE NON FEDERAL
MONEY THAT WE USE TO DELIVER
THOSE SERVICES. ON IT IS
PROVIDED THROUGH COUNTY
REALIGNED AND THERE WERE THERE
WERE TWO WHEEL ALIGNMENT. OUR
LEGISLATION ONE IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE AND ONE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. THAT FIRST PARTIALLY
AND THEN ALMOST FULLY GAVE THE
COUNTY TOTAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
FUNDING THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
THE COST OF THE PROGRAM. ON IN
EXCHANGE FOR A SHARE OF THE
STATE THE HELP THAT. I'M BUILD
LIKE THOSE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION DIDN'T CONTEMPLATE-
NOR THEY BUILT TO. CANDIDATE
REALLY DRAMATIC DOWNWARDS SPIKE
IN REVENUE THEN I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO BE TESTED- SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN CORE SERVICES
TO KEEP KIDS SAFE- AND TO AND
TO PROMOTE THEIR HEALING- AND I
DON'T SEE ANY WAY THAT HAPPENS
WITHOUT THE STATE IN THE COUNTY
WORKING TOGETHER. TO TRY TO
FIND SOME WAY TO BRING RIPPING
YOU INTO BUT TRIP BUT WE
ALIGNMENT REVENUES SHOULD THEY
SHOULD THEY DECLINE IN THE
MANNER THAT PEOPLE FEAR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT AND-
WITH- YOUR PRESENTATION YOU
TALKED ABOUT HOW SCHOOLS- ARE
IN SESSION AND THEN FOR A LOT
FOR A LOT OF CASES THAT'S THE
FRONT LINE OF REPORTING- CHILD
ABUSE ONCE WE START TO MOVE
FORWARD AND OPEN UP THE SCHOOLS
AGAIN. DO YOU ANTICIPATE A
HIGHER RATE OF REPORTING OF
CHILD ABUSE ONE SCHOOLS OPEN UP
AGAIN. CERTAINLY DO ASSEMBLYMAN
YET. THANK YOU FOR THAT- THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST ONE OTHER
COMMENT TO- IT WAS TALKED ABOUT.
THE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND MOST
VULNERABLE THAT WERE OUT THERE
BUT AGAIN- LET ME MENTION
ANOTHER MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND THAT'S THE NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION THAT SEEMS
TO GET LOST. WHEN WE START TO
TALK ABOUT THOSE ISSUES THAT
ARE AFFECTING ALL OF US IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMOS. YOU KNOW
I WANT TO START MY QUESTIONS-
WE HAD INITIALLY POSED THIRTY
EIGHT QUESTIONS TO THIS PANEL
AND SO I WILL HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS BUT REALLY WANTED TO
THE GROUND MYSELF AND FRAME
THIS IF I COULD IN WHAT FRANK
MAC- STARTED AND SAID. WHICH S
THAT THE SAFETY NET EXISTS FOR
TIMES LIKE THIS RIGHT NOW. AND
AS WE HEARD FROM THE CAL WORKS
RECIPIENT WE HEARD OF HOW
ESSENTIAL THAT AID IS AND WHAT
IS. BOTH TO HIM AND HIS FAMILY
WE HEARD ABOUT. THE IMPORTANCE
IT PLAYED IN ALLOWING HIM TO
HAVE HOPE IN DARK TIMES WHEN HE
WAS STRUGGLING. AND I LOOK
TOWARDS THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
SO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHO ARE LOOKING TOWARDS THESE.
PROGRAMS IN THIS MOMENT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TRY TO
DISMANTLE A BIT OF OUR CURRENT
STRUCTURE WHICH HAS HAD INCOME
INEQUALITY AND RACIAL
DISPARITIES. AND INSTEAD FIGURE
OUT IF THERE IS A BETTER PATH
FORWARD. I THOUGHT THAT TIA OR
SAID IT QUITE WELL THAT WE
DON'T TALK ENOUGH OFTENTIMES
ABOUT THE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
WHICH ARE AFFECTED AND- THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING IN MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS. BUT I DID WANT
TO TURN MY COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS IF I COULD TO THE
THREE DIRECTORS. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO START WITH DIRECTOR JOHNSON
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WERE
NOT FOLLOWING IT I BELIEVE THE
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
PANDEMIC EBT FOR FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCHES AS WELL AS- AB
T. WHICH WILL ALLOW DELIVERED
AND- ONLINE SERVICES. WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY HELP US TO MEET
TO FOOD INSECURITY AND NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE MOMENT. BUT
WANTED TO TALK IF I COULD
DIRECTOR JOHNSON ABOUT SOME OF
THE FLEXIBILITY SO THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE AND DATES AND-
SOME OF THEM. COULD BE ENDING
AS SOON AS JUNE AND JUST TO USE
THE EXAMPLE THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED SWEET TALK ABOUT TIME
CLOCKS. I THINK IT'S AWFULLY
DIFFICULT WITH TIME CLOCKS TO.
WONDER WHETHER OR NOT JUNE IS
THE RIGHT STATE AND SO I'M
WONDERING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION IF THERE'S A
WILLINGNESS TO LOOK TOWARDS. A
HOLD HARMLESS A VERSION THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE TIME CLOCKS WERE
INTENT DID. TO HELP TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO PEOPLE IN REAL
TIME. ONE OF YOUR COMMENTS ON
THAT DIRECTOR JOHNSON. THANK
YOU AT CHAIR- YES THEN YOU MAY
THINKTHAT. YOU'RE USING IT
OUTLINES IT GREAT POINTS AROUND
AGAIN- HOW WE ALL INTRODUCED
SPACE- WHAT WHERE THAT I DIDN'T
FIND FLEXIBILITY THAN THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. BASED ON
WHAT WE KNEW ABOUT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AT THE TIME- I
THINK ACROSS THE BOARD ATTY
CERTAINLY COULD SOME OF THE
FEDERAL FLEXIBILITY THERE ARE
KIND CONSTRAINTS AND IN TERMS
OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN APPROVED FOR
WAIVERS. AT THAT WILL BE
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEEDED
TO DO AS WELL AS WHAT WE AT
REVIEW IN TERMS OF THE STATE
FLEXIBILITY THAT YOU'VE
LOOKING AT THESE COMPONENT AS
WE SPEAK THAT TIME CLOCK
FLEXIBILITY THAT YOU REFERENCED
AT ARE SET TO EXPIRE JUNE
THIRTY AS ARE MANY OF THE
POLICY CHANGES THAT WE'VE MADE
I'M PROGRAMS. THAT WE ARE IN
REAL TIME HAVE WEAK REVIEWING
AND THINKING THROUGH AGAIN- IN
LIGHT OF WHAT WE NOW KNOW ABOUT
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
THE DURATION OF IT OUT WHERE WE
WILL HAVE. ADDITIONAL POINTS AT
EVERY EVERY MADE A WHOLE ORDER.
IN HAND HOW WE WILL PROCEED SO
BLACK ALL I CAN TELL YOU AT
THIS POINT IS ABSOLUTELY PART
OF OUR- PROSPECT THE IN REVIEW
OF HOW WE MOVE FORWARD IN WHERE
ACT I WOULD BE. AT I CAN YOU
PUT AND I WILL GIVE A- EXAMPLE
IT AND THAT. I THINK WE DIED. A
WORKING ON THE ACT. CAPABILITY
EFFICIENT THE GET WE'RE LOOK AT
TODAY. I KIND OF AS WELL TO IF
THE DARKISH FEEDBACK CAN BE. A
MORE PERMANENT IN ANY COMPONENT
OF THESE PROGRAMS SO AND JUST
WANT TO KNOWLEDGE THAT YES WE
ARE LOOKING AT AT WHAT WE HAVE
DONE- IN THE TREMENDOUS LECTIN
CHANGES THAT WE'VE MADE IN THE-
LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS AND WHAT
POTENTIALLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THEN THE FACT
THAT YOU CAN TAKE. YEAH I JUST
SOMEWHERE INSIDE OF ME I
BELIEVE THAT. TIME CLOCKS
REALLY DON'T ALLOW THIS PROGAM
TO BE EFFECTIVE DURING THIS
UNEMPLOYMENT CRISIS AND OUR
ECONOMIC RECESSION AND- WOULD
WANT TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
YOU TO FIGURE OUT THE LENGTH OF
A NEED TO HOLD HARMLESS. I DID
WANNA TALK IF I COULD NOW ABOUT
EMERGENCY FOOD AND TO KNOW THAT
THEIR- AND THEY YOU HAD
MENTIONED THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS HAD GONE UP TO THE
MAXIMUM. BUT WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT IMMEDIATE NEED FOR OUR
FOOD BANKS I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT THE ORIGINAL
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND MONEY. FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY BEEN OUT AND
DISTRIBUTED BUT THAT THERE WILL
BE ANOTHER ALLOCATION NEEDED IN
THE MIDDLE OF MAY AND FOUR JUNE
IN THE AMOUNTS OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS PER MONTH. AND
I'M WONDERING IF THERE IS A
WILLINGNESS OR ABILITY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REALLY LOOK
TOWARDS OUR FOOD BANKS TO HELP
US TO DISTRIBUTE- IN THIS TIME
OF CRISIS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CHAIR YEAH I THINK
THAT THE- NEED AT LEAST SEEN
AND THE LADY AT. THE
DISTRIBUTION IMPLEMENTATION OF
FOOD WHAT WE'VE LEARNED A
PROPHECY BANKS- IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CONTINUE TO TRACK VERY
CLOSELY. IDENTIFYING ANY ADMIT
NEEDS AND WHAT BOTH IN TERMS OF
WHAT WILL BE COMING- IN THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE THAT WILL
BE COMING IN JULY IN WHERE
THEY'RE POTENTIALLY ARE ANY
GAPS- IN BETWEEN THAT PORTION
BUT WE ARE TO BE SEEN AS- A
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT-
BEFORE THE FINAL WE NEEDING
RESPECTED FISCAL YEAR. AND I
WILL BE CONSIDERING THAT. I DO
WANT A NEW MOVE ON NOW IF I CAN
TO DIRECTOR BARGE MEN. AND
WANTED TO GET A SENSE IF I
COULD FROM YOU DIRECTOR.
REGARDING HOW THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE FARING AND REALLY
WHAT THEIR TOP CONCERNS ARE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU DOCTOR
RANDALL- IN AND PART OF THE
CONCERN THAT THEY REYES OPENERS
HAD SCARED I TALKED A LITTLE%
BIT ABOUT THAT THAT HAD TO DO
WITH THE ABILITY TO QUICKLY
NAVIGATE AND HAD THAT TO.
FOURTEEN FAMILIES IN A
DIFFERENT WAY AND SO MOVING-
AWAY FROM FACE TO FACE VISIT
THING GOING TO THE TELLER
FURTHER- AND THEN BEING ABLE TO
ADD A RAMP UP THEIR TECHNOLOGY
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THAT. WE'VE
ALSO HEARD THAT WE DON'T
CENTERS HAVE- HAD CONCERNS ON
HOW DID THEY MOVE FORWARD WITH
ELIGIBILITY YOU KNOW WHEN THEY
ARE NOT ABLE TO. THE OTHER
PERSON OR TO ACCEPT AN
INDIVIDUAL- FACE TO FACE AND-
BE RESPONSIVE TO ELIGIBILITY
BETWEEN EARLY START TO-
LETTERMAN SERVICES. AND BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT TRANSITION- TO
EDUCATION- ANOTHER ELEMENT OF
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THOSE THAT
ARE JUST ENTERING OUR SYSTEM
AND SOME OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING- IS THAT WERE HAVING
AN ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS RIGHT
NOW WITH- CDP. ENTAIL HOW TO
HAVE THAT TRANSITION FROM EARLY
START TO EDUCATION FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. THAT WOULD NOT BE
DETERMINED ELIGIBLE FOR
ONGOING. SERVICE THE- BUT
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF.
INTERVENTION SUPPORT YOUR
EDUCATION SO THAT. THAT
EXPRESSED THAT THEY CAN BATES
SHARED BURNS AS TO HOW TO THE
POOL PROVIDE. AND WHAT AT
THINGS DIFFERENT BUT LIKE I HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER THERE'S
REALLY BEEN A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY TO.
TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES- AND MAKING SRE
THAT THEY HADTHE FLEXIBILITY
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT-
NONRESIDENTIAL PROVIDERS TO
DELIVER SERVICES IN A DIFFERENT
WAY- THE OTHER IS TO HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO SUPPORT FAMILIES-
BECAUSE THEY THEY HAD SHARED
CONCERNS ABOUT- PARTICULARLY
FAMILY THAT ARE SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGHLY
COMPLEX. NEEDS THANK SURE THAT
THE THEY CAN GET SERVER AND
SUPPORT WE HAVE BIRD- FROM
RESULT CENTERS THAT THEIR THEIR
QUESTIONABLE WHAT'S NEXT AS FAR
AS- HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
CONGREGATE STUDYING AND I KNOW
OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE ALSO
ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS- AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE NEXT. COMING
WEEKS THAT WE HAVE A SMALL
GROUP AS TO THOSE NEXT STEPS
FOR RE ENTRY YOU KNOW HOW DO WE
YOU KNOW TAKE A LOOK TO
BASICALLY- HAS INDIVIDUALS
ACCESS THEM OF SERVICES THAT
THEY HAD BEFORE COVERED
NINETEEN- AND THAT'S BEEN AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION THAT WE
DON'T CENTERS HAVE ASKED US-
AND THEY ARE THEY'RE LOOKING
INTO AND- REMAIN ENGAGED- WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT. AND THEN WITH-
PROVIDER ASSOCIATION AND OTHERS
TO- TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THOSE NEXT STEPS- WE HOPE THAT
ARE LIKE I SAID HAS HAD PIVOTED
TO THAT DIFFERENT TYPES OF
SERVICE SOMEONE OF THAT. ALONG
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY SIDE OF IT
IS MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE
BEING RESPONSIVE TO A CALL THAT
FAMILIES ARE MADE INTO THEM AND
WILDLIFE I SAID NO OF THEM HAVE
FOUND WORK OUT BEEN BEEN ABLE
TO. THAT SOME OF THE OTHERS ARE
LOOKING TO. THERE THE RESULT
BANNERS. THE PRACTICES THAT HAD
BEEN AFFECT AND SURE THOSE
BARRIERS ARE A DRAFT. I AM A TO
UP ONE TIME PERMITS IN THE-
MECHANISM SO MUCH TELL HAS
ALLOWED YOU TO ACCESS AS I DO
THINK THERE ARE A FEW WAYS IN
WHICH WE MAY RISE OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC STRONGER THAN WE WENT
INTO THIS AND- MANY OF OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
APPRECIATING THE OPPORTUNITY
WHILE RECOGNIZING THEIR NOT A
DIRECT REPLACEMENT. WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO NOT FORGET
WORKING YOU WITH THAT THANK
YOU. WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO- DIRECTOR MCCAULEY WEIGHT
AND I THINK THIS MAY BE THE
FIRST TIME I'VE HEARD FROM YOU-
GOLDEN STATE FOR GOLDEN YEARS
AND DIDN'T LIKE THAT QUITE A
BIT- AS WELL AS- THIS IDEA THAT
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THE WHOLE
PERSON THE WHOLE. FAMILY I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TO RIGHT NOW IS WE'RE LOOKING
AT PUBLIC HEALTH TO RECOGNIZE
THAT WE ARE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. AND THAT WE ARE
STRONGER WHEN WE ARE A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AND THAT IT
REALLY DOES HELP US TO HAVE A
STRONG- AGING OR ELDERLY
POPULATION. AND WOULD REALLY
WANT TO DATE AGAIN BECAUSE I
WAS. REALLY CONCERNED WHEN
LOOKING AT THE LESSONS FROM THE
LAST RECESSION AND THE CUTS
THAT CAME TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND THAT I
REALLY WAS HOPING THAT YOU
COULD SPEAK TO. THE LESSONS
LEARNED DIRECTOR MCCOY WHAT AID
FROM THE LAST RECESSION WE WENT
THROUGH. THANK YOU FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND I AND I BELIEVE
I HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT WHERE
CREDITS DUE THAT I BELIEVE ARE
GOVERNOR. GOLDEN STATE FOR THE
GOLDEN YEARS SO- WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T DO THAT. YES
THERE ARE A LOT OF LESSONS
LEARNED AND IN MANY WAYS- THEY
ECHO WHAT DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND-
FRANK MAC I HAVE SAID- SO
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT CHILDREN YOU
KNOW I MEAN OFTEN WHAT IS. TRUE
FOR. EIGHT YEAR OLDS IS ALSO
TRUE FOR EIGHT ZERO THEN WE
REALLY TRIED TO LOOK AT- THE
END OF THE LIFE CYCLE. AND THE-
WHERE THE NEEDS ARE FOR HELP.
OR HOUSING. FOR COMMUNITY HER
FAMILY FOR MENTAL HEALTH. ALL
THAT GOOD CHRISTIAN ALL THAT
GOES INTO THRIVING. I THINK. WE
BE LOOKING VERY CLOSELY- AT
THAT POINT PERSON IN A WHOLE
FAMILY APPROACH- WRECK IN I
THINK IN SOME WAYS THE CO GOOD
EXPERIENCE- IT'S BEEN A
TEACHER. EVEN HARSHER LESSONS
ABOUT WHEN PEOPLE LOVE THAT THE
COURT. CHANGER FALL AWAY THAT
THE RISK OF CASCADING
CONSEQUENCES- WHEN IT GETS
HARDER TO GET THAT MAIL IF YOU
LOSE THAT VOLUNTEER OPPORTUNITY
THAT SOME PORTENT FOR SOCIAL
CONNECTION- DOES THAT LEAD TO
MORE DECLINE. MORE HEALTHCARE
COSTS MORE CRISIS CARE
RESPONSE- THAT END UP BEING SO
COSTLY SO I THINK. YEAH WANT TO
LOOK AT THE WHOLE PERSON WELL
LOOK AT THE WHOLE FAMILY THE
WHOLE COMMUNITY AND REALLY THE
WHOLE CAR IF WE CAN- BE
DIFFICULT AND PAINFUL. CHOICES
AND I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO
LOOK AT AGAIN AS ALL OF THE
PALATABLE DRAFT IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER UNLESS YOU'VE GOT SO.
POWERFULLY WELL WE'RE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER WE'RE NOT ALL
EXPERIENCING THIS TOGETHER- AND
THERE ARE CUMULATIVE IN
PREVIOUS- DISCRIMINATION
INEQUITIES DISINVESTMENT THAT
OR- BEARING BEARING UP HERE- WE
SEE AGAIN IN THE- QUICKLY IN
THE DEATH RATE. AMONG OLDER
ADULTS PRICKLY MY AFRICAN
AMERICAN OLDER ADULTS AS WELL
AS PACIFIC ISLANDER- AND WHAT'S
YOU KNOW OLDER ADULTS- AND SO
WE DO NEED TO. ASK OURSELVES
WHY THAT'S HAPPENING AND AS WE
NAVIGATE THE UNCERTAIN AND
CHALLENGING HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
REALITY THE COMING MONTHS AND
YEARS- NOT BE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL- BE MINDFUL OF AGAIN THE
CUMULATIVE EFFECT OVER TIME OR-
OFFER MULTIPLE SERVICES. GEN
REALLY DO LEAD TO OUR DIFFERENT
OUTCOME AND HEALTH AND WELL
BEING AND THE LIFE ITSELF. I
WAS WONDERING DIRECTOR MCCOY
WAIT IF YOU COULD SPEAK ABOUT
THE FEDERAL STIMULUS PACKAGES
AND OUR SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY
THEM. AND HOW THEY HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED- I THINK THIS IS.
ONE OF THE BEST WAYS WE CAN
HAVE TO HELP TO BREAK CASE
ISOLATION IS TO HELP TO DELIVER
WARM MEALS VIA THIS PROGRAM. I
THINK IT'S-SINGLE AGAINST THAT
YOUR DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN ABLE
TO. INCREASE ABILITY TO
DISTRIBUTE DURING THIS CRISIS
AND JUST WANT TO HEAR MORE
DETAILS IF I COULD. THANK YOU
YES WE REALLY DO HAVE TO LIFT
UP THE STRONG FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL PARTNERSHIP THAT HAS THAT
HAS BEEN AFFECT HERE WITH THE
OLDER AMERICANS NUTRITION
PROGRAMS THE BEDROCK. OF
PROGRAM- WE'RE SO GRATEFUL-
THAT THANK YOU THE FAMILY FIRST
ACT DID PROVIDE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS TO CALIFORNIA FOR- WHAT
USED TO BE HOME AND COMMUNITY
MAIL BUT OF COURSE NOW THEY'RE
ALL. ALSO TWENTY FIVE MILLION
AND TVA RECEIVE THAT A
DISTRIBUTED THAT. IN RECORD
TIME I BELIEVE UNDER THREE
WEEKS. OUT TO OUR COUNTY AND
NONPROFIT AGING AGENCIES WHO
HAVE THE FUN AND ARE USING THEM
TO FIT BOTH NEW NUMBERS MAKE
THOSE NEW NEEDS- BOTH PEOPLE
WHO NOW NEED MORE MALE- AND
PEOPLE WHO USED TO BE A
COMMUNITY AND FOR NOW HOME- AND
NEW PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T
NEED THE- HELP WITH MEAL
BEFORE. SO WHERE WERE VERY-
PROUD OF THOSE NUMBERS EXPECT
THOSE NUMBERS TO CONTINUE TO
GROW WE ARE- AWAITING ANY
MOMENT AND I'M I'M HOPING I
CHEN. THING IS THAT IT WILL
ARRIVE FOR ONE THING IT YEAH
NEXT BACK IN CALIFORNIA- THE
CARE THAT. SEVEN AN OLDER MALE
THE COP HELLO. SIGNIFICANT BUT
BEGAN. ALSO OKAY HAVE KIND OF
THE NEUTRAL NAME A THE COURT OF
SERVICES THAT IT MAY REALLY ARE
LIKE. FOR THAT THEY ARE
EVERYTHING BUT HEALTH AND
ENGAGE. Q. LEGAL. TO DIGITAL
DIVIDE TWO OF PHYSICAL ACTIVITY
A WHOLE RANGE OF SERVICES THAT
ARE COUNTY AND WHAT NONPROFIT
PARTNERS OF THE LIVE RING IN
NEW AND CREATIVE WAYS I
MENTIONED THE FRIENDSHIP LINE.
SO MUCH MORE IT'S HAPPENING.
YOU AYE SURE THAT- THE OLDER
PEOPLE ARE AT HOME AND AT HOME
UNDER ANY DO IT DIFFERENT WAYS
WE SPOKE. WITH WELL BEING. AND
IT ALSO SUPPORT FOR CAREGIVERS.
AGAIN THE LARGEST PORTION CARE
GIVING IN THE STAKEHOLDER.
CALIFORNIA IS. AND THE AND PAN
IN THE BROADEST SENSE OF FAMILY
OF CHOICES THE FAMILY WE DEFINE.
AS TO HOW THE FOR ALL THE WOULD
BE YOUR DURING I PARENTS. ALL
O. OUR CHILDREN. OF OUR CARING
FOR TO WE'VE GOT TO KNOW ARE
THAT FAMILY AND FRIEND THEY'RE
GIVING A HUGE. AND THEN AGAIN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCESFOR- THE
ALL BUT THEN PROGRAM WHICH IS
REALLY HELPED AMPLIFY THE
VOICES OF RESIDENTS IN LONG
TERM FACILITIES- ALL ACROSS THE
STATE LONG TERM CARE- BUT
THEY'RE MAKING CALLS- TO READ.
THEY CAN ALONG WHEN THE
FACILITY CURRENTLY BETTER
CALLING AND CHECKING IN THE
FAMILY CRAP. YEAH ARE TRYING TO
DO. WE CAN DO I'M GROUP THAT.
THE OF COURSE MAY A PART LINE
ON TO COMPLY OF ABUSE AND
NEGLECT FACILITY SO THAT
FEDERAL THE TO BE FOR MILLION
THIS ANYTHING NOW TO. AND AGAIN
TO SEE AND THEY GO WE WILL. TO
GET THAT OUT TO OUR COUNTY A
NONPROFIT AGING PARTNERS. AND I
PROBABLY WILL AND WITH JUST A
STATEMENT DIRECTOR MCCOY
WEIGHED BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WHO. ARE QUITE INTERESTED IN
THE AREAS OF OUR STATES THAT
ARE BOTH TECHNOLOGICAL AND
INTERNET DESERT AND WOULD JUST.
CONTINUE TO IMPLORE US TO COME
UP WITH SOLUTIONS FOR THAT AS
IT HELPS. MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO ACCESS SERVICES.
I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
FRANK MAC- IF I COULD AND ASK
HIS PERSPECTIVE ON OUR- AS THE
LEGISLATURE BOTH CODIFYING AND
OR EXTENDING WHAT HAS BEEN DONE
WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
OR AT THE- APARTMENT. GUIDE
REALLY WHAT I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT FROM YOU FRANK IS
WHAT EFFECT THIS WOULD HAVE ON
COUNTIES. YOU MISTER CHAIR
FRANK MECCA WOULD CLEARLY BE A
I THINK I THINK THAT AN ABRUPT
TERMINATION OF FOR EXAMPLE THE
MORATORIUM ON- TERMINATION. IT
CERTAINLY CREATE A BUBBLE
EFFECT SO THAT AT THE SAME TIME
YOU MIGHT HAVE. QUITE A FEW
PEOPLE WHO ARE APPLYING FOR AID
OR WHO ARE NEEDING CARE
WHATEVER THEIR- CAKE
MAINTENANCE BAD WEATHER AT THE
NORMAL RENEWAL. BUT THEN YOU
HAVE THE BACKLOG OF WORK- FOR.
WORKLOAD THAT YOU UST BURKE-
IT GENTLY CREATE THE WILL OF
WORKLOAD BURDEN FOR THE COUNTY-
ULTIMATELY THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
THAT THE CLIENTS AND SO IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT IF YOU HAVE THE
TIME- DID YOU BOTH SOMETHING
DOESN'T GET DONE. BUT ALSO FOR
THE CLIENT JUST GENERALLY
SPEAKING. YEAH YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT. HE TO BE A YOU KNOW OUR
VALUE IS AND IF THEY CAN'T
ECONOMIC BUT IT CERTAINLY
SEEMS. LIKE AN EVENING OUT OF
SOME OF THOSE PROVISIONS IN
EXTEND PAST JUNE COULD BE
HELPFUL. FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE-
ADD COUNTY EMERGE FROM ALMOST
COMPLETE REMOTE. ACCESS AND TRY
TO PROP THAT THE VOLUME OF THE
WORK FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE NEWLY
IN NEED OF OUR SERVICES. AND SO.
WE DON'T HAVE A RECOMMENDATION
TO SAY LOOK LET'S MAKE JUNE
SEPTEMBER BUT IT DOES SEEM THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT BOTH EXTENDING THE
PERIOD. AND ALSO EATING OUR WAY
OUT OF IT- UNDERSTANDING THAT
THEIR AUTOMATION IMPLICATIONS
AND YOU KNOW ALL SORTS OF OTHER
OTHER OPERATIONAL IMPLICATIONS
BUT IF THE CONVERSATION WE WANT
TO HAVE- WITH RESPECT TO TIME
LIMITS I THINK IT. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION YET ON THE
SPENDING TIME ON THAT BUT- I
CAN'T GET IT NOW FOR THE TRYING
TO ASK OURSELVES- GIVEN MAKES
THAT. THE COLLEGE FOR EXAMPLE
THE TWENTY FOUR MONTH TIME
LIMIT. IS A TIME LIMIT ON THE
NUMBER OF MONTHS IN YOUR LIFE
YOU CAN RECEIVE WELFARE TO WORK
SERVICES. SO FOR A CLIENT YOU
MAY HAVE EXT WHO WILL MAY HAVE
USED UP THEIR WELFARE TO WORK
SERVICES GOT A JOB- I DIDN'T
NEED IT ANYMORE- THE JOB
DOESN'T EXIST THE INDUSTRY IS
HAVING A HARD TIME COMING BACK.
AND NOW THE PERSON WOULD LIKE
TO BE RETRAINED FOR SOMETHING
ELSE. THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT
EXPIRED IN ON CAL WORKS. PART
TIME AND IT SAID WE CAN HELP
YOU. WITH THAT WOULD IMPLEMENT
SERVICE BUT WITH SOME LIMITED
EXCEPTION SO- I CAN NOW. IS THE
BEST TIME TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE UTILITY
OF DOES NOT PROMOTE JUST ON THE
FISCAL STANDPOINT BUT- DO THEY
WORK AS INTENDED DOES THE TIME
LIMIT ACTUALLY HAVE IT INTENDED
EFFECT WOULD BE INTENDED TO
FALL. ALL OF OUR EXPERIENCE. AT
THE LINE LEVEL WORKING WITH
CLIENTS. AND THE OPINION-
EXPERTS LIKE MATHEMATICA POLICY
RESEARCH WHO WE ARE WORKING
WITH TO MODERNIZE OUR WELFARE
TO WORK PROGRAM. A DAY HURT
MORE THAN THEY HELP AND WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN TAKE A DAMAGE- IN A
CLEAR CRAP THAT TECHNICAL
LANGUAGE BUT- UTILIZE THE
MOMENT TO REFLECT ON SOME OF
THE- POLICIES THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE. SOME OF WHICH IN PART AS
A RESPONSE TO THE GREAT
RECESSION AFTER CELL WHY DO WE
STILL HAVE WITH THE VALUE THAT
THEY HAD AND I THINK THAT ONE.
WE CERTAINLY COME DOWN ON THE
SIDE THAT WE OUGHT TO GET RID
OF IT AND WE WOULD HOPE THAT
THE LEGISLATUREAND THE
ADMINISTRATION. WHEN ENGAGED IN
THAT CONVERSATION. AND I WILL-
JUST BORROW AGAIN FROM THE
GOVERNOR HIS LANGUAGE REGARDING
A DIMMER. THERE MAY BE A NEED
FOR SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS TO.
BE ON THE BOOKS FOR A LONGER AS
WE WORK OUR WAY OUT OF THE
RECESSION. AND FOR OTHERS FOR
US TO CODIFY INTO PERMANENCE
BECAUSE- THEY ARE AN
IMPROVEMENT UPON THE WAY WE
CURRENTLY DO BUSINESS. WITH
THAT MY FINAL QUESTION WILL BE
FOR YOU- TIA OR- AND YOU
BRIEFLY TOUCHED ON IT BUT- I
THINK. I WOULD. APPRECIATE IF
YOU COULD. EXPAND A LITTLE BIT
ON THE LOW SINCE LEARNS FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE FOR THE LAST
RECESSION. AND WHAT WOULD YOU
WANT TO SAY THAT. DUE TO AVOID.
AND THIS ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YET HERE
OR FROM THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION I. WOULD
THINK YOU BACK OFF OF THE
COMMENTS THAT THAT MIGHT MAKE A
MENTION ANYBODY HAVE UNIQUELY
AND IN PARTNERSHIP COME UP WITH
SOME VERY CREATIVE WAYS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
ARE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION
SPACE. KINDER CAMP. AND THEY'RE
DONE JUST FOR A MOMENT IN TIME
AND SO I DETECT AGAIN TO WHAT
YOU JUST SAID I MISTER CHAIR
SOME OF THOSE THINGS THEY NEED
TO BE REVISITED ARE AFRAID THAT
IN SOME MADE MAY NEED TO BE
REVISITED FOR SOMETHING THAT WE
CONTINUE IN PERPETUITY. ABOUT
MORE SPECIFICALLY TO THE WORK
FORCE AND I WISH I HAD THE
NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME WE SEEN
IN TWO THOUSAND ANDEIGHT AND
BEYOND THE TOTAL DISMANTLING UP
OUR COUNTY FOR STRUCTURE WITH
THE MASSIVE CONTRACTING OUT OF
COUNTY SERVICES RIGHT AND
THOSE. ARE PUBLIC SECTOR MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS. IN COUNTY YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW IT CAN MATCH. I SHRIEK
ASH BUT AND THEN IT WHAT THEY
HAVE TO DO WITH WHAT THE
REALITY AT THE REST. OF THE
ALSO. HAVE DURING A- INCOME.
ECONOMY SO I WOULD I WOULD HARD
BE. PRESSED AND PUSHES. THINK
OF WAYS. THAT WE BUILD OUR IN.
TO TAKE CARE OF ARM ONE OF.
THAT WE DON'T YOU KNOW FOR
COUNTIES AND YOU. MASSIVELY AND
FORCED THIS. YOU KNOW KIND OF
NO NO WHEN DECISION WHERE YOU
HAVE TO CONTRACT OUT WORK TO.
AND ENVIRONMENTS THAT ARE NOT
ABLE TO PAY A LIVING WAGE. TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. THEIR
WORKERS A LIVING WAGE UNTIL
SOME OF THOSE- I THINK SOME OF
THOSE DYNAMICS AND MISTER CHAIR
UC. PHASE OUT THROUGH THE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT KIND OF
RECOVERY. AND WE'VE NEVER
RECOVERED SINCE THEN. OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE STILL ISN'T
BUILT IN A WAY THAT IT WAS
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
AND I THINK AGAIN. IT LENDS
ITSELF TO WHY WE'RE HAVING SUCH
A HARD TIME. BUILDING UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO RESPOND TO
THIS. THEY MAKE THAT WE HAVE.
ON RECOMMENDATIONS I WOULD JUST
GO BACK TO BE INCREASED ABOUT
REVENUE OPTION. OF NOT HAVING A
BUDGET THAT'S BASED ON
AUSTERITY BUT HAPPY ONE THAT'S
BASED ON. STRATEGY IN DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT WE CAN COME TOGETHER.
AND FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY TO
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY GROW OUR
SERVICE INDUSTRY AN INSURER
WERE CREATING GOOD JOBS AND
DELIVERING THE SERVICES THAT I
KNOW OUR MOST VULNERABLE. YOU
KNOW I'VE- SEEING NO FURTHER
PUBLIC- ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM%
THE COMMITTEE I DO WANT TO
JUST. TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK.
THIS PANEL FOR- IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND- WEIGHTY
DISCUSSION WE DO HAVE OUR
CHALLENGES SET BEFORE US. I
WOULD LIKE NOW TO IF I CAN FOR
US TO TURN TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
AS WE MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET
OF THIS HEARING WE WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR THIS PUBLIC COMMENT.
ARE CALLING NUMBER TODAY IF YOU
ARE WONDERING IS ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO. AGAIN
PLEASE ONLY TYPE IN ONE ZERO
ONCE RE ENTERING THOSE TWO
DIGITS WILL TAKE YOU OUT OF THE
QUEUE. SO PLEASE AVOID DOING
THAT. AT SOME POINT AN OPERATOR
WILL COME ON AND WE'LL
PRIVATELY ASK YOUR NAME FIRST
SO PLEASE BE PREPARED TO SPEAK
WITH THE OPERATOR AS THIS WILL
FACILITATE WHEN YOU ARE BEING
TAPPED TO SPEAK TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. I WOULD LIKE TO
ASK ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT. AT
THE MOMENT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TWENTY EIGHT PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
LINE. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE OUR
FIRST CALLER. IF YOU DO HAVE A
QUESTION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD YOU
MAY WITHDRAW YOUR QUESTION AT
ANYTIME BY REPEATING THE ONE
THEY WILL COMMAND. SB THE
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
YOUR HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING
THE NUMBER. AGAIN IF YOU DO
HAVE A QUESTION PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THERE ARE AT THIS TIME.
AND ONE MOMENT PERFECT QUESTION.
WE DO HAVE A FEW PEOPLE QUEUING
UP WAITING FOR OPERATORS.
THEN
AGAIN IF YOU DO HAVE A QUESTION
PLEASE PRESS AND ONE IN THEIR
RIGHT THIS TIME.
IN NAME
PREMIERE PARTICIPANT.
THANK YOU
HAVE A QUESTION IS FROM THE
LINE OF THE TORNADO COMMENTS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR MR DAMAGE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HERNANDEZ
GOMEZ YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
TO THE NUMBER GóMEZ CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. YES SIR. OKAY SORRY
ABOUT THAT OKAY. HI MY NAME IS
FOR NON THE GOMEZ I'M A CO
FOUNDER OF DISABILITY BUSH'S
UNITED AS WELL AS THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE WERE BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS TO COMMUNITY
OUTREACH AND PARENTS AND STUFF
ADVOCATES LED. IN YOUR OUR
SECOND PANEL. THE LAST
PARAGRAPH OUR LEAD SENT IN THE
FIRST PARAGRAPH IS. WHAT MORE
CAN THE STATE DUE TO RESPOND AS
THE PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYED A
CRISIS OF ECONOMIC RECESSION
CONTINUE. I WANTED TO ADD ONE
THE KEY THING IS SOMETHING THAT
THE STATE. IS ALREADY DOING AND
THAT IS SUPPORTING. THE EFFORT.
YOUR ADVOCATE ADDRESS
DISPARITIES WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
AS PARENTS WOULD BE WORKING
HAND IN HAND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT CAN DIRECT
DEPARTMENT SHE MENTIONED-
PRESENTATION HAS DONE AN
OUTSTANDING JOB AND WE JUST ASK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE I KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HARD TIMES IT COULD BE
A LOT OF CHANGES. BUT WE JUST
ASK YOU TO PLEASE CONTINUE TO
GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
OURSELVES SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE INTERPRET ALLOCATE
THIS DISPARITIES THANK YOU SO
MUCH AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME.
REALLY APPRECIATE. THANK YOU
SIR. NEXT QUESTION IS FROM THE
LINE OF THE NIGHT CAROLINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL THEY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. CHECK YOUR HEARING
TODAY I THINK IT'S TO COVER
MANY IMPORTANT TOPICS AND
THEMES FROM AND I GUESS I
WANTED TO START OT THERE'S A
BIKE JUST SAYING I KNOW THERE'S
AN OLD ADAGE IN THE LAW. WHICH
IS THAT- HARD CASES OFTEN
RESULT IN BAD LAW. AND I THINK
WE HAVE A SITUATION THAT WE
FACE IN THE GREAT RECESSION
WHERE GREAT RECESSION ENDED UP
TRANSFORMING OFTEN INTO BAD
POLICY. I THINK WE REALLY NEED
TO BE MINDFUL OF THAT AS WE GO
FORWARD IN THE- NEXT WEEKS AND
THEN MONTHS ABOUT THE DECISIONS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR MAKE ADMINISTRATIVE
AGENCIES MAKE. ABOUT HOW WE
RESPOND. BECAUSE THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE YOU KNOW WE MADE
THE DECISION THAT WE'RE GOING
TO STOP WELFARE TO WORK AND
HAVE FAMILY STAYING HOME FOR-
FOR A LENGTHY PERIOD OF TIME
WHILE THEY'RE FEDERAL TIME
CLOCKS RAN- BUT- YOU KNOW THAT
REALLY WELL. VERY THEY HAD A
SHORT TIME CLOCK FOR FEDERAL
PURPOSES AND THEN WE DID BRING
THEM BACK IN WE UNDERFUNDED
COUNTY THEY WERE UNDERSTAFFED
THEY WEREN'T PREPARED. TO
ENGAGE PEOPLE AND SO MANY TIMES
FAMILY SPENT WEEKS MONTHS OF
WAITING TO GET CHILDCARE OTHER
SERVICES DID NOT. HAVE THE TIME
CLOCK STOP THEM WHAT THEY GOT
LEGAL SERVICES INTERVENTION.
AND SO WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT
THE IMPACT I THINK YOU'RE GOING
TO BE AND I THINK THE WITNESS
THAT YOU HEARD FROM EARLIER
TODAY. WAS A GOOD REMINDER THAT
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN VERY BIG
CHALLENGES IN LIFE AND THAT THE
NOTION THAT WE CAN GET EVERYONE
AND CAL WORKS. THROUGH ALL PER
WORKING FORTY EIGHT MONTHS IS
JUST SIMPLY NOT TRUE PEOPLE ARE
IN DIFFERENT PLACES. NOW I
THINK. NOW WE'VE SEEN TWO MAJOR
RECESSIONS IN BARELY OVER A
DECADE WE NOW KNOW THAT.
PANDEMICS AND RECESSION DON'T
HAVE TIME ONE. BUT WE CONTINUE
TO PUT TIME LIMITS ON PEOPLE
FOR SNAP BENEFITS CAO WORK. FOR
SHORT TERM BENEFITS AT THE
CHURCH ACTORS PROVIDE SO WE
CERTAINLY ARE MAJOR. FOR OUT
TIME WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
IN TAKING A VERY IMPORTANT STEP
OF SUSPENDING THE COWARDS FORTY
EIGHT MONTH CLOCK. BUT WE
REALLY THINK THAT AS WE MOVE%
FORWARDWE NEED TO CAN WE NEED
TO KEEP UP SUSPENSION IN PLACE
UNTIL THE ECONOMY REALLY GETS
BACK ON ITS FEET. AND WE REALLY
HAVE TO EXTEND OUT THE TIME
LIMIT BACK TO THE FULL CADRE
LIMIT TWO TO SIXTY MONTHS. I'M
JUST A FEW OTHER VERY QUICK
COMMENTS FOR YOU WON'T TAKE TOO
LONG- WE THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
CENTURY MR MACULAR CAL GRANT
SIR ABSOLUTELY FOR EACH. I WAS
IN NO. OF ADDICTION COMING.
IT'S GOING TO BE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF INCOME THE
FAMILY. SOME POCKETS WITH THESE
WITH THESE. OBJECTION ORDERS
GET LIFTED- THIS COULD
LITERALLY IMPACT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. AND THAT
BRINGS ME TO AN ADDITIONAL
POINT WHICH IS THAT. ONE OF THE
OTHER ISSUES AND CAL WORKS THAT
WE REALLY THINK WE NEED TO
PRESERVE OUR THE HOUSING
PROGRAMS THE HOUSING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. THE HOUSE- TO PORT
PROGRAM FAMILY STABILIZATION
ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE GONNA
BE CRITICAL OVER THE NEXT FEW.
THAT'S FAMILY AFTERTASTE
BACKGROUNDS THEY HAVE TO THE
CASE OF FICTIONAL ORDERS
THERE'S GOING TO BE TREMENDOUS
PRESSURE ON FAMILY CAN'T
FRANKLY ON COUNTY. TO RESPOND
TO THAT- WHICH IS WHY WE THINK
THE ONGOING NATURE OF PERMANENT
SOME PERMANENT. PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY MISTER MICHAELS
AMENDMENT MADE CHEN OF IT. A
COUPLE OF TIMES ABOUT EXTENDING
OUT THE ORDERS ABOUT CUTTING
PEOPLE OFF OF ASSISTANCE TO
READ TO TERMINATION. AND CAR
SEVEN WE THINK THAT KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY NEEDS TO GET
EXTENDED INTO THE FUTURE- SO
THAT. COUNTY CAN REALLY FOCUS
ON HELPING OUR CLIENTS. BECAUSE
WE HAVE SO MANY NEW PEOPLE
COMING ON THE PROGRAM- AND THEN
LASTLY I WILL JUST WENT WITH
THIS THAT ONE THING THAT HAS
NOT COME UP TODAY WHICH I THINK
IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS. WE-HAVEN'T AT. I'M CALIFORNIANS
RIGHT NOW WHO ARE BEING
REQUIRED TO HAVE TO FILE. WITH
THE IRS TAX RETURN IN ORDER TO
GET THEIR CARES DOLLARS EACH
CHECK THESE BENEFITS ARE COMING
UP TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. FOR
EACH ADULT- THIS IS GOING TO BE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE DRAW
THIS MONEY DOWN THIS MONEY
COULD BE ESSENTIAL TO KEEPING
PEOPLE HOW. THIS MONEY CAN GO
INTO OUR ECONOMY RIGHT AWAY-
I'M HOPING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IN THE MINISTRATION WILL BE
COMING FOR PROPOSAL AT THE NAY
REVISED. TO REDUCE OUTREACH
LIKE WE DID WITH THE SSI-
CALPERS EXPANSION. TO REALLY IN
ALL PEOPLE SO I WOULD JUST
LEAVE YOU WITH THAT AS MY FINAL
COMMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU AND
OUR NEXT COMMENT IS FOUND ANNA
JOHNSON PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WE THANK YOU ALL
AND THE PANELISTS AND THE
GOVERNOR- FOR ALL OF THE
ACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN SO
FAR TO PROTECT. YOU AND THEN
AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE AGAIN
MY NAME IS ANNA JOHNSON WITH
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR ANY
ACTION THE COMMITTEE CAN TAKE
TO EXTEND THE PROTECTION FOR
YOU. WHO ARE IN AN AGING OUT OF
FOSTER CARE AND WHO ARE AT
HEIGHTENED RISK FOR-
HOMELESSNESS AND FOOD
INSTABILITY AND INSECURITY AS
FOLKS MENTIONED TODAY ON THE
PANEL WE HOPE ATTACK CAN BE
FOUND. TO PREVENT FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS BY PROVIDING A
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAM
FOR NAM INTERDEPENDENCE HOUSING
SUPPLEMENT ALLOWING YOU TO
REMAINING CAREPASSED THE JUNE
THIRTIETH EXECUTIVE ORDER DATE
AND SETTING ASIDE HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING FOR USE IN ANY
INVESTMENTS. THAT ARE MADE THIS
YEAR TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND AGAIN WE THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU'RE DOING
UP FOR THIS POPULATION WHO AS
WE KNOW. HOW ARE MORE LIKELY TO
BE CHILDREN AND YOUTH OF COLOR
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE POVERTY AND I'M MORE LIKELY
TO BE- LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER YOUTH- WHO ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN THAT SYSTEM AS
THE PANELISTS HAVE MENTIONED
TODAY- SO THANK YOU AGAIN AND I
ENJOY THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
MAY. THE EX COMMUNIST FROM
MEGAN SEPARATE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MAKE AFTER BIRTH ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES CALIFORNIA PRIMARY
CARE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS. SEVEN MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE DIALOGUE
TODAY I HAVE PREPARED COMMENTS
TO TALK ABOUT THE WORK FORCE
CHALLENGES AND I WILL BUT I
WANTED TO FIRST- DIRECTLY TO
RESPOND TO A QUESTION OF THE
CHAIR HAD ASKED OF THE LA-
EARLY ON ABOUT FINANCIAL
IMPACTS TO HEALTH CENTERS.
TRUTH SHE IS VERY OFFENSIVE
JUST OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL STIMULUS. TO
SUPPORT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY HEALTH CENTER
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE ALLOCATION AMOUNTS ARE
PUBLIC AND AVAILABLE ON HER
THIS WEBSITE BUT I'D BE HAPPY
TO. SUPPLY THIS COMMITTEE WITH
THAT INFORMATION FOR CONTACT
HEALTH CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA ON
AVERAGE GENERATE ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS A MONTH THROUGH PATIENT
ENCOUNTERED. WITH A SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN PRIMARY CARE BUT THAT
THE AMOUNT THAT WE HAVE TO
CHECK THE MONTHLY FINANCIAL GAP
OF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH.
OR NEARLY NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS A WEEK- ACTIVE TIMER
ESTIMATING THESE ARE LOCATIONS
WILL COVER JUST UNDER THREE
WEEKS OF OPERATION. OUT WE
CANNOT ANY CERTAINTY AT THIS
TIME THAT THE DOLLARS WILL
PREVENT ANY PERMANENT CLOSURES
FOR LOWS- EARLY ALSO THOUGH
THAT OBVIOUSLY OUR HOPE. AND
HURT THE DOES HAVE A NEW I
THINK I'M WE JUST HAVE HEARD
ANYTHING YET HOW DISTRIBUTION
OF THOSE DOLLARS WILL WORK-
BRIEFLY IF I MAY ON WORK FOR HE
HELPED HER SUPPORT COMPLAIN AND
FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. BASED ON VOLUNTARY
REPORTING STRUCTURE
ESTABLISHED- SHARE NEARLY FIFTY
OR PUSH OF RESPONDENTS ABOUT
THE CLOSE. ONE OR MORE STATES
AND NEARLY 66% OF RESPONDENTS
HAD TO FOR LOWER LAYOFFS GAS.
HEALTH CENTERS ARE READY
CHALLENGE WITH WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES IN WHEN THE CRISIS IS
OVER AND OUR HEALTH CENTERS.
CAN OPEN FOR NON URGENT AND
PRIMARY CARE VISITS THEY MAY
NOT HAVE THE WORK FORCE
NECESSARY TO MEET THE DEMAND
THAT WE ALL TALKED ABOUT HERE
TODAY- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES ME TO
OUGHT TO BE TALKING ABOUT
PROVIDER BURN OUT AND
RETIREMENT- OUR HELP CENTER TO
HEAR THAT BECAUSE- IT NINETEEN.
IS GOING TO PUSH PROVIDERS TWO
ON THE BRINK OF RETIREMENT OVER
THAT HUMP WHICH COULD BE
BLESSED. WITH EVEN LESS
PROVIDERS THE CURRENT HAVE. IN
RECOGNIZING THE WORK SUPPLY
DEMAND A THAT. PRE COLD IT BY
WE THINK THERE'S A- TO THE TO
AND- THAT THE ARE ENOUGH. THE
BILL OF THE TO BACK. TO HEALTH
OF EVERY WILL BE RAMPING UP THE-
AT THE ESSAY TIME. AND WE
BELIEVE WE'RE- RETRAINING WILL
CONTINUE TO BE CRITICAL AS WELL
AS INTEGRATING MARK TELEHEALTH.
AND TELEPHONIC CARE ACROSS THE
SYSTEMS OKAY I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH YOU I
THINK BEFORE WORK. THANK YOU
MA'AM. IN OUR NEXT COMMENT IS
ON THE LINE OF FRIED FISHER
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GERMAN ROOM
YOU'LL A MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I NAMES FOR CLOSURE
AND ON THE PRESIDENT'S THE
HOTEL ASSOCIATION CALLED WEST
CHAPTER. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WITH YOU
OUR EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS TO THE CODE NINETY
BILAS. THOSE DIAGNOSED WITH ALS
ALSO KNOWN AS LOU GEHRIG'S
DISEASE. COMPLICATIONS TO
RESPIRATORY INFECTION IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
THOSE WITH A LAST. DESPERATE
CODE NINETEEN ARMS REPRESENTS A
PARTICULAR REST OF THIS BEHIND
THE COMMUNITY. AS A PANDEMIC
EMERGED OUR STATE WIDE
WRAPAROUND PROGRAM COMPLETELY
TRANSFORM GRANDMA OFF CARE
WHICH RELIED UPON FACE TO FACE
INTERACTIONS IN A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY CLINICS HOME
VISITS SUPPORT GROUPS AND
COMMUNITY EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
WELL TO COMPLETELY AT
TELEHEALTH MODEL AS A PRIMARY
INTERVENTION. OKAY BUT TO TELL
HEALTH BEEN ABLE US TO MAINTAIN
SERVICES FOR THE GRANT. KEEPING
THIS HORRIBLE. SAFE WHILE
REDUCING THE SPREAD OF
INFECTION THAT'S KEEPING PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF HOSPITALS
EMERGENCY. ROOMS AND I SEE HIS.
HOW COCONUT REQUEST TO CAN.
THIS FUN OF THE RAPPER PRO.
CONCURRENT CURRENTLY WITH
DECEMBER AND COMMITTEE.
BUSINESS ELEMENT OF THE STATE'S
STRATEGY TO PRIORITIZE AND
TARGET SERVICES TO HIGH RISK
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHILE
REDUCING SPREAD. AND PROTECTING
THE CAPACITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. HERE
AT THE NEXT COMMENT AS SPAM
SERRA BRIDGE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU I REMEMBER THERE
BREAK ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT OKAY
DISTRICT PROVIDE HOSPITAL
CLINICAL BILL NOTHING DENTAL
AND A VARIETY OF OTHER
COMMUNITY HEALTH SERVICE THAT.
WOULD LIKE TO REITERATE THAT
COMMENT MADE AT THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND PANEL
ONE FEDERAL FUNDING HAS AND
CONTINUES TO BE APPRECIATED
HOWEVER THIS IS NOT ENOUGH
ESPECIALLY FOR PROVIDERS WHO DO
NOT SERVICE LARGE POPULATIONS
MEDICARE PATIENTS ANY.
MAINTAINING THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE BUT DIFFICULT PRIOR
TO COVER NINETEEN AND HAVE ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE EXTREME
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES PROVIDERS
ARE EXPERIENCING IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE HOW ROLL
WAIVERS REGARDING HELLO HELLO
HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY HELPFUL
WOULD LIKE TO BE MANY OF THESE
CHANGES BECOME PERMANENT.
FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
DOCTOR WAITED FOR HIS COMMENTS
REGARDING SEISMIC RETROFIT
ACOSTA ASSOCIATED WITH THE
TWENTY THIRTY RETRO THAT WERE
ALREADY INSURMOUNTABLE FOR MANY
SMALLER HOSPITAL. IT ONLY
BECOMES MORE DIFFICULT
CONSIDERING CURRENT FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP WITHOUT THESE HOSPITAL
CARE BECOMES BIRTH AND ALREADY
UNDERSERVED AREAS I BELIEVE
MANY OUT OF WORK WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING. THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU ENACT TEN
MINUTES FROM CURTIS FLYING
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DOCTOR ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE FIRST ONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION NATIONAL NURSES
NIGHT IT REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND NURSES.
PROVIDING DIRECT PATIENT CARE
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT BUT I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON SAFETY REQUIREMENTS
FOR HOSPITALS WE OPENING-
PROCEDURAL AND OUTPATIENT AREA.
CC GOT IN STILL RECOMMENDS
POSTPONING ELECTIVE PROCEDURES
SURGERIES AND NON URGENT
OUTPATIENT VISITS TO MINIMIZE
CHANCES OF EXPOSURE. SO HOSTILE
TO BE OPENING PROCEDURAL AREAS
THAT HAVE SAFETY PRECAUTIONS IN
PLACE TO PREVENT THE
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS
WITHIN THE FACILITY AND TO
PROTECT NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE WORKERS FROM
EXPOSURE. BEFORE PATIENTS ARE
WIDE PORT OF WHAT THE
PROCEDURES SURGERY OR
OUTPATIENT VISIT. PATIENTS
SHOULD BE SCREENED FOR ACTIVE
VIRAL INFECTION IS NOT RELIABLE
RT-PCR TEST BEFORE OR UPON
ARRIVAL AT THE FACILITY.
PATIENTS WHO TO TEST NEGATIVE
OR COULD NOT BE TESTED SHOULD
BE SCREENED FOR EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
RISK FACTORS SUCH AS HISTORY.
OF CONTACT WITH THE COME FROM
KOBE NINETEEN CASE IN FOURTEEN
DAYS BEFORE SCHEDULED FOR TO
SEE YOUR APPOINTMENT.
FACILITIES THAT ALSO CONTAIN TO
IMPLEMENT MEASURES TO THEM AND
INTRODUCTION OF THE VIRUS
FACILITY INCLUDING LIMITING AND
RESTRICTING VISITORS TO REDUCE
CHANCES THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
VIRUS FACILITY. UPON ARRIVAL AT
THE FACILITY FOR LET THE
PROCEDURE THIRTY THREE FOR
OUTPATIENT VISIT EMPLOYERS MUST
ENSURE THE NURSES HAVE ACCESS
TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL PP YOU.
AND FOR ME. CONTROLS CREATING
DOESN'T ZONES TO PREVENT
TRANSMISSION OF THE BAR WITHIN
THE- WELL WE ARE SEEN IT COME.
BILL OUT OF THE ECONOMY FOR
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYERS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THROUGH THE CARES
ACT. IT THERE'S NO FUNDING HERE
MARK FOR EATING OR TO PROTECT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHO ARE
BEING LAID OFF. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU IN THE
NEXT COMMENTED N THE LINE AB
AVERAGE BUYER BROWN LEAVE IT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS BARBARA
BEAVER I AM A LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE THANK THE CHAIR
AND EACH MEMBER FOR CONVENE AT
THE HORTON HEARING TODAY. SO
MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN REAL
CHAMPIONS FOR IMPROVING MENTAL
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY IN
CALIFORNIA. STEINBERG
INSTITUTED HERE TO SOUND THE
ALARM OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS THAT IS HERE. HOLD IT
HAS DRAMATICALLY EXACERBATED
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY
PROBLEMS AND CREATED SO MANY
NEW ONE. WE HAVE FIVE SOLUTION
FOR YOUR IMMEDIATE
CONSIDERATION TODAY TO GET HELP
TO BE ISOLATED THE LONELY
DEPRESSED. AND THOSE IN REAL
CRISIS. FIRST WE SUPPORT
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO MAKE
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY WE ALL IN
CALIFORNIA. SECOND PLEASE SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND DOUBLE OUR
STATE EXISTING CAPACITY FOR A
CRISIS AND WARM LINE. LEASE
ENCOURAGE AND PROMOTE THE
MUTUAL AID NETWORK THAT ARE
SPRINGING UP LIKE WILD FLOWERS
IN YOUR DISTRICT MAY PROVIDE
VOLUNTEERS WHO CAN PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE HELP TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. FOR IT PLEASE WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CREATE A COMPANION MENTAL
HEALTH CORE RESOURCE TO THE
EXISTING HEALTH CORPS WEBSITE
CREATED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND LAST WEEK CONSIDER
PARTNERING WITH ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE TRAUMA RESOURCE
INSTITUTE OUT OF CLAREMONT
CALIFORNIA. WHO CAN QUICKLY AND
INEXPENSIVELY TRAIN COMMUNITY
BASED VOTE THOUSANDS OF THEM TO
PROVIDE TRAUMA BASED MENTAL
HEALTH FIRST AID TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. HAPPY TO WORK IN
YOU NEED DETAILS ARE MORE THESE
WITH YOU OR YOUR STAFF OR ON
ANY OF THE SUGGESTIONS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. THANK
YOU MA'AM. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
DO WANT TO REMIND ANYONE WHO'S
LISTENING- YOU SHOULD PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE IF YOU DO WANT TO MAKE. A
PUBLIC COMMENT. SENATE PUBLIC
COMMENTS FROM THE NASA QUE
HANNAH PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IF YOU
CANNOT LOCATE THE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF AND HER
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP. ENOUGH
PEOPLE AT RISK PROVEN THE
TUNNEL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS BUT I'LL CONCLUDE
LONG TERM SAVINGS TO PUBLIC
PROGRAM SPELLED THAT SPENDING
AND HELPS FAMILIES OBTAIN
ECONOMIC SELF SUFFICIENCY. LIKE
OTHER HHS ADVOCATES WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION ON
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY THE
FOCUS ON LATIN BONTA LAST
RECEPTION AND HE IMPACT OF
THOSE. THAT HAVE ON SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. YOU'VE BEEN. TO WORK
WITH THE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE PART OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WHICH DIRECTOR JOHN CAN
HIGHLIGHTED IN HER COMMENTS
TODAY. WE'RE GRATEFUL TO THE
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES WHO
WORK ALONGSIDE OF AND IF HE-
STILL OF OUR PROGRAM LOCALLY
AND IT'S BEEN A LIFE ONE SUCH
TIME LOW INCOME MOTHERS MERRY
AND- GRATEFUL FOR THE TWENTY
PARTNERSHIP BUT LOVE FAMILIES
TO RECEIVE A COMPREHENSIVE THE
PREVENTION. AND SERVICE
CONNECTIONS. EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC BOTH DPH INDIA. MIKE
MODIFICATIONS SO AND A PEOPLE
PERSON. DELIVER HOME VISITS
TELEPHONICALLY ANSWER TELL.
WHICH ALLOWS FAMILIES TO STAY
CONNECTED WITH AMHERST HELPING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH HOUSING AND
OTHER MATERNAL CHILD HEALTH AND
PREVENTION. WE ENCOURAGE STATE
TO SUPPORT LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND NURSES. AS WELL
VOICED BY FROM THE PANELISTS
TODAY AS WELL AS MAINTAINING
TELEHEALTH SERVICE DELIVERY
DELIVERED BY TRAIN VERSUS TALK
CAMERAS WHILE LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. OR STRETCH.
DURING THE CODE AT THE SPAHN.
OUR COMMENTS ARE FURTHER OUT
BELOW THAT SUBCOMMITTEE LAST
WEEK A GREAT WE- THE PROSPECT.
AS WE ENTER A VERY THAT BUDGET
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU THE NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT AT SOME CRISTINA
HAS HAMILTON PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI HELLO- DR GRANULOMAS A
COMMITTEE THIS IS CHRISTINA
BONTA HAMILTON SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE U. D. W.
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND I JUST AS
PROVIDERS. IN TWENTY ONE
COUNTIES- THANK YOU FOR THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT DIALOGUE- THIS
IS A VERY LONG HEARING TO
LISTEN TO BUT A LOT OF REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES HAVE COME UP.
IN REGARDS TO IHS AS WE DO YOU
WANT TO DRAW ATTENTION TO A
COUPLE OF ITEMS. FIRST OFF THE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE THAT IS
SCHEDULED TO TAKE PLACE ON
JANUARY FIRST IS REALLY VITAL
FOR AYE HFS WORKERS WHO
LARGELY- MAKE JUST ABOUT THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND FOR THE I JUST
AS PROVIDERS WE REPRESENT IN IN
TWENTY ONE COUNTIES A LOT OF
THE CONTRACTS THAT WE HAVE
NEGOTIATED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL-
CONTAIN THESE WAGE SUPPLEMENTS
WHERE THE INCREASE. ESSENTIALLY
FLOATS ABOVE THE MINIMUM WAGE-
SO WE NEED TO RETAIN THOSE WAGE
SUPPLEMENTS WE NEED TO HAVE WE
DID BE- GOING UP NEXT YEAR WE
KNOW THAT THESE WORKERS ARE
GENERALLY EXTREMELY UNDERVALUED
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY DO AND
BADLY WITHOUT THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE THEY WOULDN'T BE A
GROWTH AT ALL AND IN A TIME
WHEN. WE SHOULD BE REWARDING
ESSENTIAL FRONTLINE STAFF LIKE
I JUST THAT'S WORKERS WHO
LITERALLY KEEP ELDERS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES OUT OF
NURSING HOMES OUT OF HOSPITALS
WHICH IS WHERE THE LAST PLACE
THEY SHOULD BE RIGHT NOW WITH
THE PANDEMIC WE NEED THE VALUE
THAT WORK WE DON'T NEED TO
UNDERVALUE OR CONTINUE
UNDERVALUING AT- I ALSO WOULD
CALL ATTENTION TO THEIR
CONTINUE NEED FOR P. P. E. R. I
IT JUST THAT'S WORKERS- THE
GOVERNOR HAS- COMMITTED. TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND. A FEW
KEY. WE ARE FOR THAT BUT WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S THE
THAT IS LIMITED IN TERMS OF WHO
CAN GO THROUGH THERE'S OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND WORKERS
IN GENERAL. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND WHEN WE KNOW THAT THEY
NEED TO BE REFRESHED CONSTANTLY
IS JUST THE FIRST STEP SO WE DO
WANT TO CALL ATTENTION TO THAT
AGAIN BECAUSE PEOPLE MAY BE A
SYMPTOMATIC AND KEEP HE IS ONLY
DESIGNATED. FOR WORKERS WHO ARE
SERVING INFECTED CLIENTS OR
CLIENTS WITH SYMPTOMS AND THEN
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO WHEN
ATTENTION THAT. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT ISSUE WHICH WE
WERE GOING TO BRING TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC- I JUST AS PROVIDERS
TO SERVE THEIR CLIENTS. THEIR
CHILD OR THEIR SPOUSES THEIR
CLIENTS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE UNDER STATE LAW FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. WE KNEW
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THEY WILL BE
COVERED IF THEY NEED TO UNDER
THE NEW P. YOU EIGHTY HOWEVER.
THAT IS A VERY LIMITED PROGRAM
AND IT ONLY GOES. FIRST THE
CIVIC UNEMPLOYMENT RELATING TO
COOPERATE. THESE WORKERS 85% OF
WHOM ARE WOMEN THERE'S OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND OF
THEM STATEWIDE. THEY NEED TO
HAVE ACCESS TO UNEMPLOYMENT.
ALL YEAR ROUND- MINUTE LEAVE
BECAUSE WE SEE NOW HOW
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS LIKE
UNEMPLOYMENT ARE TO KEEP PEOPLE
OF FLOW DURING THESE TYPE OF
CRISES. AND FOR THE FOLKS WHO
GENERALLY WHEN THIS IS
HAPPENING TO THEM IT'S BECAUSE
THEIR CHILD OR THEIR SPOUSE IS.
HOSPITALIZED FOR AN EXTENDED
TIME OR THEY PASSED AWAY THAT
IS A COMPOUND THE TRAGEDY WHERE
THEY'RE NOT ONLY GRIEVING THE
LOSS OF A LOVED ONE BUT THERE
NOW. CLEARLY FACING ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION BECAUSE THEY'VE
LOST THEIR PAYCHECK. THEY'VE
LOST WHATEVER- BENEFIT WAS A-
RECEIVED BY THE CLIENT AND THEN
DON'T WE- DON'T EVEN HAVE THE
SECURITY. OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
CHECK YOU TO TIDE THEM OVER SO
THOSE ARE WHAT WE WOULD
IDENTIFIES SOME OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING IN.
THE PANDEMIC MOVING FORWARD.
LOOK FORWARD TO PART WITH CAN
CHECK TO WERE ON. I SAYS
CLIENTS AND PROVIDERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE AND THE NEXT COMMENT
AND SOME ANDREAS SAYING. SAN
MIGUEL PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS ANDREA SENEGAL FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ADVOCATES ARE- A
CALIFORNIA- THANKFULLY THE
CALIFORNIA THE HEALTHY
ADVOCATE- AND SO GOOD TO TALK
WITH ALL OF YOU THANK YOU FOR
HAVING OPPORTUNITY- FOR THIS
TODAY. ALTHOUGH THE NEW FORMAT
I'M I'M SURE IS INTERESTING- WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
TOPIC OF THIS HAS BEEN
INCLUDING THE FINANCIAL NEEDS
OF THE SAFETY NOT- SO THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS- THE SEVEN
PLAY PARAPHILIAS HAVE
IMPLEMENTED. AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES ODDS DELIVERING CARE
DURING THIS TIME THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING- AND REALLY ARE
STILL WORKING TO MEET PATIENTS
WHERE THEY ARE WHETHER THAT'S
IN PERSON IN A LIMITED FASHION
OR ONLINE OR BY PHONE- SO THAT
BEING SAID WE ARE- YOU KNOW
CALLING INTO SHARE MANY OF THE
SAME CONCERNS RAISED BY OTHER
PROVIDERS. PRIMARILY THE
CONTINUED OPERATION AND
FINANCIAL STABILITY OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS WHICH
INCLUDE ONE PARENT LOCATION-
THE AT THE SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDERS ARE EASE OF OTHERS OF
PENSIONS THERE'S GONNA BE.
INCREASE AND DEFERRED AND
PREVENTATIVE CARE AND SO- YOU
KNOW WE ARE AMONG THOSE- IN
EXPECTING TO SEE AN INCREASED
DEMAND FOR SERVICES I COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS AS WELL AS- THE
USE OF MEDI CAL- FAMILY PACKED
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY FOR
PREGNANT WOMEN AND OTHER
PROGRAMS. FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
LOST EMPLOYER BASED COVERAGE
DURING THIS TIME OF- JOB LOSS
BECAUSE OF COVERAGE SO THEY'RE
JUST THREE QUICK- ITEMS I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT FROM ALL A LETTER
TO BE FEET ON CIRCULATING- THAT
WILL HELP WITH TAKING UP
PROVIDERS INCLUDING PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. THE FIRST IS JUST
THAT WE URGE THE CONTINUATION
OF PROPERTY SIX FUNDING THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED FOR BOTH FAMILY
PACKED AND FOR SOME SPECIFIC
FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES IN THE
MEDI CAL FEE FOR SERVICE AND
MANAGE CARE SIDE- WE HOPE TO
SEE THIS VERY LIMITED. AN
EXISTING HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
OUR- OF THAT PROPERTY SAID PART
OF FUND EX. THROUGH JULY FOR
TWENTY THREE. WHICH IS WHAT
WITH PROPOSED JANUARY BUDGET
THIS WILL REALLY JUST TO ENSURE
THAT OUR AFFILIATES AND OTHER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PROVIDERS
CAN RELY ON NEEDS. SUPPLEMENTAL
RATES FOR THESE CORE SERVICES
AS ALL PROVIDERS ARE WORKING
FOR THE CHALLENGE OF BUDGETING
AND THE UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR.
WE ARE ALSO ASKING THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE EVALUATE AND
CONSIDER. ALL AVAILABLE
VEHICLES FOR FUNDING- INCLUDING
THE JOINT REQUEST FOR A
LIFELINE GRANT FINDS DURING
DECLARED EMERGENCIES- THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE-
OF THEIR ONGOING FEDERAL
EFFORTS TO BLOCK FUNDING FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD ANOTHER
ABORTION PROVIDERS- THROUGH YOU
KNOW THAT THAT. THAT DISCUSSION
OF SOME OF THESE FEDERAL
FUNDING PACKAGES- SO THAT THE
CONCERNED AND I'LL JUST BRIEFLY
ECHO ON THE CHAIRS POINT AND
OTHERS. THAT IS REALLY VITAL
THE TELEHEALTH SERVICES
CONTINUE TO BE REIMBURSED AT
THE SAME RATE- ESPECIALLY ON
THE MEDIC HEALTH SIDE AFTER
THIS CRISIS IN- BEHIND US- WE
REALLY JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
INCLUDING PHONE OR NON VIDEO
TELL HEALTH SERVICES IS
CRITICAL FOR PATIENTS. WITH
INDICATING THAT- WHO ARE ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY EXPERIENCING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE- DURING THIS
TIME. SO I WILL I WILL STOP
THERE AND YOU LOOK FOR TO
COMMITTING- YOU KNOW WHAT TO
BEING. COMMITTED TO SERVING ON
ALL THESE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WITH YOU AND- AND
WORKING ALL THESE TOPICS MOVING
HAD NEED CHALLENGING. TIMES
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT
QUESTION HER I'M SORRY COMMENT
IS FOUND PATTY UP PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME.
I HEAR AN ECHO. YES SIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH. DOCTOR OF YOUR
YOUR PEOPLE I WOULD FIRST
OFFICE REPRESENTING YOUR- MY
NAME IS JEFF YEAH YEAH YEAH.
OFTEN WALK FOR EUROPE YOUR
ROOMS RIGHT NOW ALSO LOOKING AT.
THE BUT I REMIND YOU YES FIRST.
HEROES I'M WILL BE CALLING YOU
FOR. MAY FIFTEENTH ORDER AND WE
SORRY BE VERY INVOLVED IN YEAH
I DON'T THINK YOU NEED. ME
DISAPPEAR. WE NEED HELP WITH
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU KNOW PROGRAM THIS
IS UNCERTAIN TIMES AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY PART OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT
COMMON AND- BURIED CAROTENE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DOCTOR AND
YOUR MEMBERS A COMMITTEE VERY
GOOD YOU CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE KERRY TODAY-
WE REPRESENT- PROVIDERS OF
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. I DON'T THINK
ALSO DIRECTOR BUGS ME IN AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES IN RECOGNIZE THEIR
APPROACH AS WE'VE ALL COME TO
GRIPS WITH THE COVER NINETEEN
PRACTICE I'M PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE THE LATINO PAYMENTS
FOR NON RESIDENTIAL SERVICES
DECLINATION OF INCREASE TALKED
AND RESIDENTIAL SPACE- AS WELL
AS HE HELD IN- PROCURING
PEOPLE. FOR SOME PROVIDERS- AS
DIRECTED BY THE MENTION OF THE
A LOT OF PARTY SHIFTING-
COMMUNICATION WITH. OUR AND WE
GOT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT-
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE HAD
TO TRANSITION QUICKLY AND PAID
IT AS WE HAVE ADAPTED TO NEW
CRISIS AND THANK YOU YOU TOO
LIKE A MUSLIM COLLECTED
NINETEEN. YEP PARTS OF SERVICE
PROVIDED ON THAT DATE AS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO KIND OF THE
NEXT STAGE WE RE OPEN OF OUR
KITCHEN NEEDS FOR. FOR OUR
ARMED SERVICES WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I'LL WORKERS WHO ARE
CONTINUING TO- OFTEN IN PERSON-
ARE GETTING THE APPROPRIATE PP
THAT THEY'RE REQUIRING- TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE SAFE AND.
THAT THERE HI PERCENT AS WELL
ALSO ONE RICHARD SO THE ANYBODY
GET SOME OF THEM OF THIS CONTRA
ON A P. ONE OF THE SURE THAT
THERE ON SO DISABILITY STATE.
FINALLY WANT TO MENTION. AT
LEAST OF THE BY THE DECISION
MILLION THERE'S GOING TO BE. A
RECESSION WANTED TO EVERYTHING
TO PROTECT THE FONG FOR THE
DISTANCE SERVICES THAT THAT
COME CAL. WILL ON AS I THINK
MISTER MARCUS GO TO THE THAT.
WE BE ROLLED. OR ELSE IT
CREATES A TERM LAST YEAR. HE
WERE STILL RECOVERING FROM THE
BUDGET DEFICIT IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE MINUS MONACO. SO REALLY
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
CONTINUE- FUNDING THE. STATE
DIRECTOR PROFESSIONALS WHO WILL
OUT THERE TO INCREDIBLE WORK IN
JUST ONE CLICK COMMENTS BY
SAYING AND LIKE THEIR CREDIT
EFFORTS THE TIME MOST OF THE
MONEY GOES INTO OUR SET SYSTEM
DOES IN PAYING THEIR WAY TO
THERE ARE NOT GETTING PAID
ENOUGH THEY ARE DOING
INCREDIBLE ESSENTIAL WORK AND
HOPEFULLY ONE OF THE OUTCOMES
OF THIS IS THAT THE WILL OFTEN
BE INCREDIBLE EFFORTS AND- AND
THEY'RE AND THEY'RE TREMENDOUS
VALUE TO THE PEOPLE OF PLACER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU AND OUR NEXT COMMENTED
FOUND THE LINE AND PAIN
SHOULDER PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JANE SCHROEDER GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
FIRST PLACE FOR YOU WHERE IS
THE LARGEST T. H. P. AND THEN
THE PROVIDER IN THE STATE
SERVING YOU BETTER AGING OUT OF
FOSTER CARE IN ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA SAN FRANCISCO SANTA
CLARA. SOLANO AND LOS ANGELES-
WE'RE SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAME FOR CLASS TO
PREVENT FOSTER YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS BY PROVIDING A
HOUSING BUBBLE MEANT THAT HUGE
BE ENERGY PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM
IS A POWERFUL TOOL AND ENDING
DOCTOR YOU HOMELESSNESS. OR YOU
COULD SPEND TWELVE MONTHS OR
MORE WITH FIRST PLACE 90% OF
THEM ACT THAT YOU HAVE A
HOUSING 98% AVOID IRAQ AND 96%
AND ROLE IN POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION GET A DEGREE OR.
BECAUSE IMPORTANCE. A COLD
NINETEEN AND- CRISIS WELL HEY
ARE COKE AND YOU. HARD ALREADY
WE KNOW THAT OVER 50% OF THEM
POINT YOU WE HAD IN OUR PROGRAM
WERE LAID OFF FOR HAD THEIR
HOURS SIGNIFICANTLY CUT.
MEANWHILE ARE STOP RAFTING
FIRST RESPONDERS THEY'RE
CONTINUING TO AND FROM
HOMELESSNESS. YOU HAVE
ESSENTIAL. BUT THEY UNDERSTAND
LOCAL ORDERS AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS AND HAVE
ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY THEY'RE
PROMOTING THEIR MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING AS THEY
NAVIGATE FAST VERY SCARY TIME.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF NEW
SPENDING ON WAIT LIST WE NEED
THIS HOUSING AND SERVICES SO
DESPERATELY NOW MORE THAN EVER
AND PROVIDERS JUST CAN'T GROW
TO MEET THAT DEMAND FROM THE
GREAT FALLS SO FAR BELOW THE
COST OF HOUSING. BUT HOW THE
DOCUMENT IS THE BEST WAY TO
ENSURE THAT PROGRAMS CAN EXPAND
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND PREVENT FACTORY
ALMOST NEXT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
MA'AM. YOU AND THE NEXT COMMENT
AND FROM THE LINE OF THE SALE
COMPARATIVELY QUIET. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER MICHELLE
CAPITA WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. AS YOU KNOW COUNTY
THREATEN EIGHTEEN AT NATIONAL
P. PLAN AND PROVIDER NETWORKS
INDIVIDUALS WITH. MENTAL
ILLNESS SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT NEEDS AND FOR ALL
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF THE VERY
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS IN
MEDI CAL. COUNTY THERE ALSO IS
SPEAKING AT PROVIDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
THE UNINSURED INCLUDING
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS. AND
WE'RE INDIVIDUALS ARE
UNDERSERVED I THEIR COMMERCIAL
CLAN INCLUDING TO THE OPERATION
OF CRISIS SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING.
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY. WELL THE
NINETEEN HAVE HARMED ARE NOW.
HOWEVER AS PREPAID IMPATIENT
HELPFUL AND- I RECEIVED A PER
MEMBER PER MONTH LIKE OTHER
MEDIC HELP SERVING PLANS DO.
HOW DO YOU FINANCE THE HEALTH
SERVICES DURING NINETEEN NINETY
ONE AND TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT AS WELL AS THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND
OTHER NOMINAL FUNDING FOR IT.
ALL OF WHICH ARE EXPECTED TO
DROP IT BUT IT WILL BE IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS AS WE ENTER SOME
FORM. OF COVERT RELATED
RECESSION. DESPITE THINKS THIS.
WE'RE BACK TO SUSTAIN OUR
NETWORK AND THE RIGHT MAN TO
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND WITH THE SAME FEDERAL
NETWORK ADEQUACY STANDARD WITH
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLAN. ALL
IN THE FIRST WEEK FOLLOWING THE
STAY AT HOME ORDER SERVICE DEPT
AS WE COMPLETELY OVERHAULED OUR
SYSTEM TO DELIVER SERVICES.
ERELI VIA PHONE AND TELEHEALTH
THE TIDE IS STARTING TO TURN IN
AN ALARMING DIRECTION WHEN IT
COMES TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
RIGHT THIS CALL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT CALLS AND EVEN DEATH BY
SUICIDE ARE STARTING TO
ESCALATE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE'VE HEARD THAT IN SOME CASES
DEMAND FIRST AT UT SERVICES ARE
UP WE ANTICIPATE THAT ALL OF
THIS IS JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG. OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE
ARE IN THE MIDST OF A PARALLEL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PANDEMIC
WHICH WILL SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT
THE LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND DESPITE THE
FACT THAT ALL THE SYSTEM TODAY.
TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR THE VERY
CONSTITUENCIES OLDER ADULTS
DOCTOR YOU FRONT LINE HEALTH
WORKERS INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENT AND ON
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SAFETY
NET BUT NOT DIRECTLY ADDRESS IN
TODAY'S HEARING. IN TERMS OF
MEDICAL FRAGILITY COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CLIENTS
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS
TYPICALLY DIE TWENTY TO TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS EARLIER. ON RELATED
COMORBID MORBID PHYSICAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS LIKE. DIABETES AND
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE. OUR
CLIENTS ARE ALSO FAR MORE
LIKELY TO SMOKE THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION. AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH. FIVE SIX OF
ANY OF FOR EXAMPLE IS SEVENTY
TO EIGHTY HAS A 7280% CHANCE OF
BEING A SMOKER. AND OFTEN OUR
CLIENTS RESIDE IN CONGREGATE
AND RESIDENTIAL CARE SETTING.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT NOT
ENOUGH ATTENTION IS BEING PAID
TO BE UNIQUELY VULNERABLE
POSITION OF OUR CLIENTS AND THE
LADY AT THE SAFETY NET THAT
SUPPORT THIS AND ALL OTHERS. WE
WOULD URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WOULD BE HERE
HOPE THINKING THAT WILL BE
ESSENTIAL TO THE RECOVERY OF
OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR ECONOMY
AS A WHOLE LIFE WITH IF WE FAIL
TO DIRECT ATTENTION AND
RESOURCES TOWARD BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. WE HAVE REQUESTED
TEMPORARY FUNDING TO BUILD OUT
ARE SPEAKING AT SERVICES
INCLUDING BRIDGING THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE FOR OUR CLIENTS AND
BUILDING ALTERNATIVE CARE
SNIPER VULNERABLE POPULATION AS
WELL AS SHORING UP OUR DELIVERY
NETWORK. LAST YEAR AND THIS
ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH TALKED
CONCERNS FOR CALIFORNIA VOTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IT IS OUR
HOPE THAT MOVING FORWARD THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
WILL KEEP THEIR CONCERNS BY
GREAT PRIORITIZING THE BABY
RALPH SPEAKING AT FOR
INVESTMENT. AND THAT THE TOPIC.
FOR A FUTURE HEARING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM CAN LOWEST.
PLANNING CHILDREN NOW I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS TODAY AND I
AGREE WITH YOU CHAIRMAN
ARAMBULA WITH HERE YOUR MOTHER
AT THE BEGINNING AND THE
HEARING THAT BUT THAT HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES ARE INTEGRAL
TO CAPTURE THE RECESSION AND-
YOU NEVER. PRETENDED MICHAEL
HAVE CONSEQUENCES ON CHILDREN
IN NEED. OF THE LOBBYING AND
BOTH THE NEAR TERM AND IN THE
FUTURE. AND WHILE WE HAVE
COMMANDED SAM WRITTEN COMMENTS-
IN ADVANCE. HEARING I WON'T GO
INTO DETAIL BUT I DID WANT TO
RAISE. AND WE ECHO THE COMMENTS
IN THE COULD NOT GO REGARDING
THE FAMILY- GET RESPONSE.
THIRDS OF THEM AND THE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO FIND PRIORITIZE.
AND EXPEDITE. I AM AND WE
REQUIRE NOTICED FUNDING THE
REALLY KEEP KERN AND FORMER TOP
THREE YEAR AND THERE. GAVE
BIRTH. WHAT THEY NEED GET TRY
INFORMED SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
PREPARE THE FAMILY UNIT. AND
LINK YOUTH AND FAMILY HELLO-
KERN COMMUNITY. SUPPORT WHEN.
FIGURATION BUT INSTABILITY
ARRIVE. AND WE OUT THERE ARE
YOU KNOW REALLY COMPLETED
PROJECT INVESTMENT IN CHILD
CARE AND VOLUNTARY. I'VE BEEN
STATE HOMEBUILDING PROGRAM BUT
CAO WORK FAMILY AND- AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
NEED PROGRAM AREAS. MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HIGHLIGHTED
AND OUR COMMENTS ARE GEARED
TOWARDS PROTECTING THE SAFETY
NET AND I DROPPING THAT APPLE
IS CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES IN
TRAUMA. I'M CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN IN YEARS AND- MANAGE
ADD TO THAT YOU WILL CONTINUE.
TO PROTECT OUR MOST PRACTICE.
JOINT. THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM LUCY OUR
STATE OKAY THE CLASS. YEAH
HELLO I AM LUCY CELLS FEEL
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT AN
ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND NON PROFIT FROM
CALIFORNIA. AT NONPROFIT SEARCH
STEPPING UP AS THEY ALWAYS DO
IN A CRISIS TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND OTHER
VITAL PROGRAMS DURING THE COLD
AT NINETEEN CRISIS. I'D LIKE TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR THE FOURTH
LARGEST EMPLOYER AS AN INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA AND INCLUDES MANY
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS. AMPLE THE STATE
COUNCIL NON PROFITS TO PROVIDE
32% OF MEDI CAL SERVICES. BUT
NONPROFIT CAN'T CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THESE VITAL SERVICES
WITHOUT RESOURCES. WITH NEARLY
TWELVE HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT FIND OUR LETTER TO STATE
LEADERS WE ARE VIçT IF THEY
HAD A RATING THREE KEY WAY THE
STATE CAN SUPPORT NONPROFIT
THROUGH THIS CRISIS. FIRST
STATE AGENCIES SHOULD CONTINUE
TO PAY ON CONTRACTS WITH NON
PROFITS AND ALLOW CONTRACT
FLEXIBILITY. SECOND NONPROFITS
MUST RECEIVE EMERGENCY FUNDS TO
ADDRESS INCREASED COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL SERVICES INCLUDING
FOR PP. AND THIRD NONPROFITS
MUST RECEIVE PROTECTION VETERAN
PLAYERS TENANTS IN MORTGAGE
HOLDERS AND UTILITY RATE
PAYERS. AND THESE NONPROFIT
NEEDS HAVE THUS FAR LARGELY
BEEN ON MATT BY ADMINISTRATION
RESPONSES IT WAS GOOD TO HEAR
ABOUT SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
FLEXIBILITY AND AGENCY PROGRAMS
TODAY BUT MUCH MORE IS NEEDED
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AS A COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS
OUR REQUESTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM CAM MADDEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU DOCTOR IN REAL
MEMBERS TEN MADDEN REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS MERCY FISHIN HOLE
THE UNIQUE IN CRITICAL ROLE IN
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS PANDEMIC WE ALL
WANT IN NEED EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS TO BE AVAILABLE ON A
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN BASIS
ESPECIALLY IN THESE TIMES OF
CRISIS. THIRTY PATIENTS THRIVE
ON BEING ON THE FRONT LINES
HELPING ANYONE WHO COMES INTO
OUR EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT. EVEN
IF AS IS THE CASE WITH THE
COVERED PANDEMIC IT PUTS THEIR
OWN LIVES AT RISK AS WELL AS
THEIR LOVED ONE. SPEAKING WITH
OUR MEMBERS WE HAVE HEARD THE
VOLUME OF PATIENTS COMING INTO
THE MERCY DEPARTMENT AT THE
DECLINE BY AN AVERAGE OF FORTY
PERCENT. WITH A NUMBER OF
LOCATIONS HAVING REPORTED MORE
THAN A 70% DECLINE. FOR
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WHO ARE
NOT. EMPLOYED BY HOSPITALS AND
ALSO DON'T RECEIVE CAPITATED
PAYMENTS IN THE SAME MANNER AS
OTHER PHYSICIAN GROUPS. THIS IS
RESULTING IN A REDUCTION IN
THEIR INCOME AS A RESULT OF THE
DECLINE IN REVENUE FOR PATIENTS
THAT THAT. WE ARE WORTHY OF THE
EFFECT OF THIS REDUCTION AND
PATIENT VISITS. AS A PANDEMIC
IS EXPECTED TO CONTINUE
POTENTIALLY INTO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. THE CHALLENGE FOR
MERCY FISHING GROUPS IS TO
MAINTAIN A LEVEL OF STAFFING AT
OUR MERCY DEPARTMENTS THAT IS
NEEDED. TO CONTINUE TO MEET THE
ONGOING SEARCHES THAT ARE
ANTICIPATED TO OCCUR. TWENTY
EIGHT THREE THINGS. ASSISTANCE
FROM THE STATE FOR MERCY
PHYSICIANS TO HELP US THROUGH
THIS DIFFICULT PERIOD. AND WE
SUBMITTED SOME DETAILS TO THE
COMMITTEE- GOING INTO- OUR
REQUEST. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
QUICKLY MENTION THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE WORK FORCE AND THE MERCY
DEPARTMENT TO INCLUDE. ALCOHOL
AND DRUG COUNSELORS. LASHER YOU
IN THE THIRD COMMITTEE WERE
VERY SUPPORTIVE. OF THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
ALLOCATION TO PLACE TO PLACE
COUNSELORS AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. AT THE STATE HOME
ORDER CONTINUES WERE BEGINNING
TO SEE MORE PATIENTS STRUGGLING
WITH THEIR ADDICTION ISSUES.
THESE COUNSELORS ARE BECOMING
MORE AND MORE IMPORTANT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES JUST COMPLETED THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR
HOSPITALS TO OBTAIN FUNDS THE
PLACE CANCERS IN THE MERCY
DEPARTMENT. IN THE DEPARTMENT
IS TARGETED FUNDS TO GO OUT ON
MAY FIFTEENTH. ALTHOUGH ROUGHLY
A HUNDRED FIFTY HOSPITALS HAVE
APPLIED FOR FUNDING THE FULL
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS WILL NOT
BE FULLY USE THIS YAR LARGELY
BECAUSE AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
HOSPITALS ARE SO FOCUSED ON THE
PANDEMIC THEY HAVE NOT HAD TIME
TO APPLY. WE ARE ASKING THE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW FOR FUNDS
LEFT OVER FROM THIS YEAR TO
ALSO BE USE THAT NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET FOR THIS PURPOSE I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
DOWN THE ROAD. THANK YOU SIR.
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
MICHELLE GIVEN BY HEAD.GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS MICHELLE
GIVEN THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. CRITICAL ISSUE
FACING THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE HAS NOT
YET BEEN A FOCAL POINT. DURING
THE LAST RECESSION PUBLIC
HEALTH LIKE MANY OTHER SAFETY
NET SERVICES BE DETRIMENTAL HI
IN ADDITION TO BE A FEDERAL
FUNDING DECLINED ONE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF FUNDING NINETEEN
NINETY ONE HELP REALIGNMENT
FUNDING REMAINS A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION BELOW THE
RECESSION LEVEL. THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT WORKFORCE HAS
NOT RECOVERED LAST RECESSION
AND AS WE PREPARE STATE BUDGET
CHALLENGES AHEAD- THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL CONTINUE TO BE
NEGLECTED WHEN IN FACT HOLDEN
NINETEEN DEMONSTRATED NEED TO
INVEST SUBSTANTIAL MORE
RESOURCES INTO THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT INFRASTRUCTURE. OUR
WORKFORCE ALSO INCLUDES
PHYSICIANS AND MEDICAL DIRECTOR
AT THE ALA GET IT EITHER LEFT
THE GATORS CONTACT TRACERS
LABORATORY IN. AND OUT CRITICAL
PATH WORKING IN VITAL. PROGRAMS
AND OTHER VITAL PREVENTION
PROGRAMS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
ARE AGENCIES MAPLE CREEK WILL
COMPETITION WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WHICH PROVIDE HIGHER PAY
AND IN SOME INSTANCES LESS
REQUIREMENTS YET DESPITE THE
CHALLENGES PUBLIC HEALTH WORKER
SHORTAGE HAS RECEIVED LITTLE
ATTENTION AND THERE IS NOT
FOCUS ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH HI
PLANNING. HIGHER EDUCATION THEM.
OUR WORK YOU'VE GOT MORE
FUNDING WITHIN TWO THE HOME.
QUITE IT AND WHILE FOR THINK
AND POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THE COLD THANK. EFFECT
INCLUDING BOLD BUSINESS
COMMUNITY. AND OUR PARTNERS.
ARE LEANING ON A CRITICAL
WORKFORCE IN PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
GUIDANCE A FIFTY TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF COAL THAT NINETEEN.
WE ACT ALLEGED PRIOR.
STRENGTHENING OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. BECAUSE OF COLOR
HEALTH IS NOT ADEQUATELY RE
THIRTY MANY THER SECTORS ARE
AT THAT ARE. ADVERSELY IMPACTED
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MA'AM. ALEX COMMENT COMES
FROM DON COQUI PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
DONALD CAP HE WITH MCCUE
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
THE CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
CENTER IN CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RESOURCE ASSOCIATION DURING THE
TRAINING OF PRESIDENT TIMES THE
FIVE HUNDRED FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUING TO SERVE THE MOST
OUT RISK MARGINALIZED CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. DESPITE THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
SERVING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WITH DISPOSABLE DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS EFFORTS EITHER
NONETHELESS CONTINUING TO HELP
WITH PROVIDING CRITICAL
ESSENTIALS SUCH AS FOOD DIAPERS
CRIBS CLEANING SUPPLIES AND
MORE. ADDITIONALLY THEY ARE
CONTINUING TO FIGHT SUPPORTER
HERSCHEL HOME VISITS SUPPORTING
ONE ON ONE TRAINING INCLUDING
COURT MANDATED TRAINING TO
REUNITE FAMILIES PROVIDING
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS AS WELL AS HELPING TO
MAKE NECESSARY CONNECTIONS TO
HELP CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
ACCESS HOUSING. THIS IS NOT A
SNAPSHOT OF THE CRITICAL WORK
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS ARE
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT AT RISK
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WE THINK
THE GOVERNOR IS THE
MINISTRATION FOR THEIR SUPPORT.
LOOK FORWARD BUT A LOT QUICKER
AND WE CAN DO. TO SUPPORT CHIU
AND FOR AT A POINT IN TIME WHEN
FAMILIES STRETCHED THIN AND
UNDER SEVERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM TRACY WERE
ARAMBULA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
I'M TRACY WOULD TRADE WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE.
WITHOUT QUESTION LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WILL NEED RESOURCES
AND SUPPORT TO INCREASE THEIR
CAPACITY TO HANDLE THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF CODE
NINETEEN CONTROL. EQUAL URGENCY
AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES HEALTH
AND ABILITY TO SURVIVE IS
THREATENED BY THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. BUT
JUST LACK OF ACCESS TO
SUFFICIENT AND HEALTHY FOOD
UNEMPLOYMENT UNSTABLE HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE AND
EDUCATION. I WILL DO COPE WITH.
AND WILL INDOOR IN THE
AFTERMATH ESPECIALLY FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE MUST
INCLUDE COMMUNITY BASED
PREVENTION STRATEGIES TO HELP
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS WHETHER
THE ONSLAUGHT OF CHRONIC
ILLNESSES AND DEATHS OF DESPAIR
IT WE KNOW WHAT RESULT FROM
UNMET SOCIAL NEEDS. WE DON'T
HAVE TO BETWEEN. THAT AND
ADDRESSING COMMUNITY BASED
PREVENTION WE CAN AND WE MUST
DO BOTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
X. COMIC COMES FROM THE GERMANS
IN GERMAN TRANSLATES GO AHEAD.
SORRY OUR NEXT QUESTION COMES
FROM ADAM SORRY OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM ADAM FRANCIS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
ALL WHO TOOK THE ADAM FRANK
WITH THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS.
FOR THE PAST LACK OF SUPPORT
FOR PARTNER WITH AN INJECTION
WORKFORCE AND THE CONTINUED
DECLINE OF PATIENTS HAVING
ANNUAL SORTS OF PRIMARY CARE
UPLAND CALIFORNIA SPENDING UP
AND 7% OF ALL PREMIUM REVENUE
ON PRIMARY CARE THESE NUMBERS
OF THAT I MEAN IT. RIGHT BACK
TO ARE CLOSING ADDRESS OF COME
NINETEEN AND THOSE IN UNDER
SERVED IN WORLD AREAS MAY NEVER
RETURN ALL THIS IN THE STATE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
PATIENTS HAVE ACT TO THE-
DISEASE PREVENTION DEPARTMENT
RIGHT WE NEED DRASTIC ACTION
NOW WE WOULD ALSO WORK TO
ENSURE THAT WE DON'T CASES THAT
IN THE FUTURE MEDICARE
RECOGNIZE QUITE GO AND ABOUT.
ONE YOUR NO GENETIC SO ARE NOT
ASIAN THEY AT BEST HI INTO
LOANS THE ACTION WITH REAL
IMPACT THAT MEDICARE PROVIDED
WHAT'S PROSPECTIVE PAYMENT. ANY
AND MEDICARE PAYMENT FOR CARE
PROVIDERS CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
NEED THEM POLICY. PRIVATE
PAYERS CAN LOOK MARCH APRIL AND
MAY OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND A
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN
PERSPECTIVE PAYMENT BASED ON
EACH MONTH. ISSUE THEN CONTINUE
MONTH THE MONTHLY PAYMENTS AT
ALL OF THE OF EMERGENCY LAST.
CRITICAL REQUIREMENT MUST BEGIN
IMMEDIATELY OR AT LEAST BE
INCLUDED THAT JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET. WELCOME A MINUTE
AND THAT'S LIFELINE TO KEEP.
ACTIVE OPEN YOU MUST TAKE
ACTION TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT RETURN TO IT'S BROKEN
AND IT'S FUNCTIONAL OUR SYSTEM
WHEN THE NATIONAL STAGES OF
THIS CRISIS PASSED. THE PAYMENT
OF PRESCRIBE SHOULD NOT ONLY
ACTIVE LIFE PRIMARY CARE AND
IT'S PRACTICE. ALSO BE A
JUMPING OFF POINT TO BUILD ON
THAT IMPORTANT PAIN REFORM THIS
CAN BE DONE THROUGH A NEW FORD
THINKING GLOBAL PAYMENT MODEL
COUPLED WITH PERFORMANCE BASED
INCENTIVE PAYMENT. THE WHOLE
POSITION THE CAMPBELL FOR
QUALITY. ACCOMPLISH THIS WE-
REQUEST NO LATER THAN TWENTY
ONE. THE SECRETARY OF HEALTHAND HUMAN SERVICES AFTER THAT
CAN BE WAITING THE CIVIC
ANTITRUST LIABILITY TO BRING
TOGETHER PUBLIC AND COMMERCIAL
PAYER. THEIR PARTY PURCHASERS
PROVIDE INFORMATION ADVOCATE.
TO A DENTAL BY OUR COULD THINK
AND MOVE TO THE TYPE BASED
MODEL GREEN LINE ON. IF THE
STATE AND PRIME PAYOR THAT
ADEQUATE SUPPORTED CARE COULD
NINETEEN. OUR HEALTH CARE SAID
WOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH BETTER
PREPARED. A STRONG FOUNDATION
PRIMARY CARE IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT DURING PANDEMICS LIKE
OPEN NINETEEN AS PRACTICES ARE
A NATURAL FIT FOR TRIAGE IN
TESTING TREATING IN EDUCATING
PATIENTS. LET'S TAKE THIS
MOMENT KNAPSACK QUICKLY TO
DAMAGE FROM IT THE STRUCTURE
AND LOOK AT I MEAN SURE
CALIFORNIA THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO. GET THAT THEM PREMIUM
SEVEN PAIN FOR. USER COMMENT
COME FROM JUSTIN GARRETT. GLAD.
HI THIS IS JUSTIN GET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I WANT TO THANK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR EXAMINING THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA IF YOU KNOW
SYSTEM COUNTY THERE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF PROVIDING
SERVICES THE MOST. RIGHT REALLY.
OKAY TODAY'S HEARING. ALSO
APPRECIATE LEADERSHIP OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND PROVIDING
EMERGENCY FUNDING OF
FLEXIBILITY TO HELP COUNTIES
PROVIDE SERVICES SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY. OUR FOCUS ON TO-
BARGING OUT COUNTY SPEAKING AT
PARTIES BUT WOULD NOTED THERE
ARE NUMEROUS NEEDS FOR
INVESTMENT PROTECTION FOR
PROGRAMS INCLUDING A NOT SO
DISTANT. HOMELESSNESS AND
PROTECTING OLDER ADULTS AND
CHILDREN OUR MANY OF WHICH
MEANT HIGHLIGHTED DURING SPACE
GOSH. FIRST ON. FUNDING THERE
WILL BE SEVERE DECLINES IN THE
REVENUES THAT ON CRITICAL HUMAN
SERVICES PROGRAMS. THE COUNTY
STAR BEHALF OF THE STATE AND I
FULLY AGREE HOW WITH THE
COMMENTS FRANK MECCA MADE. ON
THE BECAUSE RAISE THIS ISSUE IN
THE BUDGET LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE FOR
THE WORKING TOGETHER TO
IDENTIFY THE BEST WAY TO
PROVIDE STABILITY TO RESPOND
BUT AVOID CUTS THE PROGRAM ALSO
NEEDED DURING THIS CRISIS.
SECOND PER COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION THE NEXT
APPLICATION FROM THE PROGRAM'S.
REQUIREMENTS ON COUNTY. I WANT
TO ENSURE THAT ALL THIS
INCREASED COUNTY WORKLOAD
ADEQUATELY FUNDED. PARTICULARLY
GIVEN THE CATCH OF WORK FOR
DELAYED PRACTICE OF THE HAS
BEEN REFERENCED DURING TODAY'S
DISCUSSION BUT ALSO WANT TO
MAKE A FEW COMMENTS ARE RELATED
TO THE FIRST PANEL ON HEALTH
CARE WORK FORCE. OF THE HEALTH
OF THE STATE YOU KNOW
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS AN
INDEPENDENT WE NEED TO SUPPORT
THE WORK FORCE FOR ALL
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYERS. I WHICH
PUBLIC HOSPITALS HEALTH PLANS
AND CRITICS. UNDER THE
DESPERATE NEED FOR DOCTORS
PSYCHIATRISTS AND UNDERSERVED
PARTS OF THE STATE PUT IN
CENTRAL VALLEY AND OTHER RURAL
AREAS. ABOUT THE NEED TO THINK
CREATIVELY ACREE ME WHICH IS
THAT THE COURT. HEALTH AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE PORTS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND BEYOND I WITH
THAT I THANK YOU FOR TODAY
APPRECIATE. THAT THANK SIR. AND
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
ALBERT LOWENTHAL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- FAMILY
MONEY. ARE WE NOT AND- ALONG
THE LINE IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
STOP IN FIVE ALBERT WILY PAUL
HELP AT THE MOMENT ALL OF BY
FAITH. CALIFORNIA COVERAGE HELP
MAKE THE- MISTAKES MARKET- AND
WALDRON. ALL THE FOR EIGHT WAIT
FOR THE EFFORT OF GOVERNMENTS
AND IT'S VERY. TO AT THAT COULD
NOT BE FOUND THEM AT THE BELL
WILL GRAB BY THAT. WE HAVE A
CHIEF FAR ADMITTED IT'S AROUND
SUCCESS WE LEADERSHIP US
SECRETARY MARK GALLI DIRECTOR
BRAD GILBERT AND DIRECTOR SON
AND KILL. OR THEIR EFFORT AND
WE CERTAINLY STRONG SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
IN PARTICULAR ASSEMBLY MONEY-
AROUND A LOT TO STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS- AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
DOWN THE SUCCESSFUL PATH AND
BUILD ON IT TO INSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO PARTICULAR.
LOS MOST AT RISK LOWER INCOME
ELDERLY BLACKED OUT AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR ARE SURE COOL ACCESS
TO THE HEALTHCARE BENEFITS YOU
MAY QUALIFY FOR- AND DESERVE-
SIXTY EIGHT SHY. AGAINST ALL
WELL IT WITH THE MASSIVE AMOUNT
OF BUT I AFTER MY THAT THE NOT
ABOUT OUT FOR THE WELCOME
ALTHOUGH TO THE LONGER PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE NEXT FOUR MONTHS.
WELL BEYOND ALL OVER IT ALL ALL
OUT WE AND ALMOST. I KNEW WHAT
THAT DOES IS WITH WHITE ARE ARE
AND WILL BE ALL WHILE. BY
NUMBER OF POTENTIAL MEDICARE I
WOULD STEPPED UP OKAY OKAY SO.
IF YOU'RE A GIANTS IS A SACK
BEE SYSTEMS OF THIRTY NON
PROFIT NOTHING EIGHT SERVING
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY SOUNDS.
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ENROLLMENTS PER YEAR
MOSTLY IN MEDI CAL SOME ALSO IN%
COVER CALIFORNIA. OUR MEMBER
AGENCIES LEE LOCAL ASSOCIATIONS
AND COALITIONS CONSISTING OF
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
NOW NOT PROFIT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
GOVERNMENT OFFICES. WHAT AND
OTHER PROVIDER AND WE CIRCLE.
THAT IS EIGHTY TO BUT LIKE KNOW
MOST OF THE STATE SYMBOL TO OUR
NUMBER ARE TO KNOW- WE ARE
CURRENTLY ENGAGED- NOT ONLY IN
ADDRESSING THIS MASSIVE
POTENTIAL INCREASE IN MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY. BUT ALSO ON A MANY
MANY PROJECT WHICH WILL FOCUS
ON AND THERE'S FOCUSING ON-
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION. YOU ALL YOUR MOSTLY
THAT THERE ACCESS TO THOSE BE
THE ELDERLY MOST RISK FOR THE
RAVAGES OF THIS. AND THEM I CAN
WE HELP WITH THAT EFFORT WILL
BE ADEQUATELY STORE RESOURCE-
IN THE NEAR FUTURE. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE THE- COMMENTS AND WILL
PROVIDE THESE COMMENTS TO SOME
LIKE GREATER DETAIL TO THE.
TODAY OR TOMORROW THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM LEANDRA CLARK HARVEY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM KELLY BROOK PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEM THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE COMMITTEES FOCUSED TODAY ON
THESE CRITICAL HEALTH CARE
SAFETY NET TOPICS AND YOU KNOW
THE MAJORITY OF PATIENTS SEEN
AT PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
OUR LOW INCOME AND ARE COVERED
BY THE MEDICAL PROGRAM OR
REMAIN UNINSURED. THESE
PATIENTS ARE SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS AT OUR
STATE INCLUDING THE HOMELESS
ARE JAIL POPULATIONS SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY RESIDENTS
ANOTHER. MANY OF THE PATIENTS
SURVIVE PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS ARE ALSO VERY WORKERS
ON THE FRONT LINES IN THE MIDST
OF THIS PANDEMIC ALLOWING OUR
STATE TO MAINTAIN ESSENTIAL
OPERATION THERE ARE GROW
CULTURAL- JANITORS OUR DELIVERY
DRIVERS AND OTHER LOW INCOME
FROM MY- LIKELY BECAUSE IT.
ALSO BRING THAT THE NIGHT OF
HAVING A PORTION AND ON THE
POPULAR WITH SERVE FOR EXAMPLE
LATINOS ACCOUNT 4408% OF COVER
NINETEEN IS IN CALIFORNIA AT
WILL REPRESENTED ONLY 30% OUR
POPULATION. HELP THEM STAND
READY TO CONTINUE THE- BUT THEY-
I TO THIS POINT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING HAVE BEEN AND IN PROP
COST COVERING ONLY A SMALL
FRACTION ACOSTA MONSTROSITY I
KNOW WE EXPECT TO FUTURE
FEDERAL FUNDS WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE THAT THEY WILL MEET
OUR NEEDS CALIFORNIANS MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
DESPERATELY NEED TO THESAFETY
NET INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE MUST
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC HOSPITALS
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO CARE FOR THE PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE FOR HARDEST HIT BY THIS
PANDEMIC WE KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE SHARES MISSION AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM REBECCA GONZALEZ
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I RECOGNIZE
DOLLARS FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND. AS CLIENTS
OF SOCIAL WORKERS I WOULD SAY
ALL OF THEM FAILED- EVERYTHING
FROM- AND SOCIAL WORKER SUCH AS
WORKFORCE NEED- EITHER NEEDS IN
OUR MENTAL HEALTH THE FEATHER
AND ISSUES RELATED TO PROCTOR
YOU I ONLY WANT TO MENTION YOU
THINK TODAY ABOUT- I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT AT THE I AT THAT HE
GRANT. YOU PROBABLY KNOW WOULD
HAVE HEARD AND MULTIPLE HEARING
IT'S BEEN THAT- LAST RECESSION
THIS WAS THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT
WASN'T FULLY WERE BORED AND
WE'RE STILL ASKING TO RAISE THE
AT THAT SEAT F. THIRTY GRANT-
THE PROGRAM TO BE ABOUT POVERTY
LEVEL- AT YOU KNOW THESE ARE
ECONOMIC ARE. BECAUSE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LITTLE MONEY- DON'T
SPEND THAT MONEY THEY PUT IT
BACK INTO THE ECONOMY AS WAS
MENTIONED BY BACK TODAY I'M THE
LAST SO MANY OF THE ARE PEOPLE
ON THESE ARE. STEPPED AWAY FROM
WITH THAT. GOOD THING OUT
MENTION IS HELP FOR ALL. THIS
IS CRITICALLY AND RIGHT NOW IS
WE KNOW THE CODE THAT NIGHT CAN
AFFECT THEM. REALLY AND OUR
ELDERS BUT NOW THAT THE LIKELY
TO DIE. IF WE COULD HAVE HELPED
HER SOME OF THOSE. THEY THINK.
MAY HAVE TAKING OF AND WE COULD
HAVE BELOW. THE MARK HOW RATE I
AND LAW I DO WANT TO ASK FOR
HELP IN. I AM AT THIS. FOR
THOSE IN COVERAGE HELP WE DO X.
PREMIUM AND CO AND TO GO UP
NEXT YEAR DO THAT THE PAN DOWN.
I ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM JESSICA MARIN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CHAIR MEMBERS WITH
JESSICA MORAN WITH THE CHILDREN
PARTNERSHIP THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HOSTING THE HEARING TODAY.
YOU BECAUSE THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS REALLY HIGHLIGHTED
THE IMPORTANCE OF TELEHEALTH
SERVICES WHICH IS SOMETHING THE
CHILDREN'S PATNERSHIP STRONGLY
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF-
DETERMINES THAT HAPPENED TO BE
IMPORTING AND THAT THERE WE
CONTINUE TO REMEMBER IMPAIR HE
WAS IN PERSON VISIT. I NOT ONLY
THAT WE ALSO PROVIDE THEIR
DIRECT GIVE THE CLINIC THAT.
PER ON HOW THE BILL TELEHEALTH
SERVICES INCLUDE WELL TELL
VISIT. I AM ALSO COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS HAVE SEPARATE A
HUGE HIT THE PANDEMIC IN LOS
THE MEMBERS. AND THEY ARE A KEY.
POINTS FOR LOW INCOME CHECK NO
FAMILIES. AND THEY NEED TO BE
BROUGHT HE WON THANK YOU PROP
THAT. LASTLY I WANT HIGHLIGHT
THE- OF EXPEDITING THE AND- OF
THE HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS
EFFORT WE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
YEAH- ELIGIBILITY FUSION
CALIFORNIA. FOR ONE IT DID YOU
HAVE AT LEAST A DOCUMENT CARRY
AN ADMIN- EPIDEMIC HAD PANDEMIC
HAS SHOWED. AND THE HEALTH OF
HEALTH. INTERCONNECTED NAMING.
MY WORK ISSUES. THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT COMIC FROM WRAPPED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
REMEMBER. CHAIR AROUND THE IN
THE FAMILY MATTER WITHIN THEIR.
BUT OUR WHICH. BUT BEFORE OKAY
THE DEVELOPMENTAL THEIR OWN
HEALTH. MY OF MY ATTENTION
CALIFORNIA'S BUT LET ME FOR.
DESPITE ALL THAT IT. REACHING
EIGHT THAT SO THAT WE CAN I DO
A LOT OF WEIGHT TO LEAVE IT. AT
THE MOMENT KEEPING AT EIGHT
EIGHT NOT IN OFF HELLO STATE
SPENT A LONG. ALL OF. IT WHAT
AT THE PUMP. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. IT ALL. YEAH. ONE THESE
EIGHT ALL. AT EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM JOHN WONDER PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE I'LL BE BRIEF AND BE
SURE TO FOLLOW UP WITH WRITTEN
COMMENTS AS WELL THIS IS THE
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL COALITION PERSISTED IN
REHAB TECHNOLOGY WHERE THE
MANUFACTURES AND PROVIDERS OF
COMPLEX REHAB TECHNOLOGY IN THE
STATE- WHICH IS A VERY SMALL
SUBSET OF DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT. AND A PRIMARILY
INDIVIDUAL CUSTOMIZE
WHEELCHAIRSFOR ADULTS AND
CHILDREN WITH SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES- I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING
RELATED TO- PROVIDE A GROUP NOT
RECOVERING FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT RECESSION WERE
ONE OF THOSE GROUPS THAT IS
STILL SUFFERING UNDER THE AB
9710% ON TOP OF THAT THE AND
THAT'S JUST APPROVED A STATE
PLAN AMENDMENT. THAT WILL CUT
OUR RATES EVEN FURTHER AND IS
RETROACTIVE BACK IN JANUARY ONE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. MEANING
WE WILL SEE SIGNIFICANT- CLAW
BACK. TO OUR PROVIDERS- OUR
PATIENT POPULATION PROVIDER
NETWORK IS ALREADY VERY FRAGILE
WE ONLY HAVE EIGHT COMPANIES.
AND JUST OVER THIRTY LOCATIONS
IN THE STATE. WE ALSO ARE
TRYING TO BOB THIS FRAGILE
POPULATION DURING THE CALL
WOULD NOT SEEN PANDEMIC WHICH
IS- WHICH IS. ALLOWING US TO
FACE- AL HOME DELIVERY OF CARE
ISSUES ON TOP OF THESE EXISTING
PENDING. REIMBURSEMENT ISSUES-
I WOULD NOTE THAT DH CS HAS
KEPT AN OPEN DIALOGUE WITH US
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMERCE IT.
THEM THE FUTURE CONVERSATION
EVER BUDGET DECISIONS. SOME WHO
ARE ALL TIMES OVER LATE WILL
RESIGN IN THE LEGISLATURE SO WE
HAVE WE ARE HOPING TO COME TO
YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE MOVING
FORWARD IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
TO MAYBE FIGURE OUT. IN WHICH
WE CAN HELP- ARE VULNERABLE
PROVIDER NETWORKING SO WE LOOK
FOR THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM SHANTY PRESS
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH SH HI
THIS ASSEMBLY PRASAD WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS AND THE ORGANIZING CHAIR
FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR AFTER
FIVE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS FIGURE
LEADERSHIP- AND IN HELPING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS.
WE IN THE COALITION ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED FOR THE
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO HAVE BEEN HIT
VERY HARD BY THIS PANDEMIC. I
WANT TO ADDRESS THE S. S. P.
THE STATE QUESTION ABOUT THE
FIVE GRAMS. ARE THE GRANTS
WHICHWERE NEVER RESTORED
DESPITE A DECADE OF ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. AND THIS IS THE STORY
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS OF
FOLKS NOT USING THEIR AYE HSS
PROVIDERS BECAUSE THEY'RE
WORKING IN NURSING HOMES AND SO
ARE HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN AND THEREFORE-
THE CHAPLAIN OFFICE. FIGURING
OF WAY TO GET THE HELL THAT
THEY NEED TO GET GROCERY.
ALMOST ALL ASK TO BEAR DAILY
THEIR MONTHLY BUDGETS- AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED AT FIFTY
INVESTMENT HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC MULTIPLIER OF ONE
POINT FONG. IN ADDITION TO THAT
THEY ARE NEARLY A HUNDRED JOBS
FOR EVERY TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN INCREASED ACCESS P. PAYMENT.
AND NEARLY A MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE AND LOCAL TAX REVENUE.
MOST IMPORTANTLY IT WILL
SUPPORT THE DIGNITY AND EQUITY
OF OUR AGING POPULATION AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. MOST
WHO HAVE EITHER WORKED OUTSIDE
THE HOME FOR A SIGNIFICANT PART
OF THEIR LIVES OR CARED FOR
THEIR FAMILY OR BOTH. AND MOST
OF WHOM ARE WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND YOU HAVE A- TO
EXPERTS IN A- POLICY. BUT I AM
I THE FEAR OF OUR INCOME SO.
PLEASE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
CRYING ACCESS PM ABOUT OUR
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANKS COMMENT
COMES FROM ANGIE SHORTS PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO HELLO IN THE
SHORT BY PRESIDENT OF COFFEE.
THANK YOU FOR BY PRESIDENT OF
QUALITY IN ADVOCACY FOR THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHT
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE REMARKS OF THE
PANELISTS PARTICULARLY DIRECTOR
JOHN FAN AND MR MCAFEE BOOK OF
ALL THE WORK BUT IT'S BEEN DONE
TO ENSURE ONGOING STABILITY IN
SUPPORT FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE. WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE ACTIONS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD TAKEN OF THE
GOVERNOR TAKEN FOR EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AND TO THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND FLEXIBILITY SUPPORT
OUR STATE FOSTER CHILDREN
IMPORTANT TO THE WORKING
FOCUSING ON THE NEEDS OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CARING QUE
EN AND OUT FOR THE CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE. MORE THAN 40% OF
THEM A RELATIVE HEARING FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE WHILE
THEY'RE AT HIGH RISK FOR COPE
WITH THEMSELVES DUE TO THEIR
AGE AND OTHER HEALTH
CONDITIONS. IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN STABILIZING
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE IF CARE
GIVERS RELY ON SUPPORT SERVICES
STABILIZE THE CHILDREN IN THEIR
HOME TO VERIFICATION ALL THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
NEEDS AND TO. ADDRESS THE
EXPERIENCE OF. THANK YOU. ALLEN
DID A LOT BEEN. AND FOOD AND I.
FROM SUPPORT NETWORK IN THE
PART. OF THE CHILDREN. WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT LOSING THE EXIT
TO PASS IN DRIVE OUR FAMILIES
TO THE BRINK WOULD LIKE TO A
MISTER MAC OF COMMON IN THE
NEED TO ENSURE CA THANK THE
FUNDING FOR ARE TENDED. THIS IS
THE NEED TO CONTINUE A MERGER
CARE FUNDING BEYOND THE ON THE
THAT ARE TO BE A BECAUSE JULY
FIRST. CAN WE AGREE THAT IT'S
CRITICAL THAT THE FAMILY URGENT.
SYSTEM BE IMPLEMENTED AN
EXPEDITED MANNER. TO PROVIDE
HIM WITH ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
NAVIGATE THE COUNTY IN
CIRCUMSTANCES. UNSTABLE LIKE
THE CHILDREN IN OUR HOME. AND
WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO
INCREASE THE SUPPORT OUR CARE
GIVERS- TO ADDRESS THAT THE-
TICKET ECONOMIC BURDEN BUT
THEY'RE FACING IN THE- CRIME
FOR TRYING TO CARE FOR.
CHILDREN IN OUR HOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM RYAN SPENCER PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
RANDOM NUMBERS FOR THE HEARING
TODAY- BEEN VERY GOOD TO HEAR
YOUR VOICE IS NEGATIVE FEEDBACK
IN SACRAMENTO- BUT GIVE MONIES
RIGHT SPENT JOHN SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF CHEN OPENED THE
NONPROFIT HEALTH I. P. AND
INNOVATION NONPROFIT THE SPORT
TO EACH ARE SYSTEMS FOR NUMBER
STATEMENT CLINICS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. ONE EXPECT TO
SUPPORT. HEALTH HELP HELP. A
POLICY DOES WE- DURING THE
SPEND DOWN A DIFFICULT ENSURES
MEDIC SERVER PROVIDED TO TELL
HELP A REIMBURSABLE SAME WAY AS
IF THEY WERE PROVIDED IN OFFICE
WILL HOLD FOR REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAKE THIS POLICY
PERMANENT SO MAY CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT THOSE MOST BOBBLE WHO
DEPEND ON THE SAFETY NET
SERVICES PROVIDED. OCEAN ALSO
ENCOURAGES THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE OUR STATE NOW CLINICS
ARE PROVIDED WITH THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO INNOVATE AND
APPOINT TECHNOLOGIES MOST
NOTABLY ECON TALKS PROVIDE
EFFICIENT INCUMBENT OF CARE TO
THE PATIENT DURING AND AFTER
THE SPENT EMIC THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM ANDREW SHAME
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO DOCTOR
ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING IN REALLY PUTTING A
SPOTLIGHT ON BEING A CRITICAL
POINT OF THESE PROGRAMS AND
THEIR FUTURE- I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT AND
QUESTION ABOUT THE FOOD BANKS-
IT IS TRUE THAT THE BANKS ARE
SEEING A SURGE IN THE NEED FOR
EMERGENCY COULD. IN FACT EVEN
HIGHER THAN THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE- UP THE BACK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- AND IT'S PARTICULARLY
IF THE BANKS NEED THE SHELF
STABLE ITEMS AT THE STATE THIS
AFTER COULD BOXES- HAVE
PROVIDED THIS IS BECAUSE AS
THOSE OF US WHO CAN AFFORD TO
SHOP. ARE GOING TO THE GROCERY
STORE- THERE'S A DECLINING IN
THE NATION'S OF THOSE WHO THEN
WE NEED THE PEANUT BUTTER THE
RIGHT THE BEING THE PASTA ON
THOSE BASIC IN ORDER TO KEEP
CALLED HEALTHY AND OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL- TO PREVENT A
SECONDARY- A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY OF HUNGER DURING THIS
CRISIS APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
QUESTION THERE HELLO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE GOVERNOR-
FOR ACTING QUICKLY WITH THE
INITIAL FUNDING IN THIS POPULAR
MAKE A REAL DIFFERENCE IN THE
FIELD IT'S REALLY JUST A MATTER
OF SUSTAIN. ABOUT YEAH WANT.
THEN AND THEN LATER MISTER MARK
UP THE BUT TO ABILITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE BUT ALSO
AS WE CAN MAKE A POINT ABOUT
THE NEED TO CONTINUE THEM- TO
CODIFY THEM AND REALLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
DONE- DON'T EXPIRE BUT CONTINUE
TO SERVE OUR FAMILIES AND
COUNTIES- AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
TO THIS CRISIS. FINALLY AT MY
COLLEGE COUNTY SPOKE TO THE
DESPERATE NEED TO ADDRESS
POVERTY AND BASIC NEEDS AMONGST
THOSE RECEIVING SSI THE MOST
VULNERABLE OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR. X. COMMENT
CONFIRM AND MAKE CLOUT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS SAM
MCCLOUD I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
PEACH REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY SAFETY NET HOSPITALS
WORK 86% OF THEIR PATIENTS
TREATED ARE FUNDED BY
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
STATE'S MEDICAL PROGRAM. THE P.
HOSPITALS IN PLOY OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WELL PAID WORKERS AND
ARE OFTEN THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS
IN THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
AS NOTED BY A RECENT LA TIMES
ARTICLE SAFETY NET HOSPITALS
HAVE BEENDISADVANTAGED BY THE
DISTRIBUTION FORMULA OF THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS. FROM COPE WITH
RELIEF BECAUSE THE THING THAT
HOSPITALS THAT DO NOT CARE FOR
THE UNINSURED OR LOW INCOME
FORMER REBEL POPULATION. AS A
RESULT THE SAFETY NET HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISADVANTAGED BY THE CODE RED
EMERGENCY. A COUPLE OF THE
SOLUTIONS ARE AVAILABLE THAT
HAVE YET TO BE MENTIONED. FIRST
THE STATE IS TAKING MORE THAN
1100% OF THE NET BENEFIT FROM
HOSPITALS IN THE QUALITY
ASSURANCE FEET. THIS AMOUNT TO
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
IN CASH BEING TAKEN FROM
HOSPITALS BECAUSE OF THE TIMING
ISSUE WE ARENOT PROPOSING THE
STATE FOR GO IT. STATUTORILY
ENTITLED SHARE WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT IT TAKES THE
AGREED UPON 24% INSTEAD OF RENT
LOADING AT A HUNDRED AND 12%
THAT'S THE WAY IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
TOP. SECOND THE COMMUNITY
SAFETY NET HOSPITALS ARE ASKING
FOR AN INCREASE OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO MEDI CAL. TO
INCLUDE A NEW SOCIO ECONOMIC
ADJUSTMENT ON IT MEDI CAL FEE
FOR SERVICE PAYMENTS. TO HELP
PAY FOR THE SOCIAL COMPLEXITY
THAT RESULTS FROM TREATING A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
STATE HOMELESS AND JOBLESS
POPULATION. CURRENT MEDICAL
PAYMENTS ACCOUNT FOR MEDI CAL
MEDICAL COMPLEXITY BUT THEY DO
NOT ACCOUNT FOR THE SOCIAL
COMPLEXITY NOR HAS THE BASE
RATE. BEEN INCREASED INEIGHT
YEARS DESPITE THE GROWING
NUMBER OF SOCIALLY COMPLEX
PATIENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HEARING TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT OF
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL SAFETY NET
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU FURTHER. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
HECTOR LASSEN CENA PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS A GOO
LESSON CHAIR WITH KENTUCKY
HOUSE ADVOCATES WE ARE
COALITION OF DIRECTLY IMPACTED
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
ADVOCATING ON THE INTERSECTION
OF IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND HEALTH
JUSTICE WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR LEADING THIS CONVERSATION
AND HOSTING THAT HEARING AND
THIS MUCH IN GOOD TIME WE'RE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS THAT
ARE WITHOUT COVERAGE. AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE ARE EXCLUDED FROM
MACHINE FINANCIAL SUPPORT- AND
MANY SERVICE SAYS. AND WE ARE
NOT IN USE ARTICLE THAT DURING
THIS TIME WE ARE CALLING TO
EXPRESS THE URGENCY FOR FULL
SCOPE MEDI CAL FOR INDUCTION
SENIORS IT'S REALLY BEEN HEART
WARMING TO HEAR PEOPLE ON THIS
HEARING BRINGING ATTENTION TO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED AN ELDERLY
POPULATION- CONSIDERING THE CO
THAT NECK WE ARE ASKING FOR THE
LINE ITEM TO BE EXPEDITED SO
THAT UNDOCUMENTED SHE CAN
RECEIVE THIS MUCH. CARE ACT
POSSIBLE THANK. YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER. I
THOUGHT I RECKON THE NAY HECTO
YOU ARE IN A DOCUMENT I
RECENTLY WALKED CALLED COVERAGE
AND- JUST WANTED TO SAY HELLO
SO. THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR SUPPORT AND PARTNERSHIP.
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
BENJAMIN TRANSLATE I HAD. THANK
YOU DOCTOR EVELYN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF ENTRENCHED ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK REGARDING
THAT THE HALT YOU MUST
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT ARE
UNLIKELY TO COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS OR- WILL BY MENTAL
HEALTH CARE IN HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITY ACTUALLY. THESE ARE
TRUSTED PROVIDERS WHAT THE
SKILLS AND EXPERTISE TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HIGH LEVELS OF
STRESS. DURING THE PANDEMIC.
SIMILARLY WE MUST ENSURE THAT
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
APPROPRIATE DENTAL WRITERS ARE
SUPPORTED ESPECIALLY GIVEN HOW
FEW THERE ARE EIGHT. DATA
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE BOARD ARTS
DIRECTING THE STRAIN OF CALL
THE NINETEEN WE MUST ENSURE
THAT PROVIDERS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE OPENED THEIR
PRACTICES AND THE COMMUNITY
THEY NEED THE SERVICES ABOUT.
WE UNDERSTAND IT DIFFICULT
FINANCIAL POSITION ALL
PROVIDERS ARE FACING AS A
RESULT OF COVER NINETEEN AND
SUPPORT STATE ACTORS TO ADDRESS
THE CHALLENGES. WITH PARTICULAR
EMPHASIS AROUND PROVIDERS WHO
SERVE A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF
MEDICAL PATIENTS. AND
PRESERVATION OF CRITICAL
THINKING THAT PROGRAMS SUCH AS
ADULT DENTAL BUT IF. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
COMMONSENSE FROM RONALD GOLDMAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
TODAY'S HEARING RONALD COLMAN
HERE ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION THIS YEAR IF YOU
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND ALSO
FOLLOW UP IN WRITING WE KNOW
DIFFICULT DECISIONS RELATED TO
THE BUDGET ARE COMING SOON BUT
WE DO THINK THAT INVESTMENT IN
THE SAFETY NET WILL BE CRUCIAL
TO OUR RECOVERY. WE ARE THIS
COMMITTEE FOR PRIORITIZE
COVERAGE AS AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC. FIRST
AND FOREMOST WE NEED TO EXPAND
FULL SCOPE MEDIC OUT TO BE
UNDOCUMENTED. BUT WE APPRECIATE
THAT THOSE LOCKED OUT OF
COVERAGE WILL HAVE ACTIVE TO
TESTING AND TREATMENT FOR KOBE
NINETEEN. WE URGE YOU TO ACT ON
MAKING SURE ALL UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS. GAIN ACCESS TO FULL
SCOPE MEDI CAL. GIVEN THE
CRISIS WE URGE YOUR FIRE TYPE
SENIORS UNDOCUMENTED ELDERS FOR
COVERAGE. WE KNOW THAT SENIOR
HIGH RISK THE THING IS THE
COMING FROM COMMUNITIES WITH
HIGH RATES OF UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS LIKE ASTHMA AND
DIABETES THAT MAKE THEM MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE WORKS OF
PRACTICAL BUT NINETEEN. USING
YOUR DESERVE TO GET THE CARE
THAT THEY CAN- TO MANAGE THESE
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS BEFORE
POTENTIALLY BEING INFECTED
RECOVERED NINETEEN OR ANY OTHER
ILLNESS LIKE PNEUMONIA OR THE
FLU OR LUNG CANCER. WHICH THEY
CAN'T GET ANY TREATMENT FOR BUT
CAN ALSO PUT THEM AT RISK OF
DEATH. PRIMARY AND PREVENTIVE
CARE IS KEY. WE ALSO CAN'T
FORGET THAT THIS IS A FAMILY
ECONOMIC SECURITY ISSUES.
FAMILIES ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE BURDENED WITH PAYING A
SIRIUS. ANNOUNCED A MEDICAL GET
IN MEDICAL BILLS FOR UNINSURED
LOVED ONES THESE ARE THE VERY
SAME FAMILY MEMBERS AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR LARGELY WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEARING THE
NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. BUT ALSO THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT FROM JOB LOSS WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE THIS A
PRIORITY. ADDITIONALLY DURING
THE LAST TWO MONTHS CALIFORNIA
SO MASTER SPIKES AND EMPLOYMENT
AND PROJECTIONS- THAT
SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE OF THESE
CALIFORNIANS WILL LOSE.
EMPLOYER BASED COVERAGE AND YOU
COULD SEE COVERAGE THROUGH
MEDICAID OUR COVER CALIFORNIA.
WELL THE AP A PROVIDE FEDERALLY
FUNDED AFFORDABILITY IF THEY
THINK MANY CALIFORNIANS IN THE
TÁI COSTS DATING IN THIS
ECONOMIC CLIMATE ARE STILL
GOING TO FIND IT. VERY
DIFFICULT TO BUY COVERAGE
MILLION MANY THAT ARE FALLING
OFF OF EMPLOYER BASED COVERAGE
ARE REALLY JUST GONNA
EXPERIENCE STICKER SHOCK AT
HAVING TO BUY COVERAGE I HAVE
AN INDIVIDUAL WITHOUT ANY-
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANT- MANY
CALIFORNIANS WE DID RECEIVE
SUBSIDIES. JUST LAST YEAR
HOWEVER SIGNIFICANT GAPS DO
STILL REMAINING- AND-
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELTES TO
BOTH PREMIUMS AND COST SHARING
INCLUDING COPAYS AND
DEDUCTIBLES THERE'S MORE WE
HOPE TO DO. SO WE DO HOPE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR AND WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS. TO HELP.
SUFFERING MUCH. THANK YOUS.
SELECT COMMENT COMES LEANDRO
CLASS RB PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
WE CAN THE UNDER. THANK YOU
THIS AS WE HONOR QUIRK HARVEY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES REPRESENTING MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER CBO'S PROVIDING
SERVICES TO INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE LIFESPAN WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FOCUS OF THIS
HEARING AND ALSO APPRECIATE
GATE YEAH FOR ALL THEY'RE DOING
TO HELP PRESERVE THE SAFETY NOT
AND WE AGREE WITH THE IMPACT ON
VARIOUS SYSTEM HOWEVER. WANT TO
BRING ATTENTION TO THE NEEDS
THAT THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS OUR MEMBERS TO SERVE
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND-
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE AND NO AGENCIES AFTER THIS
TRANSITION QUICKLY TO TELL HELP
THE IMPACT ON THE AGENCIES AND
CLIENTS HAVE BEEN DEVASTATING
FOR MANY WE THIRTY EIGHT THEM
RECENTLY AND FOUND THAT 89%
LACKED NECESSARY PP. 52% OF
AGENCIES ARE SERVING FEWER
CLIENT 32% HAVE ALREADY
INSTITUTED FURLOUGHS AND LAYING
OFF STAFF IT'S REALLY-
IMPACTING OUR HEATING UP WITH
SOME INCREDIBLY AND IN ADDITION
THERE'S BEEN ISSUED IDEA FOR
PROVIDING HERE AND CONGREGATE
CARE SETTINGS TRACKING CLIENTS
WHO ARE HOMELESS OR DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY AND CAN'T
TAKE. ADVANTAGE OF TELEHEALTH
AND EVERYONE HAVING CAST CASH
FLOW ISSUE UP WITH HIGHLIGHTED
IN PANEL ONE ISSUES WILL
CONTINUE AND WE NEED CONTINUE
KERR ABILITY AND FUNDING DURING
AND AFTER THE PANDEMIC WE
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION THAT
DATE YEAH OTHERS PAY TO THE
FACT HELP WORK. YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM. AND OUR NEXT COMIC FROM
MANDY KILLER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HAS MANDATE TAYLOR ALLY
CALIFORNIA ALL GVG Q. HELP
IMPLEMENT SERVICE WITH NETWORK
AND WE JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE MEMBERS WHO WERE
ABLE TO JOIN OUR CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW COLD IT NINETEEN IS
IMPACTING BUT ALL LGBT Q. A. B.
AND IN ORDER TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING
DISPARITIES CAUSED OR
EXACERBATED BY KILLED AT
NINETEEN. AND ARE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING LGBTQ
COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AT PEOPLE AND
RURAL AREA AT FOR ASKING THAT
THE COMMITTEE ENSURE THAT DATA
IS COLLECTED AND FUNDING AND
PROGRAMS ARE PRIORITIZE FOR
THESE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE- THANK YOU MA'AM. IN ONE
MOMENT FINANCE COMMON. NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM KATIE LAYTON
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR ARAMBULA AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
KATIE LATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION WHICH REPRESENTS OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PEDIATRIC
SUB SPECIALISTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
TODAY CALIFORNIA HAS
DEMONSTRATED SHORTAGES AT
PEDIATRIC SUBSPECIALTY
PHYSICIANS EVEN DURING STRONG
ECONOMIC TIME. WITH THAT AND
THEN MAKE THOUGH ARE. AND THEN
HE SHOULD VOLUME ABOUT TWO
SEVENTY. WHICH HAVE DRASTICALLY
IMPACTED REVENUE AND JEOPARDIZE
THEIR VIABILITY WE'RE ALSO
SEEING AFFECTS OTHER PROVIDERS
HAVE SPOKEN HERE INCLUDING
PHOTOS. HEY REDUCTION AND EVEN
THE PREMATURE RETIREMENT AT
SOME OLDER POSITION. THIS AND
OTHER FACTORS RIGHT NEAR THE
ABILITY OF QUALITY PEDIATRIC
SPECIALTY CARE. FUTURE I WE
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS AT THIS PM
EIGHT AND THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ADDRESSING THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE FUTURE I TO ENSURE ABOUT
ALL CALIFORNIANS GETTING
MEDICALLY FRAGILE CHILDREN.
HAVE ACCESS TO THE CARE THEY
NEED THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
GREAT SEEING THAT THERE IS NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT AND THAT
THERE IS NO ONE HERE PRESENTS
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. I WILL
END WITH JUST A CLOSING THOUGHT
IF I CAN. AND IT'S THE FIRST
STEP THIS IS BEEN BOTH A RICH
AND EDUCATIONAL DAY TODAY BUT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE IF
IT WERE NOT FOR QUALITY STAFF
WHO ALWAYS MAKES THESE MORE
ENJOYABLE. AND SO I WANTED TO
THANK NICOLE VASQUEZ ANDREA
MARGOLIS ON A MELENDEZ RUSSO
OFF MAD AND THE NEWEST MEMBER
OF TEAM ARAMBULA DR KAREN
JONES. WHO ALL OF MADE TODAY A
LITTLE MORE MANAGEABLE. BUT WE
HELD TODAY BECAUSE IN TEN DAYS
TIME WE WILL RECEIVE THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION. AND IT
WILL BE UPDATED TO ALIGN TO OUR
NEW REALITY SINCE THIS TERRIBLE
VIRUS HAS BECOME A PART OF OUR
LIVES. WHAT WE'VE HEARD TODAY
ARE SO MANY NEEDS GROWING AN
INTENSIFYING DURING OUR CRISIS.
AND WE ARE FACING AN AWFUL
DILEMMA. FOR OUR BUDGET WHICH
IS THAT EXACTLY AT THE TIME
THAT WE NEED OUR SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES THE MOST WE WILL BE
FACING REDUCED RESOURCES. I DO
REMAIN HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL
FIND OUR WAY THROUGH THIS SO
THAT WE CAN AVOID HARM TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS.
WE MUST FIND THESE AVENUES BOTH
CREATIVELY AND EXPEDITIOUSLY.
NOW EVEN IN THIS TIME OF CRISIS
WE NEED TO HOLD TO OUR VALUES.
DOES THAT OUR FAMILY FIRST
CHILDREN FIRST AND CALIFORNIA
STRONG IDEALS. I WILL DO MY
BEST TO LEAD AT THIS TIME AND I
KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUES WILL
JOIN ME IN THIS FIGHT. OUR
PRINCIPLES OUR VALUE SYSTEM AND
OUR CHARACTER MUST LEAD AND
THESE DAUNTING CIRCUMSTANCES. I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO HAS
PARTICIPATED TODAY AND PLEASE
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH US AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. TO TOWARDS OUR
MID JUNE CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO PASS A
BALANCED BUDGET. WE WILL WORK
HARD TO SERVE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC ALL OF YOU WHO ARE OUR
BOSSES. I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN AND WISH EVERYONE A GOOD
NIGHT ON TODAY'S STAR WARS DAY
MAY THE FOURTH BE WITH YOU.
THAT CLOSES TODAY SOMEONE HERE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT DOES
CONCLUDE OUR CONFERENCE FOR
TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND FOR USING
EIGHTEEN ANTI YOU MAY NOW
DISCONNECT.